I DO
NOT THINK WE LONGER THAN TWENTY.
SHE SAID SHE NOTHING TO CANCEL
THEY SET SO. I REALLY AREN'T
FERRANTE YEAH OKAY GOOD MORNING
WELCOME EVERYBODY THIS IS THAT.
HEARING THIS MORNING AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION FINANCE- JOINED BY A
MEMBER OF THE CABINET COMMITTEE
AS WELL AS THE CHAIR OF THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE- CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON ON
HEALTH DR RAMBLING ALSO I
MENTIONED EARLIER- MISTER
DONALD AS WELL AS DOING HERE
TODAY BY. ELORANTA GONZALES
WHOSE ARE CHAIR OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
ALL OF US ARE VERY INTERESTED
IN THE TOPIC TODAY- BECAUSE WE
HAVE CONSTITUENTS BUT ALSO I
THINK LOOKING AROUND HERE WE
ALL HAVE KIDS IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM SO. WE LIKE SIX
MILLION CALIFORNIA ARE OUT THE
SAME QUESTION. WHAT IS THE
STATE'S ROLE IN HELPING FOR
HELPING REOPEN ARE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA- IN
THE INTERIM FOCUSING ON PUBLIC
HEALTH MAKING SURE WE HAVE
CORRECT PROTOCOLS WHILE GO
THROUGH THIS THE LEARN PROCESS
SO TODAY'S HEARING IS HAS A HAS
A FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON THE
STATE'S ROLE IN SUPPORTING
SUPPORTING THE SAFER YOU
OPENING OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THE HEARING TODAY IS OT ABOUT
DISTANCE LEARNING IN THE ISSUES
FOCUSED ON THAT- THOSE ARE DEEP
CRITICAL CONVERSATIONS- ON THE
ON THEIR OWN WE SAID WE RESPECT
DOESN'T SUPPORT THOSE BUT TODAY
I'M GONNA ASK MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE PANELISTS TO BE LASER
FOCUSED ON THE QUOTE ON THIS
QUESTION WHAT IS THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY ENSURING THE
SAFE RETURN OF OUR STUDENTS TO
AT LEAST SOME IN PERSON
ENGAGEMENT. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC SOME DISTRICTS HAVE
STARTED SOME WILL START THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS LIKE WE HEARD
HERE LOCALLY IN SACRAMENTO SOME
OF OUR DISTRICTS HAVE ANNOUNCED
THAT IF THINGS ARE GOING
ACCORDINGLY- AS THEY ARE NOW
WITH WITH THE NUMBERS ACCOUNTS
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- WE CAN'T JUST RE
OPEN WE MAKE SURE IT'S SAFE WE
HAVE TO. BALANCE BOTH AT THE
FOCUS ON SOCIAL AND DEVELOPMENT
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS AND
PREVENTING COMMUNITY SPREAD-
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
FINAL BUDGET IN AUGUST. WE
ASSUME THAT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. WITH GOING TO BE
THE DEEP. MODE OF CONDUCT EVANS.
FOR MOST OF THE STUDENTS FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE ALL KNOW
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING DUE TO THE
SECOND WAVE. OF THE CLUB IN
NINETEEN AND AT THIS POINT
FORTY A FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
ARE. NOW ALLOWED TO REOPEN A
WITHOUT A WAIVER. AND MANY OF
THESE ARE LOCAL DECISIONS. BUT
WE WANT TO FOCUS AGAIN TODAY
WHAT'S THE STATE ROLE IN
PROVIDING. OVERSIGHT FOR THIS
AS WELL AS AN I HAVE EQUITY
WITH A FOCUS ON BALANCING THE
SAFETY AND IN PERSON EDUCATION.
NEEDS VERY CAREFULLY I WILL
NOTE THAT THERE IS ABOUT TEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN SACRAMENTO
JUST REPORTD TWO DAYS AGO.
THAT FIVE ARE ARE REAL OPENING
ALREADY AND THOSE ARE ALL
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH- THE MOST
AFFLUENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
SO. WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE HOW THESE ARE HAPPENING
ACROSS- THAT THE STATE AS WELL.
WE DO HAVE OF COURSE-
INTERESTING HEARING PROTOCOLS
TODAY BECAUSE OF. THE COVER
NINETEEN- PANDEMIC AND PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION SAID JUST A FEW
NOTES FOR THE RECORD. THESE ARE
SOME DIRECTIONS FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION- FOR PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM- I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
HERE RIGHT NOW BUT WE'RE IN
FORTY TWO OH TWO IN THE ROOM
THE STATE CAPITOL. WE MUST HAVE
PHYSICALLY DISTANT- POLICIES IN
PLACE TODAY- MAKE SURE YOU KEEP
YOUR DISTANCE SAYING IF YOU'D
LIKE TO. COMMENT LATER ON WE'LL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS FROM FROM
THE SERGEANTS- WE HAVE THE
PANELISTS. AS WELL AS THE L. A.
L. APPEARING REMOTELY- USING-
HER TECH DOT TECHNOLOGY SET UP
BY THE ASSEMBLY. AND WE HAVE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY LOCATIONS IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN DIEGO.
THERE WON'T BE ANY VOTES TODAY
THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING- WE ALL. WE IN ADDITION
WE HAVE- AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PUBLIC TO COMMENT- VIA OUR-
OUR- INTERNET AND EMAIL. GO TO
OUR WEBSITE WE'RE CERTAINLY YOU
CAN EMAIL US DIRECTLY AT BUDGET
SUB TO ASM THAT CA DOT GOP.
AGAIN WE HAVE WE WANT THIS TO
BE VERY CONVERSATIONAL TODAY WE
HAVE TO TWO SETS OF SPEAKERS-
THE FIRST REALLY HAD A STATE
PERSPECTIVES. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LMAO THE PERMANENT
EDUCATION. DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- THE SECOND POP PANEL
WILL BE PRACTITIONERS FROM
AROUND THE STATE- FROM SAN
DIEGO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION FROM OUR LOCAL
TEACHERS HERE THE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION SAN JUAN UNIFIED-
WE HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY AT OF
PEDIATRICS AS WELL AS A- EQUITY
ADVOCATE FOR THAT. SAID TRUST
WEST NOT SO WITH THAT WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THE FOR- PANELISTS
IN THE WILL WILL ALLOW WILL
HAVE A MEMBER ENGAGEMENT AFTER
THE FIRST FOUR FROM THE STATE'S
PERSPECTIVE WE'RE GONNA ASK THE
L. A. O. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF AT. AND PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO GO FIRST AND
WE'RE GOING TO- ON THAT BEGAN
WITH THE- WITH THE ELLIOTT
BEFORE THAT ALSO WANTED TO
INTRODUCE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TILTING YOUR CHAMBER BUDGET
COMMITTEE. ALSO JOINING US HERE
TODAY NOTED CHAIRMAN TANG THAT
SPELL THE MEMBERS YOU'RE
INTERESTED FOR CONSTITUENTS WE
ALL ALSO HAVE KIDS IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AT HOME SO WE
KNOW THIS ISSUE. A VERY VERY
WELL BUT BEFORE WE BEGIN ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS LIKE
O. SAY ANYTHING. WE WENT TO
TAKE THE ROLE YES WE TAKE THEIR
OFFERS. MCCARTY GALLAGHER.
LIMON MEDINA PRESIDENT
O'DONNELL YOUR- OKAY THAT'S THE
ROLE FOR COURSE FOR THE BUDGET
STEP TWO WE HAVE THREE
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS JOINING US
FOR THE DAY AS GUEST OF THE
COMMITTEE NOT SO WITH THAT
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE FIRST-
PANEL WE'RE GONNA START WITH
THE L. A. L. ARE YOU HERE. YES
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS A NEARLY
WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE BEFORE I BEGIN MY
PRESENTATION WOULD IT BE
POSSIBLE TO GET CONFIRMATION
FROM THE MEMBERS THAT YOU CAN
HEAR ME OKAY YES WE CAN AND
JUST SO. YOU CAN HEAR US JUST
JUST REMINDER FOR ALL THE
SPEAKERS ARE ASKING YOU. TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS FIVE MINUTES
PER INDIVIDUAL. FIVE MINUTES
PER INDIVIDUAL THANK YOU. OKAY
I AM JOINED BY- MY TWO
COLLEAGUES FROM THE ALEJO SO
WHEN YOU PICK A COVERS PUBLIC
HEALTH FOR OFFICE AND EDGAR
CABRAL WHO IS THE DEPUTY OF THE
K. TWELVE SECTION. SIR THIS
MORNING WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE STATUS OF
SCHOOL OPENINGS IN THE STATE.
AND SHARE ANY BEST PRACTICES
FOR HOW THE STATE CAN SUPPORT
AS SCHOOLS RE OPENING FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. GENERALLY
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT SCHOOLS
ARE RECEIVING A LOT OF GUIDANCE
ABOUT WHAT TO CONSIDER FOR RE
OPENING. BUT NOT WHAT THEY NEED
TO DO TO REOPEN. FURTHERMORE
HOUSE SEATS CAN BEST SUPPORT
SCHOOL REOPENING AND MITIGATING
KOBE NINETEEN TRANSMISSIONS IN
SCHOOLS. REMAINS LARGELY
UNCLEAR AT OUR USUALLY JUST DUE
TO THE SHORT TIMEFRAME WE'VE
HAD TO OBSERVE OTHER STATES
REOPENING SCHOOLS. I'M BUT WE
WILL PROVIDE SOME POTENTIAL
CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE STATE TO
HELP SCHOOLS NAVIGATE THIS.
UNCHARTED TERRITORY AND WE
PROVIDED A HANDOUT SO EVERYONE
CAN FOLLOW ALONG WITH OUR
PRESENTATION THIS MORNING. THEY
HAND OUT IS ENTITLED RE OPENING
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA. SO JUST
TURNING IT TO THE FIRST PAGE
OF. THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET PACKAGE ENVISIONED
ESSENTIALLY THREE MODES OF
DELIVERY OF THE INSTRUCTIONAL
DELIVERY. WITH SCHOOL SWITCHING
BETWEEN DIFFERENT MODES
DEPENDING ON HOW WIDESPREAD THE
VIRUS AS- FIRST IS IN PERTH
FULL IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
WHICH IS TRADITIONAL LEARNING
WITH TEACHERS AND STUDENTS BACK
IN THE CLASSROOM. SECOND IS
DISTANCE LEARNING WE'RE ALL
LEARNING IS REMOTE AND STUDENTS
LARGELY LEARN FROM HOME. AND
THEN THIRD IS A HYBRID MODEL
WHICH IS A MIX BETWEEN REMOTE
LEARNING AND DISTANCE LEARNING.
AND THIS IS REALLY INTENDED TO
ALLOW FOR PHYSICAL DISTANCING
IT BACK IN THE CLASSROOM FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. AT THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
PACKAGE THAT WAS ADOPTED IN
JUNE REALLY SET THE
EXPECTATIONS FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AS THE DEFAULT. SO
DISTRICTS WERE EXPECTED TO
OFFER IN PERSON INSTRUCTION TO
THE GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE.
TO ALLOW FOR CONTINUITY AND
LEARNING. THEIR BUDGET PACKAGE
ALSO SET REQUIREMENTS FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING. AT THE
BUDGET PACKAGE ALSO SUSPENDED
REQUIREMENTS FOR ANNUAL
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
TO SCHOOLS. AND ALSO ALLOWED AT
SCHOOL IS TO MEET THE MINIMUM
INSTRUCTIONAL DAVID. THROUGH A
COMPANY OF BOTH PERSON LEARNING
AND ADD. LEARNING THE BUDGET
ALSO PROVIDED FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS TO HELP
SCHOOLS- WITH DISTANCE LEARNING
AND SCHOOL RE OPENING. IN
AUGUST TO THE GOVERNOR
ESTABLISHED A FOUR TIER
FRAMEWORK TO HELP GUIDE COUNTY
RE OPENINGS AND IS ALSO
AFFECTED SCHOOL WE OPENINGS SO
THEIR KIDS ARE THE COUNTY'S
CALL FALL INTO ONE OF FOUR
TIERS. PURPLE WHICH IS WHERE
THE VIRAL SPREAD IS MOST
WIDESPREAD READ IT WHICH IS
WHERE THE VIRAL SPREAD IS
SUBSTANTIAL ORANGE WHERE THE
VIRAL SPREAD IS MODERATE AND
YELLOW WHERE THE VIRAL SPREAD
IS MINIMAL. INTO THE TEARS ARE
BASED OFF OF COPING NINETEEN
CASE RATES PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND TESTING
POSITIVITY. SO THERE RE TWO
EXCEPTIONS FOR THIS TIERED
FRAMEWORK FIRST IS THAT SCHOOLS
CAN- BRING BRING BACK SMALL
SCOOPS OF STUDENTS WITH HIGH
NEEDS AND THESE INCLUDE
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND OTHER-
STUDENT SUB GROUPS. AND ALSO
STUDENTS IN KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH GRADE SIX ARE ALLOWED
TO COME BACK THROUGH THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WAIVER
PROCESS SO WITH PUTTING THOSE
TWO EXCEPTIONS ASIDE SCHOOLS
ARE ALLOWED TO REOPEN FOR ALL
STUDENTS ONCE THE COUNTY IS IN
THE RIGHT HERE FOR AT LEAST
FOURTEEN DAYS. AND WHAT ALLOWED
TO RE OPEN THE ULTIMATE
DECISION TO DO SO IS REALLY
LEFT UP TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION IN
THE CASE OF ALTERNATIVE
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND
INDEPENDENTLY OPERATED CHARTER
SCHOOLS BUT WE WON'T NOW EVEN
THOUGH. I SCHOOLS MAY BE
ALLOWED TO OPEN AT THE TIME
THAT IT TAKES TO MAKE THAT
DECISION AND IMPLEMENT THAT RE
OPENING PLANNING TO WORK OUT
THE CONDITIONS OF RE OPENING
LIKELY DO TAKE SOME TIME.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT PAGE. SO
THE STATE NOT COAL DATA. ON
SCHOOLS HAVE REOPENED FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION THIS FIGURE
ON THIS PAGE SHOWS THE SHARE OF
K. TWELVE STUDENTS THAT ARE
LIVING IN COUNTIES- THAT HAVE.
THAT ARE PERMITTED TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS UNDER THE TIER
FRAMEWORK ON THE HORIZONTAL
AXIS ARE THE DATES OF THE STATE
UPDATES TO SCHOOL RE OPENING
STATUS. OVER ALL YOU CAN SEE
THE TREND OVER TIME IS THAT
MORE COUNTIES HAVE BEEN ALLOWED
TO RE OPEN AND MORE STUDENTS
ARE LIVING IN COUNTIES WHERE
THEY'RE PERMITTED TO BE OPEN
SCHOOLS. THIS LARGELY REFLECTS
THE STATE OVER ALL EFFORTS TO
LOWER TRANSMISSION AND CASES OF
COPING NINETEEN. AS OF OCTOBER
NINETEENTH ABOUT HALF OF ALL OF
THE STATE'S K. TWELVE STUDENTS
ARE IN A COUNTY WHERE SCHOOLS
COULD RE OPEN. BUT OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT TO DATE
MAYBE ONLY A FEW DOZEN OR SO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE REOPENED
IN THE STATE AND MOST OF THE
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION UNDER THE HYBRID
MODEL. I'M IN JUST A QUICK NOTE
THE DROP THAT YOU SEE BETWEEN
OCTOBER TWELFTH AND OCTOBER
NINTH NINETEEN IS- RIVERSIDE
COUNTY GOING FROM READ IT BACK
TO PURPLE. I'M MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT PAGE. THE GENERAL WE FIND
THAT SCHOOLS HAVE A PLETHORA OF
GUIDANCE FROM VARIOUS ENTITIES
AT THE STATE LEVEL WE HAVE
GUIDANCE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADD TO THE FEDERAL LEVEL
WE HAVE A GUIDANCE FROM THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION THE CDC. AND THEN AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WE HAVE A
GUIDANCE FROM COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION WORKING WITH THEIR
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS. AND
HOWEVER AS WE SEE ON THE NEXT
PAGE THE GUIDANCE IS NOT ALWAYS
CONSISTENT. LEAVING SCHOOL TO
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS
REGARDING IMPLEMENTATION
DETAILS. TO MOVING ON TO THAT
NEXT PAGE. HERE YOU CAN SEE A
TABLE THAT SHOWS AN EXAMPLE OF
RIGHT. YOU CAN SEE AN EXAMPLE
OF GUIDANCE ON PHYSICAL
DISTANCING THAT'S PROVIDED FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND-
ONE SAMPLE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. SO THE GUIDANCE THAT
YOU CAN SEE ON THE LEFT MOST
COLUMN THE TO FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
ASSIZES MAXIMIZING SPACE
BETWEEN STUDENT DESKS. THIS
INCLUDES ALLOWING- SIX FEATS OF
SIX FEET WORTH OF DISTANCE
BETWEEN TASKS BUT IT ALSO
ALLOWS FOR OTHER OPTIONS TO
CREATE SEPARATION BETWEEN
STUDENTS. THESE INCLUDE
PROVIDING SUB PARTITIONS
BETWEEN DESKS AND ALSO
REARRANGING DESK MINIMIZE FACE
TO FACE CONTACT. AND THEN IN
THAT MIDDLE COLUMN YOU CAN SEE
GUIDANCE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WHICH REALLY
STRETCHES STRESSES THE SIX
SPEED PHYSICAL DISTANCE
OBJECTIVES. AND RECOMMENDS THAT
SCHOOLS ACTUALLY DETERMINE THE
CAMPUS CAPACITY BASED ON THE
SUBJECT IT. AND THEN AT THAT
THE LAST COLUMN IS- GUIDANCE
FROM A SAMPLE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SERVICE CN'T
GUIDANCE STARTS OUT VERY
SIMILAR TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH EXCEPT IN THE
LAST TWO BULLETS WHERE YOU CAN
SEE THAT. WHEN CULPRITS ARE IN
PLACE- THE GUIDANCE ALLOWS FOR
SCHOOLS TO RELAX THE SIX FEET
RECOMMENDATION AND ALLOWS
ESPECIALLY IF IT ALLOWS MORE
STUDENTS- TO BENEFIT FROM IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. SO THIS
GUIDANCE PRIORITIZES FACE
COVERINGS AND STABLE COHORTS
OVER PHYSICAL DISTANCING. AS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE GUIDANCE WE
ALSO CHANGE OVER TIME FOR
INSTANCE IN THE JULY
SEVENTEENTH DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH LETTER ON SCHOOL
REOPENING. THE COUNT THE
DEPARTMENT RECOMMENDED
PERIODICALLY TESTING DISTRICT
AND SCHOOL STAFF. BUT IN AN
UPDATED GUIDANCE RELEASED ON
AUGUST THIRD THE DEPARTMENT
SAID THE ROLE OF ROUTINE
TESTING FOR STAFF AND STUDENTS
IT'S CURRENTLY UNCLEAR. I THINK
THESE ARE JUST EXAMPLES OF HOW
CHALLENGING IT CAN BE FOR
SCHOOLS TO NAVIGATE VARIOUS
GUIDANCE FROM VARIOUS DIFFERENT
ENTITIES. AND HOW TO MAKE SENSE
OF HOW ALL OF THIS APPLY TO
THEM EXPRESSIONISTIC THE
GUIDANCE IS NOT CONSISTENT- SO
ALTHOUGH THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDERS REQUIRES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO COMPLY WITH
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND- LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE. HOW SCHOOLS. REOPEN
AN INTERPRETER EMBLEM IT'S THE
GUIDANCE IS LARGELY LEFT UP TO
DISTRICT. WOULD BE AND THE NEXT
PAGE. SO OFF OF A REVIEW OF THE
LATEST RESEARCH THERE ARE STILL
MANY UNKNOWNS AND THE GUIDANCE
OF BERRIES IT REMAINS UNCLEAR
THE BEST PART WHAT THE BEST
PRACTICES ARE AND HOW STATES
CAN BEST SUPPORT SCHOOLS
REOPENING EVEN WHEN SCHOOLS ARE
ALLOWED TO REOPEN THIS IS
LARGELY DUE TO THE SHORT TIME
FRAME AND LIMITED EVIDENCE WE
HAVE FOR SUCCESSFUL SCHOOL
OPENINGS IN THE UNITED STATES.
HOWEVER AND THERE ARE SOME
ACTIONS THAT THE STATE CAN
CONSIDER TO SUPPORT SCHOOLS
LARGELY THIS IS GEARED TOWARDS
THE STATE STEPPING IN TO FILL
IN ANY POTENTIAL GAPS FIRST
MISTAKE PROVIDE MORE TAILORED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SCHOOLS
I'M RE OPENING PLANS AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE PLANS
THIS INCLUDES ON SITE- VIRTUAL
CONSULTATIONS FROM A STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS. AND
PERHAPS THIS CAN HELP BUILD
CONFIDENCE OF TEACHERS. IT'S
AND STAFF THAT THE SCHOOLS
CANNOT REOPEN SAFELY THAT
DISTRICT THAT THE DISTRICT HAS
PROPER PRECAUTIONS AND MEASURES
IN PLACE TO BOTH MINIMIZE
EXPOSURE AND CONTAIN. POTENTIAL
OUTBREAKS SECONDLY THE STATE
COULD YOU SCHOOL SPECIFIC DATA
TO INFORM DECISIONS STARTING
WITH TRACKING AND REPORTING
COBIT NINETEEN CASES CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF ELEVEN STATES THAT DO
NOT REPORT ANY SCHOOL LEVEL
DATA. THE STATE COULD ALSO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO
SCHOOLS TO CONTAIN OUTBREAK FOR
INSTANCE CASE INVESTIGATION CAN
HELP TO DETERMINE WHETHER A
TRANSMISSION HAPPENS IN THE
SCHOOL OR ELSEWHERE. IN THE
STATE ALSO SUPPORT CONTACT
TRACING DATA INTERPRETATION AND
OTHER RESPONSE MATTERS. LASTLY
THE STATE COULD PROVIDE CLEAR
GUIDANCE ON KOBE NINETEEN
TESTING THIS COULD INCLUDE
SUPPORTING OUTSIDE
COLLABORATIONS THAT ALLOW
SCHOOLS TO DEVELOP TESTING
PLANS AND ACCESS ROUTINE
TESTING. SCHOOLS IN PLACES LIKE
LOS ANGELES AND THE BAY REA
MAY HAVE MORE ACCESS TO
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS AND
HIGHER INSTITUTIONS OF
EDUCATION THAT MAY BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. SUPPORT WITH TESTING
AND ACCESS TO ROUTINE TESTING
FOR OTHER SCHOOLS IN OTHER
AREAS OF THE STATE MAY BE MORE
CHALLENGING TO FIND ACCESS TO
ROUTINE TESTING AND THE SORT OF
SUPPORT. THE STATE COULD ALSO
PROVIDE MORE GUIDANCE ON RAPID
ANTIGEN TESTING AND VACCINES
ONCE THEY BECOME AVAILABLE AND
MORE WIDESPREAD. WE DO NOT
HOWEVER AND THE LAST PAGE THAT
THESE ACTIONS COULD REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING STAFF
AND OTHER RESOURCES AND I THINK
I'LL JUST STOP THERE BUT I'D BE
HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO GET THE FIRST FOUR AND
COME BACK I KNOW I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR YOU. AND NEXT WE
HAVE JESSICA HOLMES WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
JESSICA HOLMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I'M GOING TO GIVE IT
SOME ADDITIONAL BACKGROUND ON
THE EFFORTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF TAKEN THUS
FAR- TO PROVIDE. THAT SUPPORTS
AND RESOURCES TO HELP
CALIFORNIA'S K. TWELVE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS RE OPEN AND I WILL TRY
NOT TO OVERLAP TOO MUCH WITH
THE EXCELLENT REMARKS OF MY- L.
A. O. COLLEAGUES. I'M AND ALSO
MY COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND PUBLIC HEALTH
WILL HAVE SOME MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION TO SHARE- SO I'LL-
TRY TO KEEP MY COMMENTS HIGH
LEVEL. THE ADMINISTRATION IS
MINDFUL THAT SCHOOLS NEED CLEAR
GUIDANCE AND RESOURCES FROM THE
STATE TO HELP THEM RE OPEN.
THESE MUST BE PARTNERED WITH A
BALANCED MIX OF PROGRAMMATIC
AND FISCAL FLEXIBILITY IN
RECOGNITION OF DIVERSE LOCAL
CIRCUMSTANCES AS WELL AS
ACCOUNTABILITY TO ENSURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS ARE BEING SERVED
ESPECIALLY OUR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. AS WE NOTED THE STATE
HAS ALREADY GONE A LONG WAY TO
MEETING THE NEEDS OF SCHOOLS TO
REOPEN SAFELY AND THIS IS
EVIDENCED BY THE MANY THAT
ALREADY HAVE RE OPENED. HOWEVER
YOU RECOGNIZE THAT IN A
CONSTANTLY EVOLVING SITUATION
SUCH AS THE ONE THAT WE'RE IN.
THERE'S ALWAYS MORE TO DO AND
WE'RE WORKING VERY HARD TO MEET
THE NEW CHALLENGES AS THEY
ARISE. TO DATE WE HAVE PROVIDED
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES FOR K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS. TO HELP THEM
ADAPT TO THE CONDITIONS CREATED
BY THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
FIRST WE KEPT FUNDING LEVELS
FOR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS FLAT FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THROUGH
A COMBINATION OF FUNDING HOLD
HARMLESS AND APPORTIONMENT
DEFERRALS. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
SIGNIFICANT GIVEN THAT THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED FIFTY FOUR BILLION
LASSEN REVENUES OVER THE THREE
YEAR PERIOD THAN WAS FIRST
ANTICIPATED. WE ALSO PROVIDED
AN ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
INVESTMENT OF MORE THAN FIVE
POINT THREE BILLION FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
MITIGATE LEARNING LOSS RELATED
TO COPE AT NINETEEN. AND TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS SUPPORTS TO
ADDRESS BARRIERS TO LEARNING.
THESE FUNDS WERE ALLOCATED WITH
EQUITY IN MND AS WE KNOW THAT
THE PANDEMIC AND RELATED
RECESSION OF IMPACTED LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES THE MOST. AND
I'LL STOP HERE FOR A MOMENT
JUST TO MENTION THAT- IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION. THE NUMBER ONE-
FOCUS FOR US HAS REALLY BEEN ON
EQUITY AND THAT IS WHY IT WAS
SO IMPORTANT FOR THE GOVERNOR.
THAT IS FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION AT FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN RESOURCES BE
ALLOCATED IN A WAY. WHERE THE
MOST FUNDING AND RESOURCES WERE
PROVIDED TO OUR LOWEST INCOME
ENGLISH LEARNER FOSTER YOUTH.
OUR STUDENTS. SCHOOLS WERE A
ARE ABLE TO USE THESE FUNDS TO
HELP BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
ADDRESS HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONCERNS. I'M INCREASE LEARNING
SUPPORT SERVICES AND
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME TO CLOSE
LEARNING GAPS RESULTING FROM
DISTANCE LEARNING. AND PROVIDE
WRAPAROUND SUPPORTS INCLUDING
NUTRITION AND MENTAL SERVICES
TO HELP STUDENTS OVERCOME
BARRIERS TO LEARNING. IN
ADDITION THESE FUNDS CAN BE
USED IN A VERY IMPORTANT WORK
NECESSARY TO REOPEN SCHOOLS.
THIS FUNDING WAS AN ADDITION TO
ANOTHER ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WENT TO
TITLE ONE ELIGIBLE SCHOOLS FOR
COVERED NINETEEN RELATED
PURPOSES AS WELL AS A HUNDRED
MILLION PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY COSTS AND SPRING TWENTY
TWENTY. FINALLY THE STATE ALSO
ALLOCATED NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION. TO INCREASE FUNDING
FOR SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAMS FORTY
FIVE MILLION FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICE SUPPORTS FOR HIGH NEED%
STUDENTS. AND SIX MILLION FOR
EDUCATIONAL PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ON HIGH QUALITY
DISTANCE LEARNING AND
ADDRESSING LEARNING LOSS IN
MATHEMATICS SCIENCE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS TEACHER THE
PANDEMIC. FINALLY THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES PROVIDED ALL PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS WITH TWO
MONTHS WORTH OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. TO ASSIST
SCHOOLS AND RE OPENING SAFELY.
THE STATE ALSO OPENED A
STATEWIDE CONTRACT FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY SUPPLIES AVAILABLE
FOR ALL LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO PURCHASE ADDITIONAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY. EQUIPMENT TO
REDUCE COMPETITION AMONG ALLEY
ACE. FURTHER THIS THE STATE IS
WORKING TO DOUBLE CALIFORNIA'S
OVERALL TESTING CAPACITY
ENABLING MANY SCHOOLS TO
BENEFIT FROM STREAMLINED SUPPLY
CHAINS. SPEEDY RESULTS AND
BELOW MARKET RATES FOR PCR
TESTS. LASTLY HUNDRED TWO STATE
DEPARTMENTS DEPLOYED OVER
THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED STATE STAFF
TO SUPPORT LOCAL CONTACT
TRACING EFFORTS INCLUDING AT
SCHOOLS THE 97% OF LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO REPORT THAT THEY
HAVE SUFFICIENT CAPACITY TO
NOTIFY EACH POTENTIAL CONTACT
EACH DAY. IN ADDITION TO ALL
THESE RESOURCES THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED COMPREHENSIVE GUIDANCE
AND BEST PRACTICES FOR SCHOOLS
TO NAVIGATE THEPANDEMIC SAFELY
AND ENSURE THE BEST ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF HOW THEY'RE
LEARNING. IS THAT THE GREEN
MADE THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND CAL OSHA
ISSUED JOINT GUIDANCE ON THE
PRECAUTIONS NECESSARY FOR
SCHOOLS TO RE OPEN REOPEN
SAFELY. FOLLOWED IN JULY BY IS
A DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FRAMEWORK TO HELP GUIDE LOCAL
DECISIONS ABOUT WHEN SCHOOL
SHOULD OPEN AND CLOSE BASED ON
LOCAL LOCAL EPIDEMIOLOGICAL
DATA. FOR COMMUNITIES AT HIGHER
RISK OF CARBON NINETEEN SPREAD
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
PROVIDED A WAIVER OPTION FOR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS. IN GUIDANCE
FOR SERVING SMALL COHORTS OF
STUDENTS. THESE OPTIONS ALLOW
EVEN THE MOST HEAVILY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE TARGETED
SERVICES TO OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS. AND THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE TO LEARNING LOSS
INCLUDING STUDENTS DISABILITIES
ENGLISH LEARNERS STUDENTS AT
RISK FOR NEGLECT OR ABUSE YOUTH
IN FOSTER CAE AND STUDENTS WHO
ARE NOT OTHERWISE ABLE TO
ENGAGE IN DISTANCE LEARNING.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE HAVE ALSO DEVELOPED
GUIDES AND TOOLS FOR SCHOOLS TO
UTILIZE. WHEN PLANNING HOWTO
RETURN TO CAMPUS. FINALLY BOTH
ENTITIES HAVE PUBLISHED
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES AND BEST
PRACTICES FOR DISTANCE LEARNING
TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS ARE
ENGAGED AND ARE RECEIVING THE
BEST POSSIBLE EDUCATION DURING
THIS DIFFICULT TIME. LAST BUT
MOST CERTAINLY NOT LEAST THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
PROVIDED LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES WITH THE ROAD MAP FOR
STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH DURING THE
CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THROUGH THE CREATION OF THE
LEARNING CONTINUITY IN
ATTENDANCE PLAN. THROUGH THIS
PLAN LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
REQUIRED TO WORK WITH OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO DESCRIBE HOW
THEY WOULD PROVIDE CONTINUITY
OF LEARNING DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SPECIFICALLY
CALLING OUT HOW THE L. EA WOULD
ADDRESS DISTANCE LEARNING
LEARNING LOSS. MENTAL HEALTH
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL BEING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT PEOPLE
ENGAGEMENT OUTREACH AND SCHOOL
NUTRITION DURING THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR. LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WERE ALSO
REQUIRED TO OUTLINE THEIR
EXPENDITURES RELATED TO
ADDRESSING THE IMPACTS OF THE
CODED NINETEEN PANDEMIC AS WELL
AS HOW THEY ARE INCREASING OR
IMPROVING SERVICES. FOR OUR
ENGLISH LEARNERS YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS PURSUANT TO THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS OUR
STATE AGENCIES HAVE DONE QUITE
A BIT TO HELP SCHOOLS NAVIGATE
THIS DIFFICULT YEAR. WE
CONTINUE TO MONITOR SCHOOLS TO
IDENTIFY NEEDS AND BARRIERS TO
SERVICES SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE IS
NEEDED. IN ADDITION TO THESE
REAL TIME EFFORTS WE ARE
WORKING HARD ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
ACCURATE FINANCE. WHICH WILL
REFLECT WHAT I BELIEVE OUR
SHARED GOALS OF EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY. COAL CHILD SUPPORT.
ACADEMIC OPPORTUNITY AND THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF STUDENTS
STAFF AND FAMILIES. Q. AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT MIGHT HAVE. OKAY THANK YOU.
READY GO NOW TO STEPHANIE GREG
SIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I BELIEVE YOU ARE VIA
TELEPHONE. YES GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF
THE UBCOMMITTEE CHIEF DEPUTY A
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION STEPHANIE
GREG THANKS THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS HOW THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ARE SUPPORTING OUR
SCHOOLS AND EDUCATORS AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SAFE AND
SUSTAINABLE PLAN FOR SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION. TO CLASSROOM BASED
TEACHING AND LEARNING BY THE
END OF THE LAST ACADEMIC YEAR
IN THE EARLY MONTHS OF THE COVE
IN NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS THIS CD WORKED WITH OUR
MANY PARTNERS AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO DEVELOP STATEWIDE GUIDANCE
FOR THE C. THREE OPENING OF
SCHOOLS. AT THE TIME WE ALL
WERE HOPEFUL THAT OUR STATE
COULD REDUCE INFECTION RATES AT
A LEVEL THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE SAFE RETURN TO CAMPUSES
INSTEAD A SURGEON OUTBREAK
FORCED EDUCATORS TO PIVOT
TURNING OUR FOCUS TO
STRENGTHENING DISTANCE LEARNING
FOR ALL STUDENTS UNTIL WE
FLATTEN THE CURVE IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. SINCE THEN THE CP
HAD DISABILITY TO NUMEROUS
MEETINGS BETWEEN EDUCATION
LEADERS AND HEALTH OFFICIALS IN
EVERY. TO FOSTER CONSISTENT
COMMUNICATION AND UNDERSTANDING
OF THE HEALTH AND SAFETY DATA
NEEDED TO RETURN TO IN PERSON
LEARNING. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ALSO UNVEILED A NEW COUNTY
MONITORING SYSTEM FELT COOL TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHEN IT IS
SAFER TO RE OPEN BASED ON
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION RIGHT.
AND WE AGAIN TURN OUR FOCUS IS
SUPPORTING OUR SCHOOLS WITH THE
SAFE RETURN TO CLASSROOM BASED
INSTRUCTION I THINK WE MUST
TAKE TIME TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
MONUMENTAL JOB OUR TEACHERS AND
EDUCATIONAL LEADERS HAVE DONE
IN THE FALL TO STRENGTHEN
DISTANCE LEARNING AND GO ABOVE
AND BEYOND TO REACH AND MAKE
MEANINGFUL CONNECTIONS WITH
THEIR STUDENTS. AND AS THIS
PANDEMIC HAS EXPOSED AND
EXACERBATED INEQUITIES
THROUGHOUT OUR SOCIETY WE ALL
AGREE THAT A RETURN TO
INSTRUCTION PERSON CAN HELP US
RECONNECT WITH OUR MOST
INTERNAL BOTH STUDENTS ALREADY
ON THE MARGINS. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FROM
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL PERSPECTIVE I
THIS PANDEMIC HAS INCREASED AND
INTENSIFIED THE TRAUMA TOO MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS. I KNOW HOW
MUCH OUR EDUCATORS WANT AND
NEED TO BE BACK AT SCHOOL WHEN
THEIR STUDENTS WITH THEIR
STUDENTS WHEN IT IS SAFE TO DO
SO. THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT
HAS BEEN CLEAR FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC THAT
WE CAN ONLY DEVELOP A
SUCCESSFUL PATHWAY TO RETURN TO
SCHOOL CAMPUSES IF WE ARE
GUIDED BY SAFETY AND SCIENCE
FIRST AND FOREMOST THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY COMPLEX
UNDERTAKING THAT REQUIRES
COLLABORATION A CALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA STAKEHOLDERS.
ESPECIALLY AS WE LEARN MORE
ABOUT A VIRUS THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS BELIEVE WILL BE
WITH US WELL INTO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. I'VE CALIFORNIA MAKES
STRIDES TO REDUCE CARBON
NINETEEN INFECTIONS MOST OF THE
COUNTIES ARE MOVING INTO THE
RED OR LESS RESTRICTIVE TEARS
UNDER THE STATE- PRESS.
CLEARING THE WAY FOR MORE AND
MORE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
COUNTIES CAN OPEN. HOWEVER IT
HAS BECOME CLEAR THAT EVEN WHEN
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION RATES
ARE LOWER A SCHOOL DISTRICT
PREPAREDNESS FOR IN PERSON
LEARNING IS IMPACTED. BY
AVAILABLE RESOURCES TO INVEST
IN NECESSARY MEASURES TO REMAIN
OPEN SAFELY INCLUDING CAT
CASTING PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND FACILITIES
IMPROVEMENTS. FOR INVESTMENT.
THE STATE HAS PROVIDED SCHOOLS
WITH A TWO MONTH SUPPLY OF PP.
BUT SCHOOLS MUST PREPARE TO
REMAIN OPEN FOR THE DURATION OF
A PANDEMIC AND WILL NEED MORE.
TESTING FREQUENCY AT THE LOCAL
DECISION BUT CURRENT CAPACITY
ALLOWED VERY FEW SCHOOLS TO
TEST EMPLOYEES MORE THAN ONCE A
MONTH. IN MANY CASES AT ONCE
EVERY TWO MONTHS IN FACT IN THE
NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL OF MEDICINE
ON OCTOBER TWENTY FIRST JUST
CALLED FOR FREQUENT. PROACTIVE
TESTING AS THE MISSING PIECE OF
SCHOOL RE OPENING AND THE
INCREASING RETAIN SCREENING
USING RAPID CATHOLIC SCHOOLS
SHOULD RANK AMONG OUR MOST
URGENT. NATIONAL PRIORITIES.
THE CURRENT FRAME ALLOW SCHOOL
ABILITY. FOR THE COSTS. BUT
DISTRICT HAVE EXTRA CONCERN
THAT THEIR HEALTH PLAN PREMIUMS
MAY INCREASE PERMANENTLY. IN
THE MEANTIME WE KNOW THERE ARE
MANY DISTRICTS THAT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO REOPEN AT BEGUN
DOING JEFF BACK IN ORANGE
COUNTY IMPOSTER COUNTY FOR
INSTANCE. THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
HAVE BEEN BACK TO SCHOOL IN
MODIFIED OR HYBRID FORMS FOR
WEEKS. MANY OTHER DISTRICTS
SUCH AS THE LOCALLY THE FULL
FROM CURRENT ORBIT CORDOVA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE
TAKING A PHASED IN APPROACH
BEGINNING WITH SMALL COHORT OF
YOUNGER AGE STUDENTS WITH A
FULL RETURN INCLUDING. HIGH
SCHOOL IN JANUARY. ELSEWHERE
MANY OTHER DISTRICTS HAVE
ANNOUNCED PLANS TO CONTINUE
WITH DISTANCE LEARNING AND
TELEVISION YOU WARY TO GIVE
THEM TIME TO WORK THROUGH
FACILITY UPGRADES SAFETY
INVESTMENT. TESTING PROTOCOLS
IMPLANTS FOR ENSURING LEARNING
CONTINUITY. DISTRICT IN
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS WILL ULTIMATELY
DECIDE WHEN AND HOW TO BEST
SERVE THEIR STUDENTS AND HOW TO
DO SO SAFELY. IT HAS NOT BEEN
EASY AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD AND HVE BEEN
SO CREATIVE IN FINDING
SOLUTIONS FOR MOBILE TESTING
VANS TO SCHOOL FIGHT FOR
TEACHERS TO GET TESTED. TO
PUTTING UP OUTDOOR TENTS SO
STUDENTS CAN RECEIVE
INSTRUCTION OUTDOORS.
UNDERSTANDING THAT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ARE AN IMPORTANT DRIVER
OF THE HEALTH AND VITALITY OF
LOCAL COMMUNITIES THE
SUPERINTENDENT HOUSE PULLED
LABOR GROUP. AND MAYOR'S OFFICE
IS FROM SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST CITIES TO SHARE BEST
PRACTICES AND FIND WAYS HOW
CITIES CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
LEVERAGE FUNDS FOR C. FREE
OPENING. WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO
FINALIZE THE TESTING PROTOCOL
THEY CAN HELP MAINTAIN SAFETY
IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL SETTING OVER
THE LONG TERM. LAST THURSDAY
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT ALSO
ANNOUNCED A PARTNERSHIP WITH
GENERAL MOTORS IS COMMITTED TO
DONATE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
COST MATHIS CALIFORNIA'S UNITS.
THE MASS DISTRIBUTION WILL BE
PRIORITIZED TO COMMUNITIES
SHOULD FAMILY A FARMWORKERS
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC. THIS VIDEO CARD.
DISTRICT AND FINDING CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS WITH SEEN MANY
DISTRICTS. THE FIVE THREE
DOLLAR A CARE THAT FUNDS FOR
THIS PURPOSE MANY SCHOOLS PUT
UP TEN TIME OF USE THE FUNDS
PLASTIC GLASS PART. THAT MIGHT
BE USED TO FUND FOR FISCAL
RENTAL IN ORDER TO CREATE AN TO
CREATE SMALLER CLASS SIZE.
LOOKING AHEAD TO THE WEEKS A
MONTH AHEAD. THERE ARE CONCRETE
THINGS THE STATE CAN DO TO
FACILITATE A SAFE AND
SUSTAINABLE TRANSITION TO
CLASSROOM BASED INSTRUCTION.
INCLUDING PROVIDE CLARITY
AROUND TESTING PROTOCOLS AND
FREQUENCIES BASED ON PUBLIC
HEALTH RECOMMENDATIONS AND
CONSIDERING LOCAL AREA.
FIGHTING A FRAMEWORK FOR
TESTING AND TREATING THAT DOES
NOT ADDRESS ONGOING COST TO OUR
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
CONSISTENT TRACKING AND
MONITORING STATEWIDE OF SCHOOL
OUTBREAKS AND TRENDS SO THAT WE
CAN LEARN AND ADAPT FROM THE
EXPERIENCES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WORK FOR THE CD'S
ORGANIZATIONAL CAPACITY TO
PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE TO
EDUCATORS IN AREAS OF DISTANCE
LEARNING HYBRID LEARNING MODELS
EDUCATIONAL TECHNOLOGY SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING AND MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT. THE STUDY
SUPPLY OR REVENUE STREAM TO
ACQUIRE THE NEEDED PP AND
VISIBILITY IMPROVEMENTS TO KEEP
CAMPUSES SAFE OVER THE LONG
TERM. THERE ARE MANY UNKNOWNS
IN THE WEEKS AND MONTHS AHEAD
BUT I AM CERTAIN OF ONE THING
THE RESILIENCY DETERMINATION
AND PERSEVERANCE OF OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL LEADERS TO PUT OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR SAFETY FIRST
AS WE WORK TOGETHER TO RETURN
TO THE CLASSROOM WE HAVE ALL
MISSED SO MUCH. IT IS OUR
COLLECTIVE AND SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY TO WORK TOGETHER
AS WE ARE STRONGER TOGETHER
THANK YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR QUESTIONS AND TODAY'S
DIALOGUE. THANK YOU STEPHANIE.
LAST FOR THIS SECTION WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO. DOCTOR ERICA
PAN THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH I BELIEVE WE HAVE YOU
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. IN ROOM.
ONE TWENTY SIX. GOOD MORNING
CAN YOU ALL HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN'T SEE YOU YET IS THERE YOU
ARE OKAY. GOOD MORNING CHEN
MEMBERS- I AS YOU JUST
MENTIONED UNDER TO ACT UPON AND
THE ACTING STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER. I ALSO WANNA LET YOU
KNOW I'M A PEDIATRIC INFECTIOUS
DISEASE SPECIALIST AND THE
PARENTS OF THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT AND NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART ISSUE. SO A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE HAD A LOT OF
IMPORTANT THINGS SO I'LL TRY TO
AND JUST SKIP OVER THOSE AND
PROVIDES MORE PUBLIC HEALTH
DETAILS FOR YOU THIS MORNING.
AS MENTIONED WE HAVE UNVEILED
THEIR ADMINISTRATIONS UNVEILED
THE BLUEPRINT FOR SAFER KANEMI
AT THE END OF AUGUST. AND WITH
THIS APPROACH WE HAVE MANAGED
TO HAVE A SLOW AND STRINGENT RE
OPENING. THE ALLOWED FOR A SAFE
AND STABLE RE OPENING OF OUR
STATE. AS MANY OTHERS HAVE
MENTIONED WE'RE SEEING
INCREASES AROUND THE COUNTRY
AND AROUND THE WORLD. AND WE
MANAGED TO DO THIS SLOW
INTERNET APPROACH. TO MAINTAIN
STABILITY. SOME OF THE KEY
PRINCIPLES JUST AGAIN TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS WAS MENTIONED
BRIEFLY BEFORE. WE HAVE FOUR
DIFFERENT TIERS RATHER THAN
JUST AN ON OFF. AND THOSE TEARS
HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION. WE USE
AT DIFFERENT METRICS WITH TO-
MEASURE THOSE DIFFERENT TIERS.
AND WE USE CASE RATES TEST
POSITIVITY. AS WAYS OF LOOKING
WHETHER THERE'S WIDESPREAD
TRANSMISSION OR MINIMAL
TRANSMISSION IN THE COMMUNITY.
THE OTHER REALLY IMPORTANT
PRINCIPLE WE WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING WAS IT. ANY COUNTY AS
IT SLOWLY REOPENS NEED TO BE IN
A SPECIFIC TIER FOR AT LEAST
THREE WEEKS. TO SEE STABILITY.
BEFORE IT CAN MOVE FORWARD AND
ALSO DEMONSTRATE THAT THE
COUNTY NEEDS METRICS OF THE
LESS RESTRICTIVE HERE. FOR AT
LEAST TWO WEEKS BEFORE I CAN
MOVE FORWARD TO THE NEXT YEAR
WE ALSO MADE SURE THAT DURING
THESE DIFFERENT TIERS IT WASN'T
AGAIN JUST THAT CERTAIN
BUSINESSES COULD BE OPEN OR
CLOSED. WE GRADUALLY ALLOW MORE
THINGS TO BE INDOORS VERSUS
OUTDOORS AND WITHIN INDOOR
SETTINGS ALLOWING MORE MORE
CAPACITY FOR. THE TEARS AS PART
OF OUR PRINCIPLES. WE ALSO
ADDED A HEALTH EQUITY METRIC
THAT WE- DEFINED- SEVERAL WEEKS
AGO AND THIS IS RALLY AN
IMPORTANT MENTOR TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE WHO ARE MOST IMPACTED BY
THIS PANDEMIC ARE DRESSED IN
ORDER TO MOVE FORWARD AS A
COUNTY. OTHERS ALSO BRIEFLY
MENTIONED AS FAR AS SCHOOL RE
OPENING. OF ONCE A COUNTY IS IN
THE RED TIER FOR AT LEAST
FOURTEEN DAYS SO AGAIN AN EXTRA
LEVEL OF STABILITY AND NOT READ
HERE- THAT IS WHEN SCHOOLS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BE RE OPEN AT ANY
GIVEN COUNTY. AND YOU SAW AN
UPDATE AS OF LAST WEEK AND I'D
SAY AFTER TODAY'S WILL BE AT
LEAST FORTY NINE COUNTIES. IN
OUR STATE OF FIFTY EIGHT
THEY'LL BE ELIGIBLE IN THE RED
DEER. AND ALMOST TWO THIRDS OF
OUR POPULATION WILL BE ABLE TO
OPEN- AS FAR AS OUR BLUEPRINT
AND YOUR TRADEMARK. I ALSO WANT
TO EMPHASIZE A LOT HAS BEEN OF
THE SIZE AROUND- WHAT ARE THE
RESOURCES AND LOCAL. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. IT'S ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT AS A FORMER LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICIAL MYSELF. THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS THERE
SIXTY ONE OF THEM AND
CALIFORNIA. ARE ALL WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR SCHOOLS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND ARE
HELPING EACH OF THESE. SCHOOLS
WITH THE REOPENING PLANS AND
ASSISTANCE. AND ON THAT NOTE
ALSO IS MENTIONED. AS PART OF
OUR RE OPENING FRAMEWORK IN
JULY. WELL WE SAID THAT SCHOOLS
COULD BE ELIGIBLE TO OPEN FOR
IN PERSON OR PERSONAL IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IN THE RED TERROR
AFTER TWO WEEKS. THE SCHOOLS
ARE STILL IN THE PURPLE TERROR.
OR THE WIDESPREAD. COULD ALSO
APPLY TO THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICER FOR A WAIVER FOR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT WOULD THEN GO
THROUGH A SET OF CRITERIA AND
APPROVE THOSE RE OPEN PLANS
THAT THEY WERE SAFE AND THEY
FELT COMFORTABLE WITH THE
RESOURCES. IN THAT COMMUNITY
AND CONSULT WITH. THE STATE
HEALTH DEPARTMENT BEFORE MOVING
FORWARD. AS OF OCTOBER TWO. SIX
WE HAVE OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL LEADERS OF
AND GRANTED ACROSS THE STATE.
AND I ALSO WANTED TO NOTE SO
ALL LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
ARE ALL PROVEN NINETEEN CASES
ARE ACTUALLY REPORTABLE TO
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND IN
OUR SCHOOL GUIDANCE THAT WE
HAVE RELEASED AN UPDATED OVER
TIME SCHOOLS ARE MANDATED TO
REPORT TO LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL WE ARE
ACTUALLY TRACKING THIS AND AS
OF OCTOBER TWENTY FIFTH. WE
ONLY RECORDED TWO SCHOOL
RELATED TOPICS THAT HAVE BEEN
REPORTED TO THE LOCAL
DEPARTMENT AND REPORTED TO THE
STATE HEALTH DEPARTMENT THIS
FALL FOR A TOTAL OF SEVENTEEN
CASES. AND AGAIN THERE'S
UPDATED GUIDANCE THAT IS
ONGOING WE ARE GOING TO- UPDATE
AND EVEN MORE THOROUGH GUIDANCE
FROM THE PRIOR JULY SEVENTEENTH
KIND. BUT IT REALLY OUTLINES
ALREADY WHAT TO DO WHEN THERE'S
A CASE REPORTED IN THE SCHOOL I
WANT TO DO WHEN THERE'S
MULTIPLE CASES- AND IN THE
UPCOMING ITEMS WERE ACTUALLY
GONNA OUTLINED WHAT IS THE ROLE
OF THE SCHOOL WHAT IS THE ROLE
OF THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
WHAT TO DO WHEN A SPECIFIC-
COHORT IS POTENTIALLY EXPOSED
AND WATER CRITERIA FOR CLOSING.
WE ALSO AS MENTIONED EARLIER-
ALLOWED FOR. CODING GUIDANCE
THAT AUTHORIZES SMALL GROUP IN
PERSON SERVICES AND CONTROLLED
SUPERVISED IN INDOOR
ENVIRONMENTS. SUCH AS THOSE
OPERATED BY LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES. AND THAT'S AGAIN
APPLIES TO SCHOOLS THAT CANNOT
REOPEN FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION INCLUDING
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS IN A
JURISDICTION THAT I'VE NOT
RECEIVED A LARGER SCHOOL WAIVER.
AND IN THESE CASES WILL SCHOOL
SETTINGS COHORTS ARE STABLE
GROUPS OF STUDENTS WITH NO MORE
THAN SIXTEEN INDIVIDUALS
TYPICALLY IT'S AROUND WO
ADULTS AND FOURTEEN CHILDREN-
AND THE ELIGIBILITY IS-
STUDENTS WERE MEETING FOR
TARGETED SUPPORT AND
INTERVENTION SERVICES. WELL THE
SCHOOL IS CLOSED IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. IS SPECIALIZED
SERVICES ARE DETERMINED BY THE
ELEAZAR AND CAN INCLUDE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY SERVICES
SPEECH AND LANGUAGE SERVICES
MEDICAL SERVICES. BEHAVIORAL
SERVICES OR OTHER EDUCATIONAL
SUPPORT SERVICES SUCH AS THOSE
RELATED TO ENGLISH LEARNER
STATUS OR INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS OR OTHER
REQUIRED ASSESSMENTS. WE ALSO
WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW AS FAR
AS SCHOOL CLOSER
RECOMMENDATIONS THIS WOULD BE
AN UNUSUAL CIRCUMSTANCES. BUT
THIS IS IN THE JULY SEVENTEENTH
RE OPENING FRAMEWORK THAT COULD
BE BASED ON THE PERCENTAGE OF
TEACHERS OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
STAFF THAT ARE POSITIVE FOR THE
NINETEEN. OR IF THERE ARE
MULTIPLE CASES AND LOCAL CO
HARD A SCHOOL OR AT LEAST 5% OF
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF TEACHERS
STUDENTS THAT ARE. TESTED
WITHIN A FOURTEEN DAY PERIOD.
AND THAT'S 5% BENCHMARK
GENERALLY INCLUDE THE
DENOMINATOR OF BOTH. STUDENTS
AND STAFF. LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS AGAIN CAN ALWAYS
DETERMINE SCHOOL CLOSURES
MARKET FOR OTHER REASONS BASED
ON THEIR LOCAL INVESTIGATION
AND OTHER LOCAL EPIDEMIOLOGICAL
DATA. IF A CONFIRM CODE
NINETEEN INFECTION OCCURS IN A
CLASS THE SCHOOL CAN IDENTIFY
CONTACT AND PORTANTINO EXCLUDED
CONTACTS WHICH MAY INCLUDE AN
ENTIRE COHORT WHICH IS WHY IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. TO ENFORCE
THE COHORT OF COHORTS OF
CHILDREN THAT ARE NOT MIXING.
EVEN WHEN SCHOOLS ARE OPEN FOR
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. WE ALSO
RECOMMEND TESTING OF CONTACTS
AND PURCHASING SYMPTOMATIC
CONTACTS THERE SHOULD ALSO BE
DISINFECTION AND CLEANING OF
KLOSTERMAN PRIMARY SPACES AND
THE SCHOOL COULD POTENTIALLY
REMAIN OPEN IF THERE IS NO ON
MIXING OF COVERT. THERE'S ALSO
ARCADE THAT EACH SCHOOL SITE
SHOULD DESIGNATE A LIAISON A
SCHOOL NURSE APPLICABLE OR
OTHERS WHO CAN HELP COORDINATE
MONITORING AND COMMUNICATIONS
TO LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS. AS WELL
AS THE SCHOOL COMMUNITY.
LIAISON SHOULD MONITOR REPORT
POSITIVE CASES AND CHECK
WHETHER THE SCHOOL APPROACHES
THE 5% THRESHOLD DURING A
FOURTEEN DAY PERIOD. AS FAR AS
CONTACT TRACING RESOURCES. ARE
CALIFORNIA CONNECTED CONTACT
RAISING PROGRAM ISBUILDING
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND THEIR
SCHOOL PARTNERS. ARE CAL
CONNECTED VIRTUAL AGENT CASE
EVERY SERVICE HAS BEEN EXPANDED
TO FACILITATE RAPID
IDENTIFICATION OF SCHOOL
RELATED EXPOSURE EVENTS.
INCLUDING THOSE INVOLVING-
SCHOOL OUTBREAKS OR OTHER
TEAMS. THE NEW SURVEY WILL BE
AVAILABLE ACTUALLY BEGINNING
THIS WEEK. I'VE ALSO BUILT A
USER FRIENDLY PORTAL THAT WILL
LAW SCHOOL AND DISTRICT STAFF
TO SHARE COURT INFORMATION
ABOUT SCHOOL AFFILIATED CASES
AND EXPOSE CONTACTS WITH THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT IN REAL
TIME. THIS PORTAL WILL BE GOING
LIVE ON NOVEMBER FIFTH. BUT
ALSO EXTENSIVE. RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT BY THE CONTACT TRACING
TRAINING COURSE SPECIFICALLY
FOR SCHOOL PARTNERS AND OTHER
LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AND THIS IS
BEING OFFERED THROUGH OUR UCSF
AND UCLA PARTNERS AS PART OF A
CO THE NINETEEN VIRTUAL
TRAINING ACADEMY. WE'RE ALSO
DEVELOPING NEW OPERATING
DISTRIBUTION COURSES FOR
EXPERIENCE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT STAFF WHICH INCLUDES
SKILL BUILDING TRAINING
SPECIFIC TO MANAGING SCHOOL
OUTBREAKS. AND FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS NEEDING ANY DIRECT
SUPPORT WAS SCHOOL OPERATES WE
ARE DEVELOPING STRIKE TEAMS OF
SKILLED DISEASE INVESTIGATORS
WHO CAN BE CALLED ON TO ASSIST
OR BUILDING OUT A ROVING TEAM
OF STATE REDIRECTED
CONTRACTORS. WHO CAN SUPPORT
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
SCHOOLS WITH CONTACT
UNIFICATION RELATED TO SCHOOL
AFFILIATED OUTBREAKS EXPOSURE.
I TESTING TASK FORCE IS ALSO
INCLUDED SCHOOL TESTING IN A
STRATEGIC PLAN INCLUDING
TESTING NEEDS ESTIMATES FOR
SCHOOLS. ADDITIONALLY THE
TESTING TASK FORCES CONTRIBUTED
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE STATE
HEALTH DEPARTMENT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT ABOUT SCHOOL TESTING
GUIDANCE. THIS IS AN EVER
EVOLVING. FIELD AND WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT THE ONE IN FRANCE
AND WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
PARTNERS. GREATNESS WE'RE
ORGANIZING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND SCHOOLS TO
ENSURE THE UTILIZATION OF OUR
STATE LABS THAT IS- OPENING AS
WE SPEAK TO SUPPORT SCHOOLS FOR
TESTING ACCESS CAPACITY. EQUITY
AND PERSISTENT ABILITY. AND
SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY INCLUDED IN
THE INITIAL ROLLOUT OF THE
STATE LAB PRIORITIES. THE
CONFLICT BUT THE WORK OF THE
TESTING TASK FORCE THE
ADMINISTRATION ALONG WITH OUR
STATE BOARD OF THAT AND FROM
EDUCATION THANK AGING A WORKING
GROUP OF PRACTITIONERS. BOTH
FROM LABOR AND MANAGEMENT. AND
THE GOAL OF OUR WORKING GROUP'S
RECEIVE INPUT THAT WILL
MINIMIZE BARRIERS TO BUILDING
TESTING STRATEGIES AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE FOR SCHOOLS. SO IN
CLOSING I WOULD JUST HIGHLIGHT
THAT SCHOOLS ABSOLUTELY. SHOULD
RE OPEN- AND GRADUALLY WHEN
ALLOWED WE WANT TO BALANCE THE
RISKS OF TRANSMISSION IN THE
SCHOOL SETTING WITH THE REST OF
LOSS OF LEARNING AND THE
STRUCTURE FOR. CHILDREN IN
PERSON LEARNING. THEIR EXAMPLES
AROUND THE WORLD AND AROUND THE
COUNTRY OF SUCCESSFUL SCHOOL RE
OPENING WHEN YOU FOLLOW THE KEY
PRINCIPLES OF DISTANCING FACE
COVERINGS. MAINTAINING COVERTS
AND GIVEN ELATION. AND AGAIN WE
HAVE ONGOING AN ONGOING UPDATE
SPECIFIC GUIDANCE FOR SCHOOLS
AND LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
AND AGAIN I MENTIONED THAT
SCHOOLS- PRACTICALLY TWO THIRDS
OF OUR POPULATION IS ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE TO REOPEN SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE HAVE A LARGE
PROPORTION OF OUR STATE AND
ABSOLUTELY OPEN. AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ENGAGING AND- WHAT
IS NEEDED TO CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE THE REOPENING OF THE
SCHOOLS. THANK YOU ARE. THANK
YOU OKAY I KNOW IF WE HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR YOU SPECIFICALLY
TO STAY PUT IN SO THIS OF
COURSE WAS THE FIRST FOUR FROM
THAT THE STATE REALLY
PERSPECTIVE AND WE'RE GONNA GET
TO. SOME OF THE LOCALS AN EVENT
I KNOW I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
FOR EACH OF YOU I KNOW OUR
MEMBERS HERE HAVE A LOT SO THAT
I THINK IS GOING TO BE A LOT OF
ENGAGEMENT RIGHT NOW. I'LL JUST
START OUT WITH WITH ONE
QUESTION FOR EACH OF YOU AND I
WILL GO TO THE OTHERS I MAY
COME BACK UP THE FIRST QUESTION
FOR THE WILL GO BACK. TO L. A.
L. ANY BACK ON. I REQUEST FOR
AMY LEE. YES YES YES CHAIR
RIGHT YES SO I WAS. FIRST WE'RE
ALL INTERESTED IN WHAT
POTENTIAL STATE ACTIONS- THERE
THERE COULD BE ON RE OPENING SO
WHEN YOU OUTLINES YOUR IDEAS
AND PAGE FIVE ARE ARE ARE THEY
REALLY PUBLIC POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES FOR US OR IS IT
RESOURCES IN OTHER WORDS WHAT
WHAT THE ISSUE IS WHEN THESE
DISTRICTS ARE DOING THIS NOW OR
WILL DO IT. IS IT MONEY THEY
NEED TO DO SOME OF THESE THINGS
IS THAT OR IS IT MORE- GUIDANCE
AND CLARIFICATION AND EFFORTS
THAT WE CAN DO FROM THE STATE
TO ASSESS THEM. I THINK
DEPENDING ON WHICH SPECIFIC
ACTION YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT
MIGHT BE A COMBINATION OF ALL
OF THOSE SO FOR THEM SOME OF
THESE- POTENTIAL ACTIONS THEY
ARE MORE RESOURCE HEAVY- THEY
MIGHT INVOLVE SENDING A STATE
STAFF TO SCHOOLS ARE WORKING
WITH SCHOOLS MORE CLOSELY. FOR
SOME OF THEM LIKE COULD BE
TESTING THAT MIGHT ENTAIL MORE-
THE FUNDING. AND SO IT DOES
LARGELY VERY. OKAY SO THIS IS
GOING TO BE MY BECAUSE FOLLOW
UP WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE SECOND BUT FOR YOU. OF
COURSE WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
THE BUDGET YEAR- WE'RE NOT
QUITE HALFWAY DONE. THROUGH THE
BUDGET WE WON'T GO BACK AND
EDIT THE DOCTOR NEXT BUDGETS
WILL NEXT JUNE AND THIS ALL
HAPPENING TODAY TOMORROW THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS. SO WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE STATE SHOULD BE DOING
AND THINKING ABOUT THIS WHETHER
OR NOT. IT'S MONEY WE CURRENTLY
HAVE HERE WE ACTUALLY DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF YOU KNOW THE
TATE BUDGET. OR POTENTIALLY
YOU KNOW WE'LL GET TO IN A
LITTLE BIT. OF POTENTIAL SECOND
ROUND OF FEDERAL MONEY DO YOU
THINK THAT WE NEED TO HAVE YOU
KNOW- ADJUSTMENT IN THE CURRENT
YEAR TO MAKE SURE SCHOOLS. HAVE
WHAT THEY NEED. OR. WHAT OTHER
STEPS WOULD WE TAKE. AND LET ME
ACTUALLY SEND THAT TO MY
COLLEAGUE. EDGAR CABRAL. OKAY
SO IS HERE. YES I'M HERE CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES- EVER
BROUGHT WITH THEM IS THAT OUR
FOCUS YEAH I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE IN PREPARING THESE OPTIONS
WE KIND OF JUST LAID OUT A FEW
OFTHE OPTIONS THAT WE- THOUGHT
WE'RE THANKS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER I DO
THINK IN ANY OF THESE CASES
NONE OF THESE THINGS ARE
NECESSARILY QUICK CAN BE DONE
QUICKLY SO- ANY OF THE THINGS
WOULD REQUIRE TIME AND EFFORT
SO FIRST. IN TERMS OF PROVIDING
MORE SUPPORT FROM STATE- CDPH
YOU WOULD NEED TO GET THE STAFF
NECESSARY TO GO DOWN AND
PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT AND FOR
EXAMPLE TRAIN THEM TO BE READY
TO DO THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING LIKE TESTING IT TAKES
SOME TIME TO ONE FIGURE OUT IF
YOU DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
AND THEN- BE ABLE TO- DEVELOP
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER
ENTITIES SO NONE OF THE THINGS
WE'VE NOT SORT OF THING CAN BE
DONE VERY QUICKLY RIGHT NOW
WITHIN SAY THE NEXT. MONTH OR
TWO SO THAT'S OF THESE COULD BE
PART OF THAT THEY JANUARY
BUDGET CONVERSATION AS WE HAVE
A BETTER SENSE OF WHAT THE
REVENUE. SITUATION LOOKS LIKE.
OKAY THANK YOU LET ME KINDA GO
TO THE PROM TO FIND AND THAT
THAT SIM QUESTION. CAN WE GET
JESSICA. YES HERE WITH US OKAY
SO. WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT IF ANYTHING
AS WE'RE HEARING FROM THOUSAND
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
IN VARIOUS STAGES OF RE OPENING
AND I AND WE DID OF COURSE AS
YOU KNOW IT PUT THE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MONEY IN THE CURRENT
YEAR BUDGET. FOR IN THE ONE
TIME POT TO- TO HELP DISTRICTS
WITH THESE DISTANCE LEARNING
NEEDS AND AS WELL AS POTENTIAL
RE OPENING. YOU KNOW DO YOU
THINK THEY HAVE WHAT THEY NEED.
AND POTENTIALLY YOU KNOW IF WE
HAVE A CHANCE DO YOU THINK THAT
WE WOULD WANT TO LOOK AT. DOING
SOME ADJUSTMENTS IN THE- IN THE
BUDGET YEAR THE CURRENT YEAR
NOT THE BUDGET EXCUSE ME IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. TO HELP DISTRICTS
OUT THERE TODAY. SO THIS JUST%
COMES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
YOU ASK A QUESTION THAT- IS IT
I THINK THE ANSWER IS
CONSTANTLY EVOLVING AS WE AS
THE PANDEMIC PROGRESSES AND WE
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE NEEDS OUT
AND IN THE FIELD. I WOULD SAY
THAT OUR BEST DATA POINT FOR
THE FISCAL NEEDS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- IS THE DATA THAT
WE'RE COLLECTING CURRENTLY ON
THE EXPENDITURE OF THE FIVE
POINT THREE BILLION- FUNDS THAT
WENT OUT- AND THAT'S A MIXTURE
OF FEDERAL FUNDS AS WELL AS-
SOME GENERAL FUND. THE MAJORITY
OF THAT FUNDING IS FEDERAL
CORONAVIRUS REALLY FUN ABOUT
FOUR POINT BILLION OF IT. AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE EXPANDED BY
DECEMBER THIRTIETH THIS YEAR
THAT'S PURSUANT TO FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND SO THE STATE
HAS BEEN. TRACKING VERY
CAREFULLY THE EXPENDITURE OF
THAT FUNDS BY LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES AND AT THIS POINT.
STATEWIDE WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
TRACK A LITTLE BIT LESS OR
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF THOSE
FUNDS BEING EXPENDED. CERTAINLY
WE HAVE TWO MORE MONTHS LEFT TO
THE DECEMBER THIRTIETH DEADLINE
BUT- IT DOES NOT APPEAR THAT
THAT MONEY HAS RUN SHORT YET.
SO WE'RE CURRENTLY TRACKING
THAT RESOURCE WISE IT FISCALLY
RESOURCE WISE WE BELIEVE THAT
SCHOOLS HAVE- WHAT THEY NEED ON
A MACRO LEVEL. AGAIN IT'S HARD
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION AS THE
SITUATION CONTINUES TO CHANGE
WE LEARN. NEW INFORMATION EVERY
DAY BUT WE ARE TRYING TO TRACK
THE FISCAL HEALTH OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS VERY CAREFULLY I
THINK. I'M IN OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH CBO'S GOOD CHIEF BUSINESS
pI'VE HEARD LESS OF A CONCERN
ABOUT THE CURRENT YEAR FUNDING
IN MORE OF A CONCERN ABOUT THE
ON GOING FUNDING GIVEN TO CHECK
POTENTIAL LONG TERM CHANGES IN
ENROLLMENT- SO THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING. YEAH
WELL I GUESS THE OBSERVATION
FOR ME IS THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
LOT THE HUGE NUMBER OF
DISTRICTS THAT ARE FULLY RE
OPENED WE HAVE SOME. AND THE
ONES ARE MENTIONED EARLIER.
THIS AROUND MY AREA HERE IN THE
REGION IN SACRAMENTO THE
SMALLER DISTRICTS THE OUT
LIARS. SO AS YOU GET THE LARGER
DISTRICTS LIKE. THEY'LL GROW
JUST ANNOUNCED IN SAC CITY IN
SAN JUAN THE TO HAVE PROFIT
FIFTY PLUS THOUSAND AND COURSE
ARE NOT LIKE SAN DIEGO DELEO
STATE- YOU KNOW. WE NEED TO
MAKE THE COULD GO REALLY WRONG
REALLY FAST AND SO. WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE AN
HOOPS LIKE SIX MONTHS DOWN THE
LINE AND SO WE HAVE RESOURCES
NOW SO. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE READY AND IF
THAT MEANS DOING A CURRENT YEAR
ADJUSTMENTS AS YOU KNOW WE
DON'T KNOW A LOT OF. MONEY HERE
BUT POTENTIALLY WILL HAVE. A
NEW OPPORTUNITY FOR FEDERAL
CODED TWO POINT NO- STATE
ALLOCATION IN THE COMING WEEKS
WITH THE ELECTION COMING UP. SO
THAT IS A REALITY ONE WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE ASKING
FOR FROM CALIFORNIA IF THAT. IF
THAT MATERIALIZES INTO WHAT WE
COULD DO TO HELP DISTRICTS
RIGHT AWAY. DEALING WITH THE
NEEDS OF OTHER PEOPLE HERE
THIRD CONTACT TRACING. TESTING
RESOURCES FOR VAX VACCINES FOR
ITS STUDENTS IN FACT AND STAFF
AND THE TEACHERS AND SO FORTH.
SO THAT'S JUST TO PUT ON A
HORIZON- I WANTED TO ASK A
COUPLE QUESTIONS NOW FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT. OF HEALTH PERSONNEL
THAT THE OTHER MEMBERS- ENGAGE.
JUST WANT TO ASK A DOCTOR PAN
IS DOWN THERE AND. ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. ABOUT BUT TO A CAN GET.
HER CHICKEN HEAR. OKAY SO DR
PANDA MY QUESTIONS FOR YOU ARE
THAT. WE HAVE SOME DISTRICTS SO
FAR DOING THIS LIGHT ROUTE NOT
LIGHT REAL OPENING BUT AS FAR
AS A TOTAL NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS IT'S LIKE. WHAT
TYPE OF TRENDS OUR OBSERVATIONS
OR FEEDBACK HAVE WE GOTTEN AS
FAR AS HOW IT'S GONE WITH THIS
HYBRID LEARNING WITH THE- NOT
FULL IN PERSON BUT- YEAH-
ADJUSTED IN PERSON. WELL
RESPOND WITH A COUPLE COMMENTS
I THINK IN GENERAL IT MAKES
ABSOLUTE PUBLIC HEALTH SENSE TO
DO THIS IN A PHASE WAY AND A
GRADUAL RE OPENING SO IT MAKES
SENSE TO DO HYBRID IN THE
BEGINNING WORK. SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS ARE
FACING IN THEIR YOUNGEST
CHILDREN FIRST AND THAT WAS
SORT OF THE IDEA BEHIND THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL LABOR AS
WELL. WE WENT WE KNOW BOTH THAT
THE YOUNGER CHILDREN. ARE THE
LEAST LIKELY TO HAVE A SERIOUS
INFECTION LEAST LIKELY TO CARRY
INFECTION- SO THOSE ARE AND
ALSO OF COURSE THE MOST- OFTEN
THE MOST DIFFICULT TO HAVE
DISTANCE LEARNING- AND AS I
MENTIONED YOU KNOW ALL COOKIES
IS A REPORTABLE- WE ARE
TRACKING AND- YOU KNOW ANY
SCHOOL OUTBREAKS HAVE BEEN
REPORTED TO US IN ONLY TWO TO
DATE HAVE BEEN REPORTED TO US
AT THE STATE HEALTH DEPARTMENT
FROM OUR LOCAL DEPARTMENT
COLLEAGUES. I'M AND CAN ONLY A
TOTAL OF SEVENTEEN CASES SO
THAT'S VERY ENCOURAGING
CONSIDERING THE. NUMBER OF
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE ALREADY
STARTED TO RE OPEN. AND THEN AS
FAR AS- WE HAPPENS WHEN THERE
IS BECAUSE INEVITABLY THERE
WILL BE. SOME KIDS OR TEACHERS
TESTING POSITIVE DO WE HAVE ANY
ANY GUIDELINES. AS AS AN
EXAMPLE HERE IN ELK GROVE AND
LOCALLY THIS IS THE FIRST
DISTRICT I SHUT DOWN IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S A MASSIVE
DISTRICTS PROBABLY FIFTEEN
TWENTY MILES WIDE. LITERALLY
THERE WERE TWO HIGH SCHOOL KIDS
ON THE FARM OF THE DISTRICT
THEY WERE FIFTEEN MILES AWAY
FROM. MAJORITY OTHER SCHOOLS
WHO TESTED POSITIVE IN ENTIRE
DISTRICT SHUT DOWN GRANTED THIS
WAS EARLY MARCH WE DIDN'T KNOW.
THE MAGNITUDE OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING WITH THIS ISSUE SO I
THINK YOU KNOW WOULD WE LEARN
AS FAR AS HOW THIS GOES SO.
WHAT TYPE OF ADVICE ARE WE
GIVING AS FAR AS- WHAT THE
POLICIES WOULD BE FOR SCHOOLS
AND CLASSROOMS AND HOW IT WOULD
IMPACT. THE ACTUAL SCHOOL SIRE
THE DIFFERENT DECENT SCHOOLS.
SURE AGAIN CURRENTLY THE
GUIDANCE- FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
CASE IS TO OF COURSE NOTIFY.
THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
WORK THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND DO CONTACT
TRACING. AND DETERMINE WHO IS
ACTUALLY POTENTIALLY BEEN
EXPOSED DURING THE CASES
INFECTIOUS PERIOD. SO THAT VERY
WELL MAY INCLUDE AN ENTIRE
COHORT AND THIS IS WHY THE
PRINCIPLES ABOUT NOT MIXING
COLORS AND HAVING STABLE CARDS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT. IF YOU KNOW
EXACTLY WHO THE STAFF OR
STUDENT HAS HAD CONTACT WITH
AND THE TWO DAYS PRIOR TO
INFECTION AS IN THE LAST. DAYS
PRIOR TO BEING ON THE SCHOOL
CAMPUS. THEN YOU CAN-
QUARANTINE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
YOU CAN TEST THEM FIRST AND
ESPECIALLY ANYBODY IS
SYMPTOMATIC AND THEN QUARANTINE
ANYBODY HAS BEEN EXPOSED. AND
THEN YOU DON'T NEED TO EXCLUDE
ANYONE ELSE FROM THE SCHOOL
CAMPUS AND NOT MONITOR VERY
CLOSELY. AND AGAIN OUR- OF
CURRENT GUIDANCE SAYS THAT YOU
KNOW YOU YOU WOULDN'T REALLY
CONSIDER CLOSING AN ENTIRE
SCHOOL. UNTIL YOU HAD MULTIPLE
CASES AND PROBE. OR MORE THAN
5% OF THE SCHOOL POPULATION SO
YOU KNOW REALLY THAT WOULD BE A
MORE UNUSUAL CIRCUMSTANCE AND
AGAIN WHAT WE HAVE SEEN BOTH-
IN THE STATE AND OTHER YOU KNOW
OTHER SITUATIONS AS SOMETIMES
YOU'LL SEE. YOU KNOW WHEN THERE
IS COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION ON
THE HIGHER LEVELS OF CAN
HENDERSON YOU'RE GONNA SEE.
THAT THE TIMES REFLECTED AND
STUFF OR STUDENTS BUT IF YOU
QUICKLY ISOLATE THEM YOU'D HAVE
TO CONTACT QUARANTINE THE
CONTACT YOU CAN. ABSOLUTELY
PREVENT FURTHER INFECTIONS.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT'S
HELPFUL AND OF COURSE THE YOU
KNOW THE RIGHT COURSE OF
ACTION- NOW WE'LL GET TO OTHER
MEMBERS ARE START WITH ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER CONSULT. FROM LOOKING.
AT WHAT WE WILL NEED I HAVE A
BIT OF A HERE BECAUSE ALTHOUGH
GOT NUMBER TO BEGIN OF HOW MANY
COUNTIES COULD CHILDREN LIVED
AND HOW MANY COUNTIES THAT
COULD REOPEN WE HAVE NO IDEA
HOW MANY SCHOOLS IN THE STATE
ARE OPEN DAILY. OR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DOES ANYBODY HAVE
THAT DATA. LIKE RIGHT NOW SO%
WHAT WE'RE SAYING. THERE BEEN
SEVENTEEN OPERATE. OUT OF. DO
WE KNOW HOW MANY SCHOOLS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. I WILL START AND
THEN I DON'T OVER CD COLORS MAY
WANNA SAY MORE I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN SOM SURVEYS THAT HAVE
BEEN DONE- AND RECENT SURVEYS I
DID MENTION THAT OVER ELEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY WAIVERS HAVE
BEEN GRANTED FOR ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS YOU KNOW THE INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOLS. OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED
OUR SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN. GRANTED
WAIVERS ACROSS THE STATE AND
THEN AS YOU'RE MENTIONING I
THINK THERE ARE OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE RED OR LOWER
TIERS THAT HAVE BEGIN TO RE
OPEN AS WELL AND THERE IS SOME
DATA FROM A RECENT SURVEY THAT
I BELIEVE- ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
HERE MAY HAVE INFORMATION
ABOUT. WHAT THE SCHOOLS
THEMSELVES OR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NO NOBODY'S MANDATED
TO REPORT A CHARTER SCHOOL A
PRIVATE SCHOOL SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT'S OPENING THERE'S NO.
REQUIREMENT TO WE CAN DO A
SURVEY. BUT WE DON'T REALLY
KNOW CORRECT. HEY GREG SENT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AS WE THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT TO QUEUE FOR
DISTRICTS CAN NOTIFY THEIR
OPENING PLANS. TO THE STATE. WE
DO HOWEVER KNOW WITH OUR TOP
TWENTY FIVE DISTRICT THAT
REPRESENT DISTRICTS THAT
REPRESENTS ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION. OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
ALMOST ONE THIRD OF STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. MANY OF THEM ARE
NOT OPENING UNTIL JANUARY THERE
ARE A FEW THAT ARE A FEW THAT
ARE DOING A PHASED IN. THE
OPENING STARTING IN OCTOBER
DEPENDING ON THEIR COUNTY THAT
THEY'RE IN. AND SO THEY WILL BE
FREEZING IN FROM ELEMENTARY TO
HIGH SCHOOL AND THEN BY JANUARY
ALL OF THEIR STUDENTS WILL BE
BACK IN CLASSROOM BASED
INSTRUCTION. WE DO HAVE KNOW
THAT SOME OF THEM ARE LIKE OUR
LARGER ONE DALY UNIFIED CANDY
AGAIN UNIFIED. AND FRESNO ARE
DOING SMALL COHORT FOR THEIR
OPENING AT CURRENTLY. AS THEY
LOOK TO DO. IT BASED IN RE
OPENING. OKAY I KNOW WE PASS
BUT MY COLLEAGUE HAD A BILL
ACTUALLY THAT WE PASS BUT GOT
HELD UP THAT WOULD HAVE
ACTUALLY REQUIRED SCHOOLS TO
REPORT THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
REOPEN BECAUSE I THINK WHEN
WE'RE WORKING WITH A NUMBER
LIKE SEVENTEEN WELL THAT SOUNDS
GREAT BUT WE DON'T KNOW
SEVENTEEN OUT OF HOW MANY- IT
IT'S- DATA BECOMES USELESS IF
WE CAN'TPUT AN END TO SOME
COMPARISON- MY OTHER QUESTION
IS WHERE IS THIS DATA ON SCHOOL
REPORTS OF- CASES LIKE WHERE
CAN WE FIND IT. OR IS THIS JUST
WHAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT AT THE
STATE LEVEL THE COUNTIES THAT
HAVE REPORTED OUTBREAKS AT
SCHOOL HOW DO WE KNOW. THE
CURRENTLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH THIS IS
WITHIN OUR SURVEILLANCE DATA WE
WILL BE LOOKING AT- HOW WE CAN.
WORK WITH A LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO MAKE MORE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE ABOUT
THIS OKAY SO IT'S NOT THIS IS
ALL RIGHT. WELL I HAVE ONE I
HAVE A TON OF QUESTIONS AND I'M
SORRY- SO IN THE BEGINNING THE
L. A. GAVE US A SAMPLE OF.
STATE LOCAL COUNTY LEVEL
GUIDANCE- THAT. MIGHT CONFLICT
WITH ONE ANOTHER. DO WE HAVE
THAT IN ITS GUIDANCE RIGHT
BECAUSE NOBODY IS ACTUALLY-
CHECKING TO MAKE SURE THE
SCHOOLS ARE DOING IN. THIS
GUIDANCE IT'S NOT LIKE. COUNTY
HEALTH OFFICERS OR ARE THEY
SUPPOSED TO BE THIS IS THAT A
QUESTION THAT'S COMING UP IN MY
COUNTY RIGHT NOW SO- THERE'S
GUIDANCE. MAYBE THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT CAN FOLLOW THE
GUIDANCE MAYBE IT'S NOT
PRACTICAL I THINK THAT WAS THE
WORD THAT WAS BEING THROWN
AROUND- DO WE HAVE LIKE AN
ULTIMATE GUIDANCE HERE BETWEEN
THE- COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
THE CD AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
FOR SCHOOLS. IS THERE LIKE A
FINAL GUIDANCE. ARE YOU
DIRECTING IT TO I ALREADY FOR
MY HEALTH YES WELL THE L. A.
KIND OF LAID IT OUT SO I DON'T
KNOW IF THEY ARE ARE SUGGESTING
THAT THERE WERE THINGS CONFLICT
WE'RE NOT SURE. WHAT THE WHAT
WHAT THE SCHOOLS ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING. SO BEFORE YOU
ANSWER THAT EXHIBIT TECHNICAL
THING SO IF ANYBODY WANTS TO
ANSWER DO WE NEED TO TELL YOU
WHO ARE LOOKING FOR OR CAN
ANYBODY JUMP IN AND TALK. SO.
IT IS VERY BROAD I BELIEVE ANY
OF US CAN JUMP IN AND TALK I
THINK I THINK WELL JUST MAKING
SURE WE KNOW WITH THE
APPROPRIATE PERSON I THINK ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE I WOULD.
I WOULD SAY SOME OF THE THERE
ARE SOME ASPECTS OF THE CDPH
GUIDANCE THAT IS REQUIRED I
BELIEVE LIKE THE MASK.
REQUIREMENT FOR EXAMPLE THAT
IS. AN ABSOLUTE REQUIREMENT FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THERE MIGHT
BE ANOTHER THAT I CAN'T
REMEMBER BUT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THE DETAILS ABOUT HOW YOU
IMPLEMENT. THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
NOT SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THIS IS. IT
THESE ARE THINGS GOING TO
CONSIDER TO TRY TO IMPLEMENT TO
THE DEGREE POSSIBLE TO DOESN'T
MEAN THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO
IT. THAT'S THAT'S WHERE MOST OF
THE MAJOR DECISIONS ARE ASIDE
FROM THE MATHIS YOU. GREAT AND
THEN MY FINAL QUESTION FOR NOW
I DON'T THINK YOU AND I THINK
THIS IS FOR DOCTOR PAN BECAUSE
THE- DISCUSSION ABOUT COHORTS
WAS REALLY. EXCITING AND
INTERESTING. ALTHOUGH I KNOW
IT'S JUST A VERY RECENT
OUTBREAK- IF IT'S TO UNIFIED
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE- OLDER KIDS
THEY SUPPOSED TO BE REQUIRED TO
BE IN COHORTS BECAUSE I KNOW-
WITH SO FAR THAT THEY'VE HAD I
THINK FOUR. POSITIVE TESTS IN
THE LAST WEEK TWO OF THEM HAVE
REQUIRED THEM TO- CORTINA
HUNDRED FIFTY KIDS SO CLEARLY-
THIS IDEA OF A SEVENTEEN
PERCENT. CORE HORROR ARE
FIFTEEN FOURTEEN TWO. TEACHERS
IS THAT JUST FOR THE WAIVERS
FOR THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS OR
IS THAT SUPPOSED TO BE FOR- THE
COUNTIES THAT ARE IN RED WHOSE
HIGH SCHOOLS. AND MIDDLE
SCHOOLS ARE OPENING UP. I THINK
DOCTOR SHOULD. YES CAN YOU ME
AHA. OKAY GREAT SO THE KIND OF
WILL ANSWER OF YOUR- I SO. OLD
AGAIN THE LOCAL UNFORTUNATE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY AND
THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT AT
A LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS HAVE
THE ULTIMATE AUTHORITY AROUND
THESE THINGS. AND I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF. YOU KNOW IN
IN THE IN THE TIMES TO TRY TO
BE AS FLEXIBLE AS POSSIBLE TO
HAVE GUIDING PRINCIPLES OF THE
GETTING PEOPLE BEGAN ARE AROUND
FACE COVERING SO. AS WAS
MENTIONED THAT IS A STATE
MANDATE THAT FACE COVERINGS
MUST BE WORN FOR EVERYONE THIRD
GRADE AN OLDER. AND THEN
STRONGLY RECOMMENDED FOR
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH SECOND
GRADE AS WELL. AND THEN THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING SO AGAIN
BUT I'M TRYING TO BE AS
PRACTICAL AS POSSIBLE TO MAKE
SURE. YOU KNOW EVERY SCHOOL IS
DIFFERENT AND THE SPACE IS
DIFFERENT AND THE SIZE THEY'RE
DIFFERENT SO. THE AND TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT THE COURT
NUMBERS SO THE COURT NUMBERS-
ARE REALLY FOR OUR SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE NOT YET RETURNED TO FULL
TO EVEN PARTIAL IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. TO ALLOW FOR THOSE
HIGH NEEDS CHILDREN. OR
CHILDREN HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS TO
START TO COME BACK. I THINK
ONCE YOU GET INTO EVEN THE
HYBRID OR PARTIAL IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION YOU WE WANTED. TO
HAVE FLEXIBILITY AND LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE ECHOED
AND AGAIN I HAVING BEEN A LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT OR SOME
MYSELF IT IS REALLY HELPFUL FOR
EACH LOCAL DISTRICT. AND LOCAL
SCHOOL TO HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY
TO TRY TO DETERMINE HOW CAN
THEY BEST SET UP THEIR
CLASSROOMS. TO PHYSICALLY
DOESN'T THE CHILDREN TO ALLOW
FOR COHORTS AND ALLOW FOR
STAFFING AND SAFE WAY- SO IT
IS. AGAIN THESE GUIDING
PRINCIPLES ARE THE SAME ACROSS
ALL THESE DIFFERENT GUIDANCES
BUT- TRYING TO ALLOW FOR THAT
BALANCE WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
BALANCE I THINK THE- THE
POTENTIAL FOR. A TRANSMISSION
AND PREVENTING TRANSMISSION IN
THAT SETTING BUT ALSO. YOU KNOW
HOW TO HAVE THE BEST ACTUAL
INSTRUCTION. FOR CHILDREN IN
THESE IN PERSON SETTINGS. SO I
DON'T. THINK FAN JUST ADD IN A
ROW THE CALIFORNIA. OF A-
GUIDANCE GUIDING WITH BASED ON.
THAT PRINT. PUBLISHED BY THE
PDP. AND THEN ALL OF. ARE FOR
WAS. AROUND THE EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENT. FOR AN INSTRUCTIONAL
MODELS. THAT ARE DISTRICTS
WOULD BE LOOKING AT AS THEY
LOOK TO RE OPEN. AND SO OUR
FOCUS WAS MAINLY ON THE
EDUCATIONAL COMPONENT OF RE
OPENING. THANK YOU AND I JUST
DR PAN AGAIN JUST BECAUSE I'M A
LITTLE CONFUSED BY ALL THIS AND
WHAT'S GOING ON ACTUALLY IN MY
COUNTY- IT IS THE COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICER WHO IS SUPPOSED TO BE
POLICING THE SCHOOLS. IF YOU
WILL I GUESS THAT'S NOT A GREAT
WORD BUT. WELL I'D SAY AT AN
EXTREME THE LOCAL HELD HER IN A
COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER OR LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER BECAUSE THERE
ARE THREE CITIES HELLO THIRTY
TO CLOSE THE SCHOOL AND
CERTAINLY HAVE AUTHORITY TO- TO
ENFORCE LOCAL HOLD ON THIS
ORDER IS THAT HAVE YOU KNOW
COURSES YOU KNOW HAVE A HUGE
SPECTRUM SO. I THINK THE
ABILITY TO PHYSICALLY ENFORCER
PHYSICALLY THE ON SITE IS NOT
FEASIBLE FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALSO DEALING WITH ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT SECTORS- BUT BUT
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW ENFORCEMENT
IS AN ISSUE IN MANY SECTORS
INCLUDING SCHOOLS AND WE'VE
DEFINITELY BEEN HEARING ABOUT
SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT FOLLOWING
THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT OR
STATE HEALTH GUIDELINES. THANK
YOU MY LAST QUESTION I PROMISE
IS IF THERE SHOULD BECOME A
VACCINE IS THEIR THOUGHT
PROCESS AS FAR AS- THE BUDGET
AND- ANY BILL WOULD HAVE TO BE
APPROPRIATED ON- INSURING THE
CHILDREN WERE VACCINATED PRIOR
TO- RETURNING TO SCHOOL. ANY
THOUGHTS ONCE THERE'S A VACCINE
HAVE WE STARTED TO THINK ABOUT
THE. I THINK IT WOULD BE
CHEAPER THAN THE- TESTING EVERY.
HE WEEK SERVICE IS DOCTOR PUN
AND IF YOU CAN STILL HEAR ME I
WOULD SAY IN GENERAL MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS FOR ALL AGES A
VACCINE IS SORT OF YOU KNOW THE
SAYING THAT WE ARE NOT GOING TO
BE CHARGING PEOPLE FOR BACK
THEN IT'S GOING TO BE OFFERED
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL WILL ALSO
JUST AS FAR AS EXPECTATION AND
LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
ALL OF THIS TESTING IS GOING ON
NOW IS PART IS AN ADULT SO IT'S
GOING TO BE SEVERAL MONTHS OUT
BEFORE WE CAN ACTUALLY GET
PEDIATRIC SAFETY TRIALS. OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU. MR
ARAMBULA MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M I'M
GOING TO ADDRESS MY FIRST FEW
QUESTIONS TO DR GREGSON WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IF I COULD AND I
SHE'S COMING TO THE MIKE I JUST
FIRST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING M HERE TODAY IT. IS
MY FIRST TIME SITTING ON SUB TO
ACTUALLY MY FIRST TIME IN AN
EDUCATION HEARING AND WANTED TO
TAKE A MOMENT IF I COULD TO
TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
EDUCATION AT LEAST FOR ME. I
WORE THIS MASK ON PURPOSE TODAY
BECAUSE I WAS AT A RECENT
GROUNDBREAKING WHERE WE HAVE A
SATELLITE CAMPUS FOR FRESNO
CITY COLLEGE AND AT THAT
GROUNDBREAKING WE HAD PASTOR B.
T. LEWIS WHO TOLD US IN
ARISTOTLE QUOTE. THAT THE ROOTS
OF EDUCATION ARE BITTER BT THE
FRUITS ARE SWEET. AS I START TO
THINK ABOUT ALL THE SACRIFICES
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE BY SO MANY
PEOPLE SO WE CAN HAVE.
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN EDUCATION.
MY GRANDPARENTS WHO NEVER WANTS
TO A SINGLE DAY OF SCHOOL SO
THAT WE COULD TRY TO. BECOME
SOMETHING OURSELF INSPIRES ME
TO WANT TO CREATE THOSE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CHILDREN
TODAY. BUT I WISH TO SPEAK
ABOUT ANOTHER ARISTOTLE QUOTE
RIGHT NOW WHICH IS EDUCATION OF
THE MIND WITHOUT EDUCATING THE
HEART. IS NO EDUCATION AT ALL.
AND IT IS IN THAT SPIRIT THAT I
WISH TO ASK MY FIRST QUESTION A
FEW DOCTOR GREGSON. WHAT IS THE
CURRENT STATE OF MENTAL HEALTH
FOR CHILDREN AND TEACHERS IN
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM. WHAT ARE
THE DRIVERS OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES CHILDREN AND
TEACHERS ARE FACING AND HOW IS
THIS PROBLEM BEING ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
YOUR QUESTION AT MENTAL HEALTH
HAS BEEN ON OUR MINDS IT SINCE
MARCH THIRTEENTH. WHEN OUR
SCHOOLS. WERE SHELTERING IN
PLACE AND SCHOOL BUILDINGS WERE
CLOSED. RCT PRETENDED OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND HAS
THAT MADE IT A PRIORITY TO
BRING TOGETHER THE MENTAL
HEALTH COALITIONS ACROSS THE
STATE. TO INSURE THAT WE HAVE A
PATCHWORK. WILL ACROSS THE-
FOUR ARE STILL TO ACCESS MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT AND SO HE HAD
BEEN DILIGENTLY WORKING WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH COALITION TO
ENSURE THAT. ALL OF OUR MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE CONNECTED WITH EACH
OTHER AND CONNECTED WITH
DISTRICTS AND THE DISTRICTS ARE
UNDERSTANDING WHERE THEY CAN GO
FOR THEIR STUDENTS TO TAKEAT
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT. THIS IS
A VERY TRAUMATIC TIME FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND THE ADULTS IN THE
SYSTEM WHO ARE CARING FOR OUR
STUDENTS THERE IS NO DOUBT
ABOUT THAT AND SHARING THAT WE
ARE MAKING MENTAL HEALTH A
PRIORITY IS ABSOLUTELY A MUST.
IN OUR GUIDANCE WE MADE A HEAVY
EMPHASIS ON ENSURING THAT THAT
NOT ONLY WILD TEACHERS WERE
PROVIDING CONTENT AREA
INSTRUCTION THAT THEY WERE ALSO
LOOKING AT THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
ASPECT OF THEIR STUDENTS.
ENSURING THAT THEY WERE
CONNECTING ENSURING THAT THEY
WERE. PROVIDING TIME TO CONNECT
AND ASK QUESTIONS THAT ARE
OUTSIDE OF THE NORMAL
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME. SEEING HOW
THEY'RE DOING I KNOW MANY
TEACHERS PROVIDED ASSIGNMENT
THAT ASKED STUDENTS TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES AND HOW THEY WERE
FEELING IN DIFFERENT WAYS AND
SO MENTAL HEALTH IS DEFINITELY
A MUST AS FAR AS PRIORITIZING
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT FOR
THE STUDENTS. AND THE. ADULTS
WERE CARING FOR THE STUDENT.
YOU FIND DR GREG I DO. REALLY
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
STATE THAT YOU MADE FIRST THAT
THESE ARE VERY DRAMATIC TIMES
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S THE
ECONOMIC DISTRESS THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING THE ISOLATION THAT
IS OCCURRING THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC. ACES ARE OCCURRING TO
OUR CHILDREN TODAY WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO HELP TO
CONNECT PEOPLE TO RESOURCES YOU
HAD MENTIONED THAT THERE ARE A
PATCHWORK OF SERVICES AND THAT-
SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND IS
WORKING WITH THE COALITION I
WOULD LIKE TO IF YOU CAN HE WAS
A FORMER COLLEAGUE OF OURS HERE
ON THE DIESS. TO EXTEND AN
INVITATION TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR OFFICES
I SPECIFICALLY WOULD LIKE TO
LOOK INTO HOW WE CAN PLANET
TAKE AWAY THE SILOS BETWEEN
EDUCATION AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE PROVIDING THE SERVICES THAT
ARE NEEDED DURING THESE TRYING
TIMES. HOW CAN WE NOW THAT WE
START TO BREAK THE SILOS DOWN
THINK ABOUT TELEHEALTH IS THERE
AN OPPORTUNITY NOW FOR US TO
CREATE A NEW SYSTEM THAT
PROVIDES FOR SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING THAT IS AN-
OPPORTUNITY OUT OF THIS CRISIS
AND SO I THINK THAT'S AN AREA
I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH YOUR OFFICE AND WOULD LOVE
TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW UP AS- I
THINK THAT'S A MAJOR AREA THAT
WE CAN WORK ON NEXT YEAR. BUT I
DIDN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT WAS RECENTLY
WITHIN THE LA DAILY NEWS WHICH
JUST SHARED SOME INFORMATION
FROM A PARENT SURVEY WHICH
SHOWED THAT 76% OF PARENTS SAID
THEIR CHILDREN AREN'T LEARNING
OR MAKING PROGRESS. WITH
DISTANCE LEARNING. AND 74% SAID
THEIR CHILDREN REGRESSED IN
THEIR BEHAVIOR AND
DEMONSTRATION OF SKILLS AND FOR
CD. DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF THAT
DATA POINT IS GENERALLY TRUE
ACROSS THE STATE. OR IS THE
STATE DATA DIFFERENT. CAN YOU
SHARE MORE ABOUT WHAT YOU HAVE
DONE TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
WHAT ARE THE BEST PRACTICES
THAT EXIST AND WHAT CAN BE DONE
TO IMPROVE THE SITUATION.
ESPECIALLY FOR CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS. ALL RIGHT TO SAY
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND
FOCUSING ON THE MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT I THINK THAT WOULD BE A
GREAT PARTNERSHIP. IS FAR AS
DISTANCE LEARNING AND OUR OUR
STUDENTS THAT HAVE NEEDED MORE
SERVICES. SPECIFICALLY AROUND
SPECIAL EDUCATION ARE ENGLISH
LEARNERS OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING READERS THERE HAVE
BEEN MANY LEARNING FOR FROM THE
SPRING INTO THE FALL MANY OF
OUR DISTRICTS TO HAVE PUT IN
PLACE DIAGNOSTIC ASSESSMENT.
AND PROGRESS MONITORING
ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE WHERE
STUDENTS ARE AREAS OF GROWTH
OUR ADS AND WHAT THEY NEEDED TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE GETTING
THE CORRECT SERVICES FOR
WHETHER ACADEMICALLY. MANY OF
OUR DISTRICT HAVE BEEN BRINGING
OUT THERE BUT BRINGING BACK
THEIR MOST STRUGGLING STUDENTS
AND SMALL COHORTS SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED STARTED BRINGING BACK
TO STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
AND SMALL COHORTS. SAN JUAN
UNIFIED IS STARTING THOSE THE
ELK GROVE UNIFIED SO MANY OF
OUR LARGER DISTRICT IN OUR
SMALLER DISTRICTS ARE PROVIDING
IN PERSON SUPPORT IN A SAFE
MANNER. IN A SMALL COHORT WAY.
WE HAVE ALSO THE SCENE PROVIDED
GUIDANCE PHYSICAL ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THESE. STATE WHO NEED A
LITTLE BIT MORE- ACADEMIC
STRUCTURE THROUGH OUR MULTI
LINGUAL ONLINE DOCUMENTS
THROUGH OUR RE OPENING GUIDANCE
AND OVER THE HUNDRED WEBINARS
WE DID IT THROUGH OUCH FROM
MARCH UNTIL THIS POINT IN TIME.
YOU KNOW I DID WANNA HIGHLIGHT
IF I COULD EARLIER YOU HAD SAID
WHAT A MONUMENTAL JOB OR
TEACHERS HAVE DONE THIS YEAR
AND IF YOU WOULD JUST GIVE ME
AN OPPORTUNITY I HAVE THREE
KIDS WERE IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
AND SO FOR MISS LITTLE MISS
LONG QUESTION MISS HUDSON WHO
ARE DOING A TREMENDOUS JOB WITH
MY DAUGHTERS AND ALLOWING THEM
TO GROW RIGHT NOW INTO. YOUNG
ADULTS I JUST WANTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND RECOGNIZE HOW HARD
THE WORK IS FOR TEACHERS AND
WHAT WE'RE ASKING THEM TO DO
AND- HOW MUCH THEY NEED TO BE
SUPPORTED THROUGH THESE TRYING
TIMES WHICH IS WHY I'M TRYING
TO. FIGURE OUT IF WE CAN BLEND
THOSE SILOS BETWEEN EDUCATION
AND HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
BUT THAT WILL BRING ME TO MY
THIRD QUESTION BECAUSE I DEAL A
FAIR AMOUNT WITH THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. AND SO I WANTED TO
ASK IF YOU COULD HOW MANY
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE TO CD
HAD HE HAVE IN ITS SYSTEM. AND
OF THOSE HOW MANY HELP THE
TECHNOLOGY HI EITHER COMPUTER
OR WIFI ACCESS IN ORDER TO
PARTICIPATE IN ONLINE LEARNING.
AND THEN I WILL ASK A VERY
SPECIFIC QUESTION AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DIRECTNESS OF
IT. BUT HOW IS THAT ASSESSMENT
DETERMINED. WHO IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR ENSURING THAT THE CHILDREN
HAVE ACCESS TO THE TECHNOLOGY.
AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE ANSWER
THE QUESTION. BY DESCRIBING THE
DISTRIBUTION OF
RESPONSIBILITIES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION REGARDING FOSTER
CARE. IT IS WE HAVE OVER THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND FOSTER CARE
STUDENTS ACROSS THESTATE AND
THAT MADE THAT NUMBER MAY BE A
LITTLE BIT OFF BUT THAT IS THE
NUMBER WE HAVE IN THIS MOMENT
IN TIME AS FAR AS THE DIGITAL
COMPONENT OF ENSURING THAT OUR
FOSTER CARE YOUTH GET THE
DEVICES THAT THEY NEED. C. D.
E. HAVE PARTNERED TO DILIGENTLY
WITH OUR DIGITAL DIVIDE TASK
FORCE AND THE MANY. DONATIONS
FROM THE DATE THAT HAVE COME
FROM THE DIGITAL DIVIDE TASK
FORCE. TO ENSURE THAT OUR
FOSTER CARE YOUTH WERE
PRIORITIZED AND THAT THEY HAVE
THE DEVICES THAT THEY NEED. TO
OUR DEPARTMENT WORK TO
DILIGENTLY WITH FOSTER CARE
YOUTH COORDINATORS AT EVERY
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO
pENSURE THAT EACH EACH FOSTER
CARE YOU. GOT THE DEVICE FIRST.
THE SECOND PART OF THAT IS HOW
DOES THE ASSESSMENT DETERMINED
AND HIS RESPONSIBILITIES THAT.
R. AS WHETHER OR NOT THE FOSTER
CARE YOUTH NEEDED THE DEVICES
THAT WAS DETERMINED BY THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
THE LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCY.
THEY ARE THEN THE ONES
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
ONCE WE PROVIDE THEM THE DEVICE
THE DEVICE GETS IN THE HANDS OF
THE STUDENTS WE USE THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AS A
DISTRIBUTION MECHANISM TO
ENSURE EACH OF THOSE STUDENTS
RECEIVE THEIR DEVICES. AND I
WOULD JUST SHARE WITH THE
MCCARTY LANDS- CONCERN WHEN WE
HAVE SYSTEMS MULTIPLE SYSTEMS
NEEDING TO INTEGRATE TOGETHER
TO MAKE SURE THAT- WE HAVE THE
END GOAL IN MIND. AND SO WE
JUST ASK THAT WE ENSURE THOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE. DETAILED
SO THAT OUR FOSTER KIDS CAN
HAVE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES. IF
YOU COULD I HAVE JUST A FEW
MORE QUESTIONS AND HEADS JUST
BECAUSE I DON'T GET TO SIT ON
THESE EDUCATION PANELS THAT
OFTEN. BUT WHAT IS THE CURRENT
SITUATION WITH INDIVIDUALS
INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION PLANS
FOR CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
INCLUDING WHETHER ALL
CHILDREN'S WITH IT PEAS HAVE
BEEN EVALUATED. AND IF THEY
HAVE HAD THEIR IEPS MODIFIED IF
CD IS NOT TRACKING THAT WHY OR
WHY NOT. YEAH WE- A GREAT
SETTING AND- AT THE DEPARTMENT
WE DO HAVE A MONITORING SYSTEM
BOARD INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION PLAN
OUR ENTIRE SPECIAL EDUCATION
DIVISION SUPPORT EACH OF THE
DISTRICTS IN ENSURING THAT THE
I. PEAS ARE UP TO DATE AND THAT
THOSE SERVICES OUTLINED IN THE
IDPS ARE BEING PROVIDED TO THE
STUDENTS. EVEN THROUGH THE VERY
CHALLENGING TIME WE ARE WORKING
DIRECTLY THROUGH OUR CELL
PHONES ARE COUNTY OFFICES AND
OUR DISTRICTS TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE BEING AFFECTED AND
TIMELY MANNER AND BEING PROVIDE
THE SUPPORTS AND SERVICES THAT.
ARE OUTLINED IN THERE I EAT
PEAS. JUST BECAUSE I REPRESENT
ROULERS I DO. OBLIGATED TO ASK
ABOUT THE CURRENT STATUS OF
WIFI ACCESS. ACROSS THE STATE
FOR ALL CHILDREN AND WHAT IS
BEING DONE ABOUT THE SITUATION.
WELL WE HAVE BEEN WORKING OUR
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION HAS CALLED FOR THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE TASK FORCE THAT
WAS CHAIRED BY SENATOR LEYVA
SEVERAL OTHER ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
WERE A PART OF. THIS DIGITAL
DIVIDE TASK FORCE AND THEY HAVE
BEEN CONNECTING WITH INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO ENSURE THE
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE
PROVIDING CONNECTIVITY AT LOWER
RATES FAR LOWER INCOME FAMILIES
AND ALSO WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ON ENSURING THAT CAN ACTIVITY
IS. SLOWING LIKE ELECTRICITY
ACROSS THE STATE WE HAD A
HEARING YESTERDAY THAT OUR
SUPERINTENDENT PARTICIPATED IN
OUTLINING ALL OF THE PLANS IN
THE PARTNERSHIP. TO ENSURE THAT
OUR CONNECTIVITY'S HAPPENING
FOR EVERY STUDENT ACROSS THE
STATE BUT THIS IS A COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY AND THAT WE ALL
NEED TO WORK TOGETHER ON HOW TO
DO THAT. BECAUSE THIS IS THAT
SOMETHING. THAT OUR STUDENTS
DESERVE. IF I COULD I WOULD END
WITH THE CENTRAL GOVERNMENT
TORKEL QUESTION OR STATEMENT IF
YOU COULD BUT- IF WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT WHAT C. FREE
OPENINGS OF SCHOOLS LOOK LIKE.
I WOULD OPINE THAT WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT TEACHERS AND
PARENTS ARE INCLUDED IN THOSE
LOCAL DECISIONS. MOST OF WHAT I
HEARD WERE ABOUT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MAKING THOSE
DECISIONS AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
PROVIDING THE EDUCATION WHO ARE
ON THE FRONT LINES WHO. ARE
EXPOSING THEMSELVES POTENTIALLY
TO AN ILLNESS ARE ALSO INCLUDED
AND MUST BE INCLUDED IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. WITH THAT I
BELIEVE THAT'S HOW WE DO THE
HARD WORK FOR RE OPENING OUR
SCHOOLS I BELIEVE THAT'S HOW.
WE MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE ROOTS
OF EDUCATION SO THAT SO MANY OF
OUR KIDS CAN BLOSSOM INTO THE
YOUNG ADULTS THAT THEY WILL
BECOME. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR ALLOWING ME TO ASK
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SOMEONE
MEMBER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL. I THANK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU TO
ALL THE PARTICIPANTS TODAY'S
HEARING I JUST A FEW QUESTIONS-
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I'VE BEEN
HEARING FROM A COUPLE CBO IS-
IT'S WITH REGARD TO
SUPPLEMENTAL. WELL IT'S WITH
REGARD TO A POTENTIAL REDUCTION
SUPPLEMENTAL CONSECRATION GRANT
FUNDING. BECAUSE THE
DOCUMENTATION IS A COMING BACK
FROM PARENTS THAT IS THE
REQUIRED DOCUMENTATION. TO GET
BASICALLY COLLECT FREE AND
REDUCED MEAL FORMS- THE
LOGISTICS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
ARE VERY DIFFICULT THIS TIME.
ASSEMBLY BILL REALLY HAVE AN
INCENTIVE TO FILL THEM OUT
QUITE FRANKLY BECAUSE THE
MANDATE IS BASICALLY VENDOR TO
FEED FOLKS AND THAT'S A GOOD
THING. BUT THERE'S A BIT OF A
HURDLE HERE AND- ITS- THAT
DOCUMENTATION IS REQUIRED. FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO RECEIVE
THEIR- CFF THEIR SUPPLEMENTAL
CONSERVE GREAT. CONCENTRATION
GRANT FUNDING- HAVE YOU BEEN
HERE YOU MAY THIS MAY BE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE
YOU. HAVE YOU. HEARD OF THAT
CONCERNED YOU HAVE ANY PLANS TO
ADDRESS IT I KNOW WE'VE HELD
HARMLESS. THE ADA BUT. THIS IS
REALLY A SEPARATE ISSUE I WOULD
ARGUE. YES YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- O'DONNELL SO WE ARE
AWARE OF AS SOME CONVERSATIONS
AMONG CERTAIN CBO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WHO HAVE HAD SOME
CONCERNS AROUND AND DUPLICATED
PERCENTAGES WHICH IS YOU KNOW
WHAT WE WERE FOR THAT'S THE
SORT OF THE SHORTHAND TERM FOR-
THE PERCENTAGES OF STUDENTS
THAT GENERATE SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANTS FUNDS AND
THE LARGEST OF THOSE BEING
THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE. FOR
FREE AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS
ONE OF- ONE OF THE AS
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S PROVIDING
A WAIVER TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ALLOW THEM TO RUN THEIR STE
THEIR SUMMER MEAL PROGRAMS
INSTEAD OF THEIR NORMAL SCHOOL
MEAL PROGRAMS WHICH IS A VERY
EXCELLENT THING- BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS- EVERYONE'S NO KIDS TO
GET FAT AS YOU MENTION. IS THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS AROUND FAMILIES
FILLING OUT FREE AND REDUCED
PRICE MEAL APPLICATIONS- TO
HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THEIR
COLLECTION OF THE STATE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
RECENTLY EXTENDED. THE TIME
PERIOD BY WHICH SUCH AS SCHOOLS
HAVE TO REPORT THEIR FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE MEAL ELIGIBILITY
BY TWO MONTHS. SO NOW THAT
INFORMATION IS NOT DUE UNTIL
THE END OF DECEMBER OR START
MID DECEMBER I BELIEVE- SO THAT
HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL AND WE'VE
HEARD A LOT OF VIDEOS THAT'S
VERY HELPFUL IN GETTING THE
INFORMATION AND- MANY MANY OF
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND WE
WOULD EXPECT THIS GIVEN THE
ECONOMIC. CONDITIONS THAT WERE
AND ARE ACTUALLY REPORTING THAT
THEY HAVE MORE. SCREEN REDUCE
PRICE NO ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES THAN THEY HAD IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY. SO OUR
HOPE IS THAT- SCHOOLS CAN GET
THE DOCUMENTATION- OF THEIR
FAMILIES PRIOR TO THAT
EXTENDED- THAT- MANY SCHOOLS
MAY SEE THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
HIGHER FREE INTRODUCED PERSONAL
PERCENTAGES. THAN OTHERWISE WE
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT IN
TERMS OF THEIR ENGAGE WITH
FAMILIES. I'M TO BE REACHING
OUT AND GETTING THE INFORMATION
FROM THOSE FAMILIES SO THAT
THEY CAN ALSO ASCERTAIN WHAT
OTHER NEEDS AS FAMILIES HAVE.
SO AT THIS POINT- WE BELIEVE
THAT THE- ADDITIONAL TIME WILL
BE HELPFUL IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
GETTING THE PAPERBACK THE
PAPERWORK BACK FROM FAMILIES
BUT WE ARE AWARE AND ARE
MONITORING THIS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. GREAT THANK YOU AND I
GET A DISTRICT GETS A
CONTINUING CONCERN THAT
DISTRICTS HAVE SO I THINK WE
NEED TO WATCH CLOSELY. SO THEY
DON'T COME UP SHORT YET ARE.
ARE SERVING THE SAME THE SAME
STUDENTS. I LEX QUESTIONS WITH
REGARD TO RE OPENING SCHOOLS-
IN IN THE CAR AND I'M NOT SURE
WHO THIS QUESTION WHO DO WHO
MIGHT JUMP ON THIS QUESTION-
BUT CAN COUNTIES IMPOSE
REQUIREMENTS BEYOND THOSE
REQUIRED BY THE CALIFORNIA.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS
A CONDITION FOR REOPENING
SCHOOLS. I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE
LONG BEACH. THE CITY HAS
THERE'S THREE CITIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS THEIR
OWN HEALTH DEPARTMENT- THANKS
LONG BEACH PASADENA AND
BERKELEY I BELIEVE. BUT THE
CITY'S HEALTH DEPARTMENT AS- IT
IMPOSED REQUIREMENT THAT
APPARENTLY AS I UNDERSTAND IT
AND AS OF. THAT COMMUNICATION
WITH THE DISTRICT THIS. THEIR
FIRMNESS. THAT STUDENTS WILL
HAVE TO HAVE THE FLU VACCINE- I
GUESS IT'S PROBABLY A SHOT. IF
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO RETURN TO
SCHOOL. THIS IS DOCTOR PRODUCT
RESPONDED. SO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE DO ONE THING DR REALLY
REPEAT THE QUESTION IS CAN CAN.
CAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS I'M SORRY
CAN CAN'T APART CAN COUNTY
SIMPLE REQUIREMENTS BEYOND
THOSE REQUIRED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AS A CONDITION OF
REOPENING SCHOOLS. SERVER TO
HELP AND IN THIS CASE IT'S
ACTUALLY A CITY HEALTH
DEPARTMENT ON A COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. THAT'S THE KIND OF
EXPLAINED EVERITT ALTERNATE
BACK YOU. SURE HELLO YES- THIS
IS STOCKED UPON AGAIN YES A
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS
ABSOLUTELY YOU'RE RIGHT THERE
SIXTY ONE LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS
AND CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES AND THREE CITIES. DO
HAVE LOCAL AUTHORITY TO BE
STRICTER THAN THE STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT ON ANY ACTUAL- HELLO
THIS ORDER FROM THE STATE OR
HEALTH OFFICER AND THEY CANNOT
ALLOW MORE THINGS AND A LOT OF
THE STATE. THE LOCAL OFFICES
CAN OFTEN BE STRICTER. SO IS
THAT IS IT IN THE END OF YOUR
DEFINITION OF BEING STRICTER.
IS IT ALLOWABLE FOR A COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENT IN THIS CASE
THE CITY HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO
IMPOSE SUCH A REQUIREMENT THAT
A FLU VACCINE BE REQUIRED. YES
WELL THE VISITORS CAN ISSUE
ORDERS OR REQUIREMENTS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. STILL CONCERNING
TO ME THANK YOU. THEN THE NEXT
QUESTION IS FOR A- THE TO
HEALTH RELATED QUESTION
DEPARTMENT HEALTH RECORDED
QUESTION- IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PURCHASE OF AT LEAST
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF COVERT TASKS. AND THE
QUESTION IS WILL THE
ADMINISTRATION ALLOCATE THOSE
TESTS TO SCHOOLS AND ALL OF A
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
THEY HAVE. IF DAY I GET TO MEET
TESTING IS KEY RIGHT NOW WHAT
WHAT WE NEED TO TRY TO CONTROL
OUR VIRUS MUCH AS WE CAN. GIVEN
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A VACCINE SO
TEXT TESTING IS. USUALLY I KNOW
LA UNIFIED AS A- YOU KNOW THEY
DEVELOP A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
PROGRAM MAY BE A MODEL FOR THE
STATE EVENTUALLY. BUT THAT. ARE
ARE THOSE TESTS THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS A- HAS. HAS
PURCHASED GO GOING TO GO TO
SCHOOL SITES. SERVICES DOCTOR
POLLOCK AND WE DO HAVE OUR
TESTING TASK FORCE AND- WITH
THE LAUNCH OF OUR NEW
PERKINELMER LAVALIER ABSOLUTELY
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OTHER
PARTNERS TO. PRIORITIZE AND
WORK WITH LOCAL DEPARTMENTS AND
LOCAL SCHOOLS- AROUND TESTING
IN THE SCHOOL SETTING. SO IS
THE IS ARE THOSE TESTS THAT THE
GOVERNOR PURCHASE GOING TO GO
TO IS JUST TO SCHOOL SITES OR
TO COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
AND THEN BE DEALT OUT TO SCHOOL
SIDES. DID YOU KNOW THAT ANSWER
NOW. IF YOU DON'T IT'S OKAY I'M
JUST. YEAH I THINK MY ANSWER
SPECIFIC TO OUR NEW LAB ARE
PERKINELMER LAB IN A LOT OF OUR
EXPANDING OUR CAPACITY IN
GENERAL FOR A LONGER TERM AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE DOUBLING OUR
CAPACITY OF PCR TESTING ACROSS
THE STATE WITH THIS PURPOSE
NUMBER ELEVEN SCHOOLS AND ONE
OF OUR TOP PRIORITIES. I'M NOT
SURE WHICH SPECIFIC LAB TESTS
YOU ARE REFERRING TO BUT WE CAN
FIND OUT WELL THE RETURN OF
IT'S BEEN IN THE PRESS SOMEONE
SENT OUT A PRESS RELEASE THAT
SAID THEY'RE GOING TO PURCHASE
ALL THESE TESTS AND A GREAT IT
WAS. MY QUESTION IS ARE THOSE
GOING TO GO TO SCHOOLS. SO
WE'LL NEED TO GET BACK TO. OKAY
THANK YOU. THAT IS GOING. I
KNOW IT QUESTIONS ASKED-
EARLIER ABOUT THE TESTING AND
THE REAP THE REPORTING OF THAT
TESTED TESTING AND THEN THE
CASES LINKED TO SCHOOLS AND
WILL BE REPORTED OUT OF THE
DISTRICT LEVEL AT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT LEVEL EVEN MAYBE THE
SCHOOL SITE LEVEL AND OTHERS
CONCERNS ABOUT CONFIDENTIALITY
ALONG THOSE LINES. BUT AND THEN
LUMPING SOME CONCERNED ABOUT
LOVING SCHOOL BASED INFECTION
WITH OVERALL. COUNTY DATA MIGHT
NOT NECESSARILY BE HELPFUL AND
I COME FROM A DISTRICT COURT
NEXT DOOR THEY'RE OPEN. MY
DISTRICT IS SHUT DOWN SO I'M
GETTING BEAT UP ON THIS ISSUE
PRETTY HANDILY BY PARENTS WHO
ARE VERY CONCERNED THAT JUST
YOU KNOW A MILE AWAY SCHOOLS
ARE OPEN KIDSARE GOING THEIR
MODIFIED. THE SCHOOLS AND THAT
ARE OPEN THE SCHOOL THAT IS
OPEN OF MODIFIED BUT IT'S JUST
A- IT'S A REAL CONCERN TO FOLKS
TO. LET MY DISTRICT HAVE KIDS
LIKE ME SO THAT I THINK YOU
THANK YOU. THAT YOU MISTER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANK. THANK YOU
MISTER JUST JUST TO REITERATE I
THINK A LOT OF MY COMMENTS MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS SCHOOL RE OPENING HAS
TO BE I HAVE I WOULD IMAGINE
IT'S THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN
EACH AND SINGLE EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF OUR DISTRICTS IT'S AN
ISSUE THAT WE ARE CONSTANTLY
GETTING QUESTIONS. AS ARCHER
MENTIONED WE ARE ALL PARENTS OF
A PUBLIC SCHOOL CHILDREN AND SO
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE FACE
EVERY SINGLE DAY- I MEAN IT'S
SOMETHING THAT REALLY- WE NEED
I THINK WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE IN TERMS OF.
COORDINATION BETWEEN
DEPARTMENTS EDUCATION BUT FROM
A PUBLIC HEALTH PLUS ALL OUR
VARIOUS LOCAL COUNTIES AND
THEIR DESTRUCTION OF QUIET THE
VERY CHALLENGING ENTERPRISE
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE EVERY
DISTRICT HAS COMPLETED LOCAL
AUTHORITY AND AUTONOMY. BUT I
THINK WE HAVE AS A STAY HAVE TO
DO EVERYTHING. POSSIBLE TO WORK
TO GET OUR SCHOOLS. OPEN
SAFELY- IN A MANNER THAT SAY
FOR OUR TEACHERS SAY FOR OUR
CHILDREN STAY FOR THE STAFF- I
KNOW THAT'S ALL OUR GOAL- I AM
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE-
DIVIDE IN TERMS OF EQUITY
BECAUSE I'M STARTING TO SEE.
MANY OF OUR PRIVATE SCHOOLS IN
SAN FRANCISCO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE OPENING GUIDELINES ARE
STARTING TO OPEN AGAIN. BUT OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE VERY SLOW TO
DO THAT- I WOULD POINT TO A
PARTICULAR MODEL THAT HOUSE-
STARTED WORKING IN TERMS OF
SOME SUCCESS WHICH IS IN SAN
MATEO COUNTY THE OTHER COUNTY
THE REPRESENT. WHERE YOU HAVE
THE DISTRICTS WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THEIR- COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
ENSURE THAT THERE IS A PROPER
TESTING PROTOCOLS. BEING
DEVELOPED- IN THAT TESTING
AGAIN JUST TO FOLLOW UP WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PALM BEACH IS
TALK ABOUT THAT TESTING IS
PROBABLY. ONE OF THE MAJOR
ISSUES FOR TEACHERS AS THEY
STRUGGLE WITH WET WEATHER TO
COME BACK OR NOT SO IN TERMS OF
JUST. GOING TO. BACK TO DOCTOR
POND IS YOU KNOW ARE YOU ARE
YOU GIVING- GUIDANCE TO THE
COUNTIES AND LOCAL DISTRICTS
ABOUT- TESTING PROTOCOLS RIGHT
NOW I THINK. THE IDEA OR THE
CURRENT GUIDELINES PLEASE CREEK
FROM WRONG IS TO. TEST TEACHERS
POTENTIALLY ONCE EVERY TWO
MONTHS MAYBE THAT'S MY LOCAL
GUIDANCE PERSISTS AT THE STATE
GUIDANCE. BUT ARE YOU ARE YOU
STARTING TO- TRY TO DEVELOP
GUIDANCE IN RELATION WITH
SEEDEATER. LET DISTRICTS KNOW
RICK BROTHER YOU KNOW WHAT IS
WHAT IS CONSIDERED SAFE TESTING
PROTOCOLS FOR OUR TEACHERS AS
THEY START TO CONSIDER GOING
BACK. SO YES WE ARE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY AGAIN WITH- THE
WORKGROUP THERE'S A WORKING
GROUP WORKING WHETHER TESTING
TEST FOR THE MINISTRATION- AND
OUR PARTNERS AT. THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND CD AND
ALSO- PARTITION OF THE LABOR
MANAGEMENT REGARDING TESTING I
THINK FOR THE MOST PART
RESOURCES THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT. IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN THERE IS A
CASE THAT THAT PERSON IS TESTED
IN THAT CLOSE CONTACTS ARE
TESTED- INTERNET OF PEOPLE ARE
TESTED THAT IS AFTER THE PARTY
AND THAT IS YOUKNOW THERE ARE
PLENTY OF REASONS FOR THAT AS
WELL AND THEN. WE ARE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THE INVOLVING
TESTING GUIDELINES ABOUT ANY
TESTING GONNA. SWIM WITH THIS
KIND OF BE RELEASE. WHAT IT IS.
THE WORD IT IS ACTUALLY MEETING
AND AGAIN THIS THE SCIENCE THAT
CONTINUES TO EVOLVE YOU KNOW
ACROSS THE NATION AS WELL. SO
I'M TAKING THAT AS A I DON'T
KNOW WHEN YOU WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE SCHOOL YEAR SO I
DON'T KNOW HOW. YOU ANTICIPATE
LOCAL DISTRICTS WOULD HAVE TO
BARGAIN MANY OF THESE
CONTRACTS. ONE OF WHICH IS
STICKING POINTS IS WHICH IS
TESTING- I KNOW YOU'RE NOT A
LABOR. LAWYER BUT YOU KNOW IF
YOU DON'T COME OUT WITH
TESTING. PROTOCOLS FOR OUR
STATE IT PUTS OUR DISTRICTS IN
A VERY TOUGH. POSITIONS A WIN
WITH THOSE GUIDELINES BE
RELEASED WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF
A SCHOOL YEAR AND WITHOUT THIS
KIND ON SEPT MIGHT BE VERY
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
SCHOOLS TO OPEN UP. SO AS AS IS
ALREADY IN OUR JULY GUIDANCE I
THINK THERE ARE SOME POTENTIAL
RECOMMENDATIONS THERE AND AS I
MENTIONED THE MOST IMPORTANT
GUIDELINES AROUND FIRST TESTING
OF SYSTEMATIC CASES AND
CONTACTS. CAN YOU REFERRAL I
APOLOGIZE SINCE JULY FEELS LIKE
FIVE YEARS AGO CAN YOU REFRESH
MY MEMORY AS TO WHAT THOSE
GUYS. GOT WHAT THAT GUIDANCE
WAS. SO IT TALKS ABOUT A
POTENTIAL IN IT YOU ALSO NEED
TO VERY IT BASED ON THE LOCAL
CONDITIONS N THE LOCAL I.
PENOLOGY THE LEVEL OF SPREAD.
OR ONE LITTLE TRANSMISSION AND
THE COMMUNITY THAT IS WHY THERE
IS NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
POTENTIALLY BUT IN THE JULY
GUIDANCE WE TALK ABOUT ONE
PARTICULAR CONDITION TO BE-
TESTING- BELIEVE IT'S 25% EVERY
TWO MONTHS IS A BIT OF A
CONDITION AND AGAIN THE MOST
IMPORTANT RECOMMENDATION THAT
WE'VE ALREADY MADE IS TESTING
RESOURCES FOR. THIS OUR- CASES
AND CONTACTS. I'M SORRY CAN YOU
REPEAT THAT THE BLACK THE LAST
TWO AGAIN NOT I COULDN'T VERY
CLEARLY APOLOGIZE. THE MOST
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTATION THERE
TO BE TESTING CASES AND
CONTACTS IN THE SETTINGS AND
NOT IS ALREADY THE
RECOMMENDATION. TESTING CASES
IN CONTEXT MEANING THAT IF- YOU
GET A POSITIVE SOMEONE GETS A
POSITIVE TEST- BUT THE
CHALLENGES IF YOU'RE TESTING
ONLY EVERY TWO MONTHS. SOMEBODY
COULD HAVE EXPOSED THE ENTIRE
SCHOOL THAT TWO MONTHS. PERIOD.
SO AGAIN THIS YOU KNOW I THINK
ALL OF THE OTHER THINGS WE
TALKED ABOUT AS WELL OUR MODELS
THAT WORK FOR IF YOU HAVE
EVERYONE'S WEARING FACE
COVERINGS USING PHYSICAL SYSTEM
SAYING THE COVERT MODELS AND
THEN AGAIN WHEN YOU HAVE A CASE
YOU CAN IDENTIFY THEM QUICKLY
IDENTIFY THE CONTACTS SO THOSE
ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
PRINCIPLES. RIGHT BUT- COULD
LOOK LET'S LET'S TALK ABOUT TO
ENTER YEAH TWO OTHER VERY HIGH
CONTACT ENVIRONMENTS WHICH IS
WITH PRESENCE AS WELL AS WITH.
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES WERE
HAVING A HEARING ON SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES TOMORROW-
THAT IS NOT THE PROTOCOL FOR HI
THERE ARE CORRECTIONS
DEPARTMENT OR ARE. SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND. WHEN YOU
BRING. CHILDREN SO THOSE
PROBLEMS RIGHT THOSE SETTINGS
ARE RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS ARE
CONGREGATE LIVING SETTINGS AND
IT'S ALSO ALL ADULTS SO AGAIN
YOU KNOW I THINK THE OTHER.
THING THAT- BUT NOTHING KENNEDY
AFTER X. AND OTHERS HAVE
CONTINUE TO YOU KNOW THE STUDY
IN THE YOU KNOW MORE MORE
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT YOUNG
CHILDREN ARE LESS LIKELY TO
HAVE SERIOUS HONEST THEY'RE
LESS LIKELY TO INFECT OTHERS. I
AM IN CONTACT OF EDUCATION- OF
RESOURCES YOU KNOW AND- STUDIES
LESS THAN ONE LESS THAN 10% OF
THE INDEX CASES ARE TYPICALLY
CHILDREN TO CHILDREN MUSCLES
OKAY JUST READ SO IT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT SETTING THAN A
RESIDENTIAL SETTING. WITH ADULT
AND ELDERLY. NO I COMPLETELY
MISSED AND I THINK AS A- WITH
YOUNGER CHILDREN I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND- THE REST LEVEL FOR
THEM I THINK THE CHALLENGE IS
HOW DO YOU CONVINCE THE
TEACHERS AND THE JANITORS AND
THE- PRINCIPLES IN THE
ADMINISTRATORS. IN THE NURSES
TO. COME BACK BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW- MANY OF THEM ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT. GOING BACK. SO THAT IS
EXACTLY WHY WE AREN'T IN THIS
WORKING GROUP AND WORKING
TOGETHER WITH YOU KNOW THE
DIFFERENT PARTNERS TO HELP
DETERMINE THE BEST. K. LINES IN
THE BEST WAY TO GET. TO YOUR
POINT TO HELP GET OUR SCHOOLS
RE OPEN NON NON UNDERSTAND SO
I'VE I'VE I APPRECIATE THAT.
YOUR MEETING BUT WE'RE TO
BASICALLY WE'RE TWO MONTHS INTO
MOST SCHOOL YEAR SO WHEN IS
THIS. GOD IS GOING TO BE COMING
UP WE ARE WE TALKING LIKE WE
GONNA COME OUT IN THE
SUMMERTIME AFTER SCHOOL SO WE
OFFER I THINK I THINK WHAT I'M
TRYING TO CONVEY IS THAT IS NOT
A REQUIREMENT OR RECOMMENDATION
IN ORDER TO REOPEN SCHOOLS I'M
BUT I'M TRYING TO CONVEY THAT
PEOPLE ARE WAITING FOR THIS GUY
HAS TO GO TO REOPEN THE SCHOOLS
AND THAT. YOU HAVE TEACHERS AND
THE TEACHERS ARE DISCUSSING
THIS WITH EACH OF THEIR
DISTRICTS AND AS FAR AS I CAN
TELL IN THE VERY LIMITED
KNOWLEDGE THAT I HAVE TALKING
TO THE FEW DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT IS EVERYBODY IS ALL
OVER THE MAP. IN THIS TESTING
ISSUE IS CENTRAL TO EVERY
BARGAINING DISCUSSION UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. SO WHAT I'M
TRYING TO CONVEY IS WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING HEY. DISTRICTS YOU CAN
DO WHATEVER YOU WANT WE'VE
GIVEN YOU. A LITTLE BIT OF
GUIDANCE BUT NOT REALLY MUCH
DIRECTION. AND GO FORTH AND DO
YOUR BEST I'M SAYING THAT.
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF GUIDANCE
SCHOOLS MOST LIKELY. MAY NOT
OPEN UP BECAUSE TEACHERS AND
STAFF ARE NOT WILLING TO GO
BACK. SO WHERE AREYOU GOING TO
BE ISSUING FURTHER GUIDANCE
BECAUSE- I THINK AGAIN. LET ME
LET ME JUST BE EXTRAORDINARILY
CLEAR. YOUR GUIDANCE MAY
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
SCHOOLS WILL RE OPEN OR NOT.
SEOUL IS A TASK FORCE GOING TO
DO SOMETHING IN THE NEXT WEEK
OR TWO OR WE TALK IN THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THINGS ARE EVOLVING WE
KNOW WE WE'RE YOU KNOW WE'RE
BUILDING THE PLANE IN MID
STREAM WE ALL ADMIT THAT AND
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO DO THE BEST
WE CAN. BUT I THINK THE ANSWER
THAT YOU'VE GIVEN IS COMPLEELY.
NOT UNDERSTANDING WHAT
DISTRICTS AND TEACHERS NEED. SO
WHEN THE TASK FORCE CAN ISSUES
GUIDANCE. YEAH SO I THINK WITH
TIME. I THINK WE NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER TO COME TO AN
AGREEMENT TOGETHER ON THIS WITH
OUR WORK FORCE WE WITH OUR I
THINK YOU HAVE A LEGISLATURE
THAT HAS BEEN- LOOKING TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION BUT I
DON'T KNOW I HAVE BEEN
CONTACTED I DON'T KNOW IF ANY
OF MY OTHER COLLEAGUES HAVE
BEEN CONTACTED WORKS. WERE ALL
LISTED IN THE PHONE BOOK SO-
YES HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU BUT-
AGAIN WE HAVE TO. DO THIS LIKE
IMMEDIATELY. GET A WE WE'VE
WE'VE HEARD THE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF HOW ON SCHOOL ARE
NOT ABLE TO OPEN UP AND AGAIN
THIS IS THIS IS ONE OF THE
CENTRAL ISSUES TO KEEPING CLOSE
KEEPING SCHOOLS CLOSED IN AGAIN
I SEE FROM MY OTHER SCHOOLS
THAT HAVE THE RESOURCES HAVE
THE MONEY DON'T NEED. YOUR
ASSISTANCE BUT THAT IS NOT THE
WAY OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE
SHAPING UP TO BE. SO THEY VERY
MUCH NEED SO ARE YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE READY TO MEET TOMORROW
AND I'LL JUST SAY THAT TO ME I
THINK I THINK ALL OF US READY
TO ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES THERE'S
NOT A SINGLE LEGISLATURE THAT
I'VE- HEARD OF. THAT HASN'T
SAID THAT THIS IS NOT THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN THE
DISTRICT I MEAN. THIS IS THIS
IS GONNA BE THE ONE ISSUE THAT
WE ARE CONSTANTLY HEARING FROM
EVERYBODY ABOUT. ARMS SO I JUST
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP- AND JUST
UNDERSTAND WHAT SORT OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO-
COUNTIES THAT YOU'RE GIVING
ASIDE FROM TESTING JUST JUST
TO- SORT OF CREATE SOME
CONSISTENT PROTOCOLS AND
SCHOOLS ARE REOPENING BECAUSE
AGAIN. SEEMS TO BE. RATHER
BROTHER BROAD AND FAIRLY SHE
CAN SYSTEM WHICH I THINK THE
CHALLENGE. ARE YOU ASKING ABOUT
OVERALL GUIDANCE FOR SCHOOL
GUIDANCE IN A VERY SPECIFIC
SCHOOL SPECIFIC GUIDANCE THAT
WAS ISSUED AS MENTIONED EARLIER
THIS SUMMER AND CONTINUES TO BE
UPDATED- AND THEN THERE'S ALSO-
THE THAT IN THE RE OPENING FREE
MARKET ALSO AGAIN TALKS ABOUT
WHAT TO DO WITH CASES CONTACTS
COHORTS WE ARE AGAIN UPDATING
THAT AS I MENTIONED TO REALLY
TALK ABOUT- BOOK ROLE OF THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND THE
REFERRAL OF THAT THE SCHOOLS
AND HAVING THE SCHOOL LIAISON.
AND REINFORCING THAT IS
REPORTABLE AND I ALSO
MENTIONED- ALL THE CONTACT
TRACING RESOURCES WE ARE ALSO
ALLOCATING AS FAR AS TRAINING
FOR SCHOOLS HAVING A PORTAL FOR
SHARING OF INFORMATION WHEN
THERE ARE CASES IN SCHOOL
SETTINGS AS WELL AS- HAVING A
VIRTUAL ROVING TEAM AT SCHOOL
INVESTIGATORS IF NEEDED IF
LOCAL APARTMENTS NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR THIS
VERY MUCH A LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT ROLE. TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH OUR SCHOOLS AND-
AND THERE'S YOU KNOW WE DEAL
WITH BOTH LOCAL AND STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH HOW PROVIDE ALL
KINDS OF ASSISTANT RELATED TO
OTHER. INFECTIONS IN SCHOOL THE
SETTINGS ALL THE TIME AND WORK
CLOSELY WITH THEIR SCHOOLS IN
THE SETTINGS OF THIS IS JUST
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THAT'S THERE
ARE MORE HER THE INFECTION THAT
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE WORRIED
ABOUT AND FOLLOWING UP ON THAT
THESE RELATIONSHIPS EXIST ON A
LOCAL LEVEL. AND A LOT OF-
CLOSE WORK WITH SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IS HAPPENING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IF YOU ARE JUST GOING TO SEE IF
CALLING. OR CD WITH ABLE TO
AFTER THAT. AS WELL. ABOUT THE
L. A. R. I THINK I WOULD JUST
SAY. IF YOU CAN WITH WITH ANY
OF THE THINGS THAT WE ARE
PRESENTATION I THINK WE TRIED
TO HIGHLIGHT. THE FACT THAT
LOTS OF THE DECISIONS ARE MADE
IT MADE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL I
THINK WE RECOGNIZE THAT IF YOU
WANTED TO GET SOME MORE
SPECIFIC GUIDANCE. THAT WOULD
BE A LITTLE BIT MORE CONCRETE
FOR DISTRICTS YOU DO END UP IN
SITUATIONS WHERE FOR MANY
DISTRICTS THAT BECOMES. MORE OF
A CHALLENGE IN IMPLEMENTING.
SOME FOR EXAMPLE MAY NOT NOT
HAVE THE FACILITIES BASE TO
KEEP. A KID THAT'S GOOD PART.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE. THAT
THAT THAT YOU ALL OF. ME TO
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO BE ONE
OF THE STATE IN TERMS OF FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE BEST WAYS TO OPEN
BUT I THINK WE- IT. IT'S IT
MISTER THEY'RE WALKING.
CONTINUE CONSTANT MONITORING
AND EVEN IF THERE WAS MORE
SPECIFIC ITEMS. I NEED TO
CONSTANTLY MONITOR REVIEW AND
SEE WHAT'S GOING ON HERE TO.
MAKE SURE THAT THINGS ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED- AS AS- THE LAPSES
YOU THINK SHOULD HAVE BEEN. THE
GREAT FAN I JUST WOULD LIKE TO.
THAT OUR- TROOPER. HAS CAN.
PEOPLE LOOKING RE OPENING THAT
INCLUDES OUR LARGEST CITIES
LIKE SAN FRANCISCO AND LA AND
TO FOCUS ON DETECTING TRACING
AND PP AVAILABILITY ALL AS PART
OF EFFORTS TO GET SCHOOLS OPEN.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN ON HE STARTED A LAST WEEK
A WITH THE BIG CITY MAYORS AND
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THAT WE
MUST WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE
THAT OUR SCHOOL CAN OPEN SAFELY.
THE SUPER TECHNOLOGIST AGAIN
URGE YOU TO INCORPORATE-
TESTING INTO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS I THINK IT'S VERY
CRITICAL. AS I'M HEARING FROM
FROM MY DISTRICTS AND FROM. MY
TEACHERS BUT I THINK IT'S
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT THAT
THERE ARE. BECOME SOME GREATER.
RAIDER GUIDANCE AROUND TESTING
JUST BECAUSE THERE IS THERE IS
REAL FEAR BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
TELLING EVERYONE TO STAY HOME.
AND WE HAVE A GROUP OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO GO TO WORK AND WE SEEM
WITH THEIR INFECTION RATES ARE
SO I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND AS
WORKERS ARE BEING ASKED TO
LEAVE THEIR HOMES AND GO INTO A
WORKPLACE ENVIRONMENT- THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR GUIDANCE AND
GUIDELINES THAT PROVIDE THEM-
WORKPLACE SAFETY SO I THINK
IT'S TOTALLY REASONABLE
EXPECTATION AND I HOPE THAT YOU
ALL. THE CORPORATE THAT INTO
YOUR- INTO YOUR- DIALOGUE
CORRECT GO BACK TO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ON THE QUESTION MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH LAST.
WHICH IS. TESTING TEACHERS
WE'VE MADE A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHICH THIS
COMMITTEE. SIGNED OFF ON TO
INCREASE TESTING
INFRASTRUCTURE- THAT WAS WHEN
THE QUESTIONS WE ASKED- HERE
MISS POSNER WAS SIGNED OFF ON
THESE LETTERS. SO WE ROLL WHAT.
WHAT KIND OF TESTING IS GOING
TO GET SET ASIDE FOR. TEACHERS
AND EDUCATORS. JUST HOMES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO I'M
I'M NOT I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH
WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO. MAYBE
A BETTER QUESTION FOR- ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN OUR HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES UNIT- HOWEVER I
CAN SPEAK TO THE PERKINS ON OUR
CONTRACT- THAT- DOCTOR UPON
RECENTLY REFERRED TO AND- YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE WITHIN
THAT CONTRACT I KNOW THAT THE
PRIORITY IS FOR. I'M LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES- TESTING.
SINCE THERE WOULD BE SOME-
LEVEL OF PRIDE THAT THAT IS
WHAT I'M REFERRING TO IS THAT-
I APOLOGIZE I FORGOT THE
ORGANIZATIONS FOR THE COMPANY'S
NAME. BUT THE- THE CONTRACTS
THAT THERE WOULD BE SOME LEVEL
OF PRIORITY FOR- PEOPLE WHO
WORK IN EDUCATION BERMAN.
ABSOLUTELY AND I BELIEVE IT'S
DOCTOR UPON TO BE TO GET INTO
SPECIFICS BUT CERTAINLY- LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES HAVE THE
PRIORITY WITHIN THAT CONTRACT.
THANK YOU I FOR ONE LAST
QUESTION FOR THE DOCTOR POND-
AND FEEL FREE IF YOU WANNA
LAUGH RATE ON THAT LAST
QUESTION WITH HEAR YOUR
RESPONSE TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LONG BEACH. WHICH WHICH IS- YOU
YOU YOU HAVE OUR SCHOOLS ARE
NOT O BE OPEN FOR ALL STUDENTS
WITH THE COUNTIES IN THE RED
TIER. CAN CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH HOW YOU DETERMINED-
THAT TEAR WOULD BE. SORT OF. OR
JUST BE BASED YOU KNOW WHAT'S
WHAT WAS THE REASONING BEHIND
BEHIND CHOOSING THAT TEAR
PERSON ANOTHER TEAR. SURE AND
JUST TO QUICKLY RESPOND YOUR
OTHER QUESTION AGAIN TO YOU
KNOW AS I EARLIER MENTIONED.
AND AS FAR AS OUR TESTING TEST
SCORES AND THE NEW- BRANCH LAB
FOR THE STATE DEPARTMENT OUR
SCHOOLS OUR ABSOLUTE PRIORITY
AND AS I MENTIONED WE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY AGAIN WITH.
EDDIE PRACTITIONERS FROM LABOR
AND MANAGEMENT- AND THE BOARD
OF EDUCATION AND ADMINISTRATION
FOR- THE TESTING RESOURCES
AFRICAN ONLINE ABSOLUTELY WAS-
AS FAR AS DOUBLING ARCTIC
POLICY ONE THAT PRIORITIES IS
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE TESTING
IN SCHOOLS. FOR THE PARTIES I
MENTIONED AS FAR AS OF THE RED
TEARS SO. IT WAS A COMBINATION
OF LOOKING AT SORT OF BASICALLY
CASE ATES AND TEST POSITIVITY
SO OUR PRIOR. FUNNY DATA
MONITORING LIST WHAT WHAT WE
HAD IN THE SUMMER AND IN JULY
WE FIRST HAVE THAT RE OPENING
FRAMEWORK. WE HAD ALSO SAID
THAT A SCHOOL COULD REOPEN
AFTER TWO WEEKS OFF OF NOT
MONITORING THIS AND- THAT SORT
OF GENERAL CUT OFF AT THAT
LEVEL OR- A CASE RATE OVER
SEVEN AND A TEST POSITIVITY
OVER. CENTER SO A LOT IS ABOUT
THAT WE DO NOT AS WIDESPREAD
COMMITTEE TRANSMISSION. AND OF
COURSE THERE'S A HUGE SPECTRUM
ABOVE THAT IT COULD BE RIGHT AT
THE BORDER OR COULD BE WAY OFF
OF THAT SO WE DID SAY. JUST
SORT OF BACKING INTO THAT AS
WELL THAT AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
THE TIMES THEY OPEN AT THE
LOWER END OF THAT. AND THAT
ONE'S- COUNTY WAS IN A STABLE
RANGE AND NOT READ TEAR OR A-
PRIOR TO THE FLOOR PLAN WHEN IT
WAS JUST OFF ACCOUNTED IN A
MINDLESS. YOU'RE OFTEN IN THAT
RANGE OF THE- THE RED TEAR THAT
RANGE OF CASE THREE AND TEST
POSITIVITY AND YOUR STABLE FOR
AT LEAST TWO WEEKS OF THAT AT.
A LEVEL TWO. ARE CONSIDERING
OPENING. THANK YOU JUST A JUST
FOLLOW UP. ON THE PREVIOUS
QUESTION I THINK IT'S AN FOR AS-
WE TO YOU KNOW INCREASE OUR
TESTING CAPACITY THE THAT
AMOUNT OF. FOR TEN NUMBER YOU
KNOW RANGE OF TEST NUMBERS GET
COMMUNICATED TO THE DISTRICTS
STATEWIDE THEY CAN HAVE SOME
LEVEL OF EXPECTATION HOW MANY-
TESTING MIGHT HAVE ACCESS TO I
MEAN AGAIN THIS IS A VERY
CENTRAL ISSUE IS ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT- KEEP TEACHERS FROM
GOING BACK SO I THINK IF THERE.
IS AN EXPECTATION THAT IT'S I
DON'T KNOW A HUNDRED THOUSAND
TESTS ARE MILLION TESTS OR TEN
MILLION WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS
ON I THINK THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL SO IT'S NOT AN ABSTRACT
WE HAVE. TEST AVAILABLE I MEAN
DISTRICTS DISTRICTS HAVE X.
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES INDEX
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THEY I THINK
THEY REALLY NEED TO KNOW YOU
KNOW WHAT TO DO JUST ARE THEY
ONLY GONNA GET LIKE. FIVE
THOUSAND TIMES PER DISTRICT OR
THIS CAN BE A LOT. Là MORE
SORT REALLY TRYING TO HAVE A
NUMERIC. RANGE OF WHAT MIGHT BE
POSSIBLE AND OBVIOUSLY THAT
CHANGES AS WE RAMP IT UP. BUT
AS YOU KNOW I THINK WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- I KNOW I HAVE MORE
QUESTIONS WELL BUT I'M GONNA
HOLD OFF BECAUSE I THINK WE GOT
TO A LOT AND WE HAVE ONE MORE
PANEL. WHICH YOU REALLY WANT TO
HEAR FROM. LOCALS MISTER
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND I JUST
CAN I JUST MAKE ONE WANT ONE
JUST ONE QUICK STATEMENT AND I
THINK IT. IS REALLY HE DIDN'T
SAY IT BUT I THINK HE- HE SEES
IT. AND PROBABLY THE WAY I DO-
WE HAVE A GLARING CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUE EMERGING IN THE STATE IN
THAT. PRIVATE SCHOOLS ARE
OPENING AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE
NOT. MORE VETTING ON A VACCINE
WHAT WE SHOULD PROBABLY DO IS
BE MUCH BETTER PREPARED FOR
THIS TO BE AROUND FOR SOME TIME
AND GET TESTING INDOOR SCHOOLS
THAT WE CAN SOMEWHAT. ATTEMPT
TO CONTROL THAT ENVIRONMENT BUT
THIS IS I THINK THE
CONVERSATION YOU'RE HEARING
TODAY THE TOPIC I JUST
MENTIONED IT IS I THINK.
EVERYBODY I WATCH IT BECAUSE
IT'S COMMON. YEAH CONVERSELY
I'M SORRY CAN I ADD TO THAT
BECAUSE I WAS THE ONLY WOMAN ON
THIS PANEL I WILL SAY WE KNOW
THAT WOMEN ARE BEING
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
CHILDREN STAYING HOME TO WERE
DROPPING ON THE WORK FORCE TO
LARGER NUMBERS IT'S BECAUSE-
IT'S- I KNOW. IT'S HARD FOR ME
TO GET UP HERE TO DO MY JOB-
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY IN OUR JOBS. SO AND
I KNOW INFECTS FATHERS TO BED
BUT MOTHERS IN PARTICULAR AND
WE HAVE SPENT MORE TIME AND WE
HAD I THINK CLEAR GUIDANCE ON
BARS AND MOVIE THEATRES THAN WE
HAVE ON SCHOOLS. WHAT IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE AVAILABLE
FOR THE SCHOOLS THE TESTING
WITHOUT SPECIFIC GUIDELINES OR
CLEAR GUIDELINES I THINK WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS LIKE WE'RE TALKING
OF COURSE WHAT I THINK THAT
SOUNDS GREAT. BUT IF IT'S NOT
REQUIRED THEN WE HAVE SOME
SCHOOLS THAT ARE OPENING UP
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
OPENING UP WITHOUT ANY TYPE OF-
JUST MASKS BASICALLY THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENED A VISTA UNIFIED.
AND THEN EVERYBODY IN THE
SURROUNDING. AREA T. PARENTS
ARE THINKING OH MY GOD THAT YOU
CAN OPEN UP LIKE THAT I DON'T
WANT MY SCHOOL TO OPEN UP LIKE
THAT SO. WE JUST HAVEN'T BEEN
VERY CLEAR WITH OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WE HAVE BEEN CLEAR
WITH THEIR TEACHERS. WE'RE NOT
SAYING HOW MUCH WE'RE GOING TO-
PROVIDE AS FAR AS TESTING- IF
COHORTS ARE GONNA KEEP KIDS
SAFE THAN REQUIRE COHORTS BUT
LIKE LET'S. LET'S BE CLEAR SO
KIDS CAN GO BACK TO SCHOOL I
THINK RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS WE'RE CREATING THE
PERFECT STORM. WHERE PRIVATE
SCHOOLS CAN FIGURE IT OUT
THEY'VE ENOUGH MONEY TO FIGURE
IT OUT. WE HAVE SOME PUBLIC
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE JUST
GO IN. LIKE THE WILD WEST IN
AND RUNNING INTO PROBLEMS AND
THOSE ARE THE STORIES WERE SEEN
AND SO. IT'S PREVENTING
EVERYBODY ELSE WHO REALLY NEEDS
THAT TO GET BACK THESE BIGGER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO I JUST I
IMPLORE- THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND I KNOW
CITIES TRYING TO DO WHAT THEY
HAVE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM. BUT
WE'VE GOT TO BE CLEAR WITH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SO THAT THEY
CAN HAVE A REAL OPEN PLAN IT'S
OUR KIDS. BACK TO SCHOOL.
THAT'S ALL THAT'S MY- MOTHERLY
PLEASE I THANK AMEN AND ALL
THIS FURTHER WHAT I SAID IN THE
INTRO JUST AYE. I WENT OVER
THAT QUICKLY BUT- THERE ARE A
DOZEN OR SO. MAJOR DISTRICTS
HERE. IN SACRAMENTO ON THE DEED
A STORY JUST TWO DAYS AGO. AND
LITERALLY HALF ARE ON THEIR WAY
TO RE OPENING. AND THOSE ARE
THE HALF OF THE DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE THE LOWEST NUMBER. OF FREE
OR REDUCED LUNCH GETS. SO THE
FAMILIES. THAT ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. THAT YOU KNOW HAVE
SOME. YOU KNOW IT'S- GREAT
STRUGGLE IN AND MAKING IT ALL
WORK FOR THEIR- THEIR KIDS ARE
THE ONES THAT AREN'T. AREN'T
DOING WHAT THE WITH THE PRIVATE
SCHOOLS ARE DOING SOME NOT SO
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES. ON THE WERE ALL
IN THE SAME. REGION AS WELL SO
AS FAR AS PURPLE AND ORANGE AND
RED. BUT A REALITY THE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE OPENING. I
ESSENTIALLY. OPENING JUST LIKE
A PRIVATE SCHOOL SO. THERE IS A
HAVE AND HAVE NOT. EQUATION
THERE RIGHT HERE LOCALLY. SO
WITH THAT WE WENT TO NOW GET TO
OUR- SECOND PANEL WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH THE SAN DIEGO.
COUNTY OFFICE OF ED IN HERE
FROM. THERE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT. DR PAUL- GOT
HOLD. THE SECRET MAYBE. MY HAVE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MCCARTY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN CHAIRMAN
PARTY MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND IN PARTICULAR.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GONZALEZ
FLETCHER THANKYOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT LEADERSHIP
AND OUR REGION. IN AN EFFORT TO
TRY NOT TO. BE REDUNDANT SOME
OF THE FOLKS THAT HAVE GONE
BEFORE US SAID I FIRST OF ALL
JUST WANT TO. THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND I THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR COMMITTEE TO
PUBLIC EDUCATION HOLD HARMLESS-
DURING THE TIME THAT THIS WAS
IN QUESTION TO HAVE TO GO
THROUGH BUDGET CUTS REDUCTIONS
POTENTIAL LAYOFFS ALONG WITH
NAVIGATING. THE PANDEMIC WOULD
HAVE BEEN EXTRAORDINARY IT'S
BEEN CHALLENGING ENOUGH WE'VE
EXPERIENCED LOSS IN OUR OWN
COMMUNITIES AND- I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT.
TO IT TO GIVE US TIME TO ADJUST
TO IT IT IS SO MUCH APPRECIATED
THE LOCAL LEVEL- AS OF TODAY WE
HAVE THIRTY THREE OF OUR FORTY
TWO DISTRICTS IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. OPEN TO SOME OR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION WHETHER
THAT'S THROUGH ITINERANT
SERVICES WITH SPECIAL LEAD
APPOINTMENTS- IT FOR MOST
VULNERABLE KIDS. OR HYBRID
SCHEDULES- BUT IN IN MOST
CASES- WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY.
EIGHTY TWO TO EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND KIDS IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS DISTRICT SCHOOLS RIGHT
NOW ON CAMPUSES AS WE SPEAK WE
HAVE SEVEN ADDITINAL UP
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS. IN OUR CHARTER SCHOOL
CAMPUSES. AND AS OF LAST WEE
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR-
OF FOLKS IT AT THE COUNTY-
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND
PUBLIC HEALTH. REPORTED THIRTY
NINE CASES OF KOBE NINETEEN
WITH POTENTIAL SCHOOL BASED
EXPOSURE IN THE PREVIOUS TWO
WEEKS. THIS DOES NOT MEAN THAT
THOSE CASES WERE CONTRACTED AT
SCHOOL. THE VAST MAJORITY WERE
CONTRACTED OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL
BUT MOST RECENTLY WE ARE AWARE
OF TWO OUTBREAKS IN OUR- IN OUR
SCHOOLS IN IN BOTH OF THOSE
SITUATIONS- THESE WERE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THE
GUIDELINES. OF MASKS DISTANCING
WERE NOT FOLLOWED A STAFF
PARTY- WITH A POTLUCK WITHOUT
MASKS. ANNA IN THE EXPERIENCE
THAT- GONZALEZ FLETCHER TOOK
YOU WAITED EARLIER- WHEN IT
COMES TO STAFF TESTING WE'VE
BEEN VERY FORTUNATE. TO HAVE-
OUR PUBLIC ART OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SUPPORT TESTING.
THEIR FORTY TWO TESTING CENTERS
ACROSS THIS COUNTY- FIVE OF
THOSE CENTERS HAVE BEEN
DEDICATED EXCLUSIVELY. FOR
STAFF EMPLOYEES- AND THEY MADE
THE COMMITMENT TO TEST- EXACTLY
WHAT THE CDPH GUIDELINES STATE
THAT'S 50% OF. ALL SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES EACH MONTH FOR A 100%
EVERY TWO MONTHS- ASSUMING
EVERY SCHOOL OR OPENNESS ANY OF
COUNTY THAT'S WE HAVE OVER
EIGHTY THOUSAND SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES. ACROSS OUR COUNTY
AND THOSE TESTS ARE ARE.
TYPICALLY A HUNDRED DOLLARS
EACH. I ARE ARE COUNTY HEALTH
WAS ABLE TO. THAT RATE WITH YOU
LOOKS DOWN TO FIFTY FOR SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES THREE FIFTY DOLLARS
TESTING FORTY THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES A MONTH IS- AN
EXTRAORDINARY EXPENSE WE ARE
FORTUNATE. THAT THEY MADE THAT
COMMITMENT TO OUR SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES IN THIS REGION AND WE
ARE NOT A- RESPONSIBLE FOR
PAYING FOR THAT. I ALSO WANT TO
TALK ABOUT JUST RE OPENING
SCHOOLS I THINK YOU CAN'T TALK
ABOUT REOPENING SCHOOLS
WITHOUT. WHAT ARE THE KIDS ARE
IN OUR PARENTS OF FAMILIES HAVE
GONE THROUGH WE HAD TO SPEND. A
LOT OF TIME ON JUST ZERO G. AND
SAFETY MEASURES CREATING VIDEOS
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S THE
PARENTS AND STUDENTS.
UNDERSTOOD THE DYNAMICS WHEN
COMING BACK TO SCHOOL AND WHAT
THOSE THINGS MEANT- WE ALSO
CREATED A BANK OF RESOURCES TO
TALK ABOUT RACE AND SOME OF THE
ISSUES. THAT HAVE GONE ON
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES. WE
CAN'T JUST BRING THE KIDS BACK
AND DIVE DIRECTLY INTO THE
ACADEMICS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY-
WHAT WERE THE WHAT WERE THE
THINGS GOING ON IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES. THAT WE
COULD BEST SUPPORT THEM WHEN
THEY COME BACK TO SCHOOL AND
HOW COULD WE PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
TEACHERS AND ADULTS IN THOSE
SITUATIONS. ONE OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WHEN
YOU FOLLOW THE HEALTH
GUIDELINES. YOU THERE'S NO WAY
WE SAID THIS BACK IN MARCH WE
IMMEDIATELY WENT INTO RECOVERY
YOU CANNOTBRING BACK MOR THAN
3250% YOUR KIDS ON CAMPUS AT
THE SAME TIME. AND WITH THAT
COMES YEAR AM PM SESSIONS YOUR
HYBRID SCHEDULES. AND IMAGINE
AN EDUCATOR WHO HAS CHILDREN OF
THEIR OWN. COMING BACK TO
REPORT ON CAMPUS DEVELOPING.
LESSON BANKS. THE KIDS HAVE TO
ACCESS ONLINE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY. WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THEIR OWN CHILDREN WHEN THE
SCHOOLS ARE ONLY OPEN HALF DAY
OUR KIDS ARE GOING TO SCHOOL TO
THREE DAYS A WEEK. AS A COUNTY
OFFICE WE PROVIDE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS DIRECTLY TO OUR KIDS
WHO ARE INCARCERATED. COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS HOMELESS FOSTER YOUTH
WE ACTUALLY HAD TO BUILD IN
CHILDCARE STIPENDS. TO SUPPORT.
OUR OWN TEACHERS AND CLASSIFIED
STAFF COMING BACK TO WORK.
BECAUSE THERE IS NOT. THE
ACCESSIBILITY EVEN AFTER FULLY
UTILIZING AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. FOR KIDS. TO BE TO
GET THAT CHILD CARE THE WHOLE
DAY. ONE OF THE OTHER
UNINTENDED ANY THINGS THAT
WE'VE BEEN- DO WE HAVE WE SET
UP SEVERAL TASK FORCES. FOR
MOST VULNERABLE KIDS ONE OF
THOSE BEEN IMMIGRATION TASK
FORCE. AND SINCE MARCH WE HAVE
FORTY NINE THOUSAND AMERICAN
BORN STUDENTS LIVING NOW IN
BAJA CALIFORNIA ALONE. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THOSE CHILDREN ARE
FROM CALIFORNIA. AND THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THOSE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN ARE FROM SAN DIEGO WE
ESTIMATE ABOUT EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND KIDS WE DON'T KNOW
WILL COME BACK WEEK 80% THE
JOBS LOST IN OUR REGION OUR
TOURISM RETAIL. HIGHER
EDUCATION PRIVATE SCHOOLS SO WE
ARE ACTUALLY IN THE PROCESS OF
BUILDING A BI NATIONAL SCHOOL
WHERE KIDS CAN GET A DIPLOMA
THAT'S BOTH GOOD IN MEXICO AND
THE UNITED STATES TO SUPPORT
OUR KIDS BUT I CANNOT IMAGINE
AFTER THE HOLD HARMLESS.
EXPIRES WHAT THE FISCAL CLIFF
COULD LOOK LIKE NOT JUST FROM A
BUDGETARY STANDPOINT BUT ALSO
FROM. A LOSS OF EIGHTY A-
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT MANY OF
OUR CHILDREN HAVE HAVE LEFT ARE
ARE NOT PRESIDING RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA. THEY PREVIOUSLY DID
SO I WILL TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE DIGITAL DIVIDE WE
HAVE PICNIC MADE INCREDIBLE
STRIDES AND HOW WE'RE LOOKING
AT THIS IS A BASIC RIGHT JUST
LIKE POWER. LIKE WATER
ELECTRICITY AND EVEN IF IN A
SITUATION WHERE STUDENTS ARE
NOW GOING TO BE BACK AT SCHOOL
IT IS IMPORTANT MORE THAN EVER
A 100% OF THEM ARE CONNECTED.
BECAUSE MANY OF THOSE
ACTIVITIES WILL STILL CONTINUE
IN A VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENT. IN IN
MARCH WHEN WE DID A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT OF OUR COUNTY. OVER
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS
WERE UNDER CONNECTED WE HAVE
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
SO ROUGHLY ONE OUT OF FIVE KIDS.
AS WE WORK THROUGH THE
SITUATION GIVE A COUPLE
EXAMPLES OF HOW WE'VE BEEN
TREATING. OUR SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
OPENED WE HAVE A UGH OUR COUNTY
OFFICE. OF HEALTH HAS A CONTACT
TRACING TEAM THAT'S DEDICATED
TO K. TWELVE EDUCATION- WHEN
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED A SOMEONE
WHO HAS. BEEN EXPOSED TO
SOMEONE WHO TESTED POSITIVE.
THE PRESS THE SUPERINTENDENT IS
ALERTED. THE PRINCIPAL
CLASSROOM SHUTS DOWN. FOR TWO
WEEKS IN AN ABUNDANCE OF
CAUTION THE KIDS BY TEN THIRTY
AFTER PICKING UP MATERIALS
PIVOT INTO DISTANCE LEARNING
FOR FOURTEEN DAYS. RESUME BACK
ON CAMPUS. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
OUR DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL WITH THE RE OPENING
PLANS WHEN FOLLOWING. THE
GUIDELINES SET FORTH BY THE
STATE WITH MASKS DISTANCING.
VENTILATION AND REALLY JUST THE
SPIRIT INTENT OF WHAT THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO DO AND THAT'S KEEP.
SMALLER GROUPS OF KIDS ON
CAMPUS AT A TIME I ONCE AGAIN
WANT TO JUST THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR ALL OF YOUR
SUPPORT. WE MET HAD. A NUMBER
OF SITUATIONS WE'VE HAD TO- WE
LIKE THE TEST KITCHEN I GUESS
IN IN SAN DIEGO HAVE BEEN
OPENED FIRST BUT NOW THE
SUPPORT WE'VE RECEIVED FROM CVS
AND OUR OUR LAWMAKERS IS
EXTRAORDINARY. THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME- PRESENT TODAY AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU WILL CERTAINLY
COME BACK TO YOU NEXT WE HAVE.
BILL SIMMONS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE SAN JUAN TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION BELIEVE DOWN HERE
IN THE CAPITAL ROOM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON GO HEAD. THANK YOU-
I'M BUILT THEM IN A SIXTH GRADE
ENGLISH AND HISTORY TEACHER AND
PRESIDENT OF THE FAN ONE
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF EDUCATIONAL
PRACTITIONERS. PRACTITIONERS
CAME INTO EDUCATION BECAUSE
THEY CARE ABOUT STUDENTS AND
WANT THEM TO LEARN AND GROW.
ALL OF US WANT TO BE WITH OUR
STUDENTS. WHEN IT IF THEY-
UNTIL THEN WE HAVE ACCEPTED THE
CHALLENGE THAT THIS PANDEMIC
HAS CREATED AND WE ARE WORKING
TIRELESSLY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS IN A VIRTUAL
CONTACT. PUTTING IN TEN TO
TWELVE HOUR DAYS TO GET IT ALL
DONE. I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
OF THE THINGS ARE ASSOCIATION
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE SAN
JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
HAS DONE TO PLAN FOR CALL RE
OPENING. WE LEARNED A LOT FROM
LISTENING TO STUDENT. AMYLASE
AND STAFF ABOUT THEIR
CHALLENGES FROM THE SPRING AND
USE THAT FEEDBACK TO IMPROVE
DISTANCE LEARNING FOR THE FALL.
THERE ARE SEVERAL APPS ACTIONS
THAT WE TOOK. WE JOINTLY
SELECTED PRACTITIONERS TO
DEVELOP A BANKABLE THAN
FOCUSING A CENTRAL FAN. THANKS
OF STANDARDS ARE THE POWER
STANDARDS IN EACH GRADE LEVEL
AND CONTENT AREA. THE LESSONS
WERE PUT INTO A LESSON BANK
THAT COULD EITHER SERVE TO
SUPPORT A FLIPPED CLASSROOM OR
TO BE USED AS MODEL LESSONS TO
LEARN FROM. WE WERE ALSO ABLE
TO AGREE UPON A DEFINITION OF
THE SYNCHRONOUS TIME. AND
CRAFTED OUR AGREEMENT TO ALLOW
PRACTITIONERS. CHANGE DESIGN
THEIR SCHEDULE TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF EACH OF THEIR STUDENTS.
THE SCHEDULES WERE MEANT TO BE
RESPONSES. AND FLEXIBLE JEFF AS
WE WOULD BE IF WE WERE IN
PERSON. TO ALLOW TEACHERS TO
MOVE BETWEEN THE WHOLE GROUP
INSTRUCTION. SMALL GROUP
SUPPORT AND ONE ON ONE
INTERVENTION. ELEMENTARY
STUDENTS ALSO HAVE TIME EACH
WEEK WITH A MUSIC R. P. OR
FINANCE SPECIALIST IN ADDITION
TO TIME WITH THE CLASSROOM
TEACHERS. OUR AGREEMENT ALL THE
LAYERS AND MORE SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS WHO NEED MORE. IN
ADDITION TO TIME WITH THE
CLASSROOM TEACHER ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS RECEIVE
THIRTY MINUTES OF DESIGNATED
BLT INSTRUCTION EACH DAY.
STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
RECEIVE THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THEY REQUIRE. SUCH AS
SPEECH AND ADAPTIVE PETE. WITH
ADDITIONAL LEARNING NEEDS SUCH
AS RESOURCE SUPPORT OR
INTERVENTION ARE PROVIDED THE
SERVICES LIKE EITHER THE
CLASSROOM TEACHER ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE REQUIRED MINUTES FOR
ALL STUDENTS. OR MAYBE PROVIDED
BY A SPECIALIST IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
CLASSROOM TEACHER. ALSO OUR
AGREEMENTS CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A SOCIAL WORKER
OR COUNSELOR TO ADDRESS SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL NEEDS THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING.
THESE PROFESSIONALS ALSO WITH
THIS FAMILY IN SECURING
RESOURCES SUCH AS TECHNOLOGY.
WHO ARE HOUSING. THE SAME ONE
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
SAN JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT ALSO JOINTLY
RECOGNIZED THE NEED TO ALLOW
EVERY STUDENT AND FAMILY
OPTIONS TO MEET THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS THIS SUMMER
WE EXPANDED OUR HOME SCHOOL AND
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAMS TO
MEET PARENTAL REQUESTS FOR A
CHOICE OF EDUCATIONAL OPTIONS.
OVER ONE THOUSAND STUDENTS HAVE
MOVED TO THESE OPTIONS GIVING
PARENTS A CHOICE OF EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS DURING THIS
UNPRECEDENTED TIME. WELL THERE
ARE MANY THINGS WE HAVE DONE TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
DURING DISTANCE LEARNING WE
CONTINUE TO THOUGHT TO PLAN FOR
A PHASETRANSITION TO IN PERSON
SERVICES. WE CREATED WAYS TO
ALLOW THE RESUMPTION OF ONE ON
ONE ASSISTANCE FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION. THEN WE PERMITTED TO
FOCUSING ON BRINGING BACK SMALL
GROUPS OF STUDENTS THAT RECEIVE
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES.
THAT WILL BEGIN ON MONDAY
NOVEMBER SECOND. OUR WORK NOW
FOCUSES ON RETURNING TO IN
PERSON SERVICES OUR YOUNGEST
YELL STUDENTS. WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME REVAMPING OUR HYBRID
PLANT. OUR ORIGINAL PLANS THAT
WE DRAFTED IN THE SUMMER ARE NO
LONGER VIABLE DUE TO CHANGING
GUIDELINES STATE REQUIREMENTS.
AND ARE LEARNING FROM THOSE WHO
ARE ALREADY OPEN. AS WE SHIFT
FURTHER IN PERSON SERVICES WE
NEED YOUR HELP. FIRST PLEASE
CONSIDER CREATING GUIDELINES
FOR THE EDUCATIONAL PROCESS BUT
AVOID GETTING INTO THE WE- AS
YOU CAN SEE BY PROVIDING US
WITH A LOOSE FRAMEWORK OF THE
MINIMUM NUMBER OF INSTRUCTIONAL
MINUTES. WE WERE ABLE TO MEET
THE ACADEMIC NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS AND ADDRESS
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL NEEDS IN
WAYS THAT WERE RESPONSIVE AND
ADAPTABLE. IT ALLOWED US TO USE
LOCAL INFORMATION TO DRIVE
DECISIONS WHICH IS A MUCH
BETTER THAN IF WE WERE
CONSTRAINED WITH ONE SIZE FITS
ALL REGULATION. IF YOU THINK
ABOUT NEXT STEPS PLEASE GIVE
LOCAL DISTRICTS AND THEIR
ASSOCIATIONS THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DEVELOP PROGRAMS THAT MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR LOCAL STUDENTS.
AND FAMILIES. SECOND PLEASE
PROTECT OUR SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION FUNDING FOR THE
NEXT SCHOOL YEAR BY CONTINUING
WITH THE HOLD HARMLESS APPROACH
SAN JUAN HAS CONTINUED TO USE
THOSE DOLLARS TO ADDRESS THE
ACADEMIC SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS BY
INCREASING COUNSELORS NURSES
SOCIAL WORKERS AND ACADEMIC
INTERVENTION TEACHERS AS YOU
KNOW THE INFORMATION SOURCE OF
MUCH OF THAT FUNDING OMES FROM
FREE AND REDUCED MEAL
APPLICATION. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC FAMILIES ARE NOT
COMPLETING THE APPLICATION TO
RECEIVE THE MEALS AS THEY HAVE
IN THE PAST. MANY OF THEM ARE
FOCUSED ON KEEPING OR SECURING
EMPLOYMENT OR HOUSING. THE
IMPACT ON DISTRICTS LIKE OURS
IS THAT THE APPLICATION
COMPLETION RATE IS WAY DOWN.
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS IN NEED
HAS NOT DROPPED. WELL THE NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
HAS ACTUALLY INCREASED. BUT THE
NUMBERS FROM THE FORM COVER UP
THAT REALITY. WE NEED YOU TO
CONSIDER THE UNINTENTIONAL
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF DOING
BUSINESS AS USUAL DURING THIS
UNUSUAL TIME. THIRD PROVIDE US
WITH THE NECESSARY FUNDS FOR
THE THINGS SCHOOLS DID NOT NEED
BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC BEGAN. WE
NEED TO SEND THE PRECINCT
TESTING CAPACITY. AND
CONVENIENT TESTING SITE FOR
STUDENTS FAMILIES AND STAFF. I
KNOW YOU HAVE SEEN THIS
INFOGRAPHIC. REGARDING HEALTH
CRITICAL TESTING IS TO CONTROL
COVERT NINETEEN. THE CURRENT
STATUS OF TESTING IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE WE NEED RELIABLE
CONSISTENT TESTING TO REDUCE
THE RISK OF ANY PERSON
SCHOOLING AND STUDENTS AND
STAFF SAFE. INCREASES FUNDING
FOR THINGS SUCH AS DAILY
TEMPERATURE TAKING EFFORT TO HE
FIRST TO THE AND- WE NEED
RESOURCE FOR MATERIALS AND
SUPPLIES TO KEEP SCHOOLS CLEAN
AND TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW ALL OF
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
GUIDELINES. SHOULD BE ABLE TO
FOLLOW ALL THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY GUIDELINES. HELP BUILD
CONFIDENCE IN OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES BY MAKING SURE
EVERYONE OVER THE AGE OF TWO IS
REQUIRED TO WEAR A MASK. IF YOU
NEED A MASK TO GO GROCERY
SHOPPING. WE NEED THAT IN
SCHOOLS. HELP US TO
SUFFICIENTLY RESOURCE
MEANINGFUL CONTRACT RACING.
THAT ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL TO DO
IT IN A TIMELY AND EFFICIENT
WAY IT TAKES ADDITIONAL
PERSONNEL TO DO IT IN A TIMELY
AND EFFICIENT WAY. FINALLY
PLEASE KNOW THAT WE WANT WHAT
WE WANT IS TO BE WITH OUR
STUDENTS WE WOULD MEAN THE
FIRST ONE IS TO BRING ALL
STUDENTS BACK. IF IT WERE STATE.
WE CARE ABOUT THE EDUCATIONAL
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS. AND WE CARE ABOUT
THEIR PHYSICAL WELL BEING. WE
THINK WE CAN ADDRESS BOTH IF
YOU HELP US WITH SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES MOVING FORWARD. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
NEXT WE HAVE DOCTORS CORBEAU
WITH THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS WHO'S GOING TO BE
REMOTE. I REMOTE PARTICIPANT.
PLEASE BEGIN THANK YOU. OH
SORRY IT WAS A LITTLE TOO LATE
FROM THE CAMERA YEAH MY NAME IS
JACQUES CORPS OF ON THE
PEDIATRIC HOSPITALISTS IN
ANTIOCH. AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA.
REPRESENTING OVER FIVE THOUSAND
PEDIATRICIANS HERE IN THE
STATE- FIRST OF ALL I WANTED TO
THANK FELLOW CALIFORNIANS FOR
BELIEVING IN MASKS. I THINK I'M
CURRENT NATIONAL EVENTS HAVE
REALLY SHOWN THAT MASKS TO
WORK. AND REALLY WE'RE HERE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION AND
ABLE TO DO THIS BECAUSE OF THAT
HAS CALIFORNIA PEDIATRICIANS
WE'VE ASKED THE STATE AND
DINNER OF FELLOW PARENTS AND
TEACHER COLLEAGUES TO REALLY.
IRA TIES- EARLY EDUCATION AND
YOUNG LEARNERS TO BE AN IN
PERSON IT'S GOING- PARTICULARLY
FOR OUR YOUNG LEARNERS THERE'S
LESS SERVED BY DISTANCE
LEARNING. AND MORE IMPACTED BY
DISCIPLINE LEARNING. THE IMPACT
OF COVE IT IN THE IN INTENDED
AND ATTENDANT MITIGATION. HAS
BEEN PARTICULARLY. DEVASTATING
TO A LOT OF CHILDREN- WE'RE
SEEING COMPOUNDING INEQUITY
HUNGER VIOLENCE- INCREASING
BECAUSE OF THIS THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE- THE SOCIAL ISOLATION
AND LONELINESS ON OUR TEENS. IS
JUST AS IN THE LAST COUNT TURN
INCREASING THE RISK OF
DEPRESSION ANXIETY PTSD. IT
PEDIATRICIANS- TAKE SAFETY.
VERY SERIOUSLY AND WITH THE
UTMOST CONSIDERATION OF SAFETY
OUR NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
STRONGLY RECOMMENDED. THE GOAL
OF HAVING STUDENTS PHYSICALLY
PRESENT IN SCHOOL- AS THE
PRIMARY GOAL FOR RE OPENING. IF
THE LONG IT YOU KNOW SO FOR-
OUR STATE COLLEAGUES CALIFORNIA
PEDIATRICIANS WE FURTHER STATED
THAT THE STATE AND TO SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZING OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS AND- I A DON'T SEE
HOW. T. K. AND KINDERGARTEN IN
THE REMOTE LEARNING ENVIRONMENT.
ALL SERVICE ANY OF THE
EDUCATIONAL GOALS. ANY OF THE-
TRAINING THAT TEACHERS GET TO
TEACH THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
SKILLS THAT THAT CHILDREN NEED
TO HAVE FURTHER SUCCESS IN
EDUCATION IN LIFE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION HAS BEEN
SHOWN TO IMPROVE THE LIFELONG
HEALTH- EDUCATIONALIST HAIN
MEANT- OF PLACEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. OF CHILDREN AS A
THE APPROACH ADULTHOOD- WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO MISS THESE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A GENERATION.
IN ADDITION TO YOUNG LEARNERS
WE ALSO ASK THE STATEMENT
TEACHER COLLEAGUES TO.
PRIORITIZE SPECIAL EDUCATION.
CHILDREN WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- ADHD OUR
PARTICULARLY LESS SERVED BY
DISTANCE LEARNING AS WELL AND
REALLY SHOULD BE PRIORITIZED
FOR IN PERSON LEARNING. AND AS
I SAID WE DON'T TAKE THE SAFETY
LATELY- I WANT TO GIVE SPECIAL
THANKS TO UCSF MEDICARE'S
COLLABORATIVE FUND ON
REOPENING. AND IN PARTICULAR DR
NAOMI BARDOCK BECAUSE THIS IS
BEEN. A INTELLECTUAL AND
EMOTIONAL JOURNEY. FOR
PEDIATRICIANS. WE WERE RIGHT TO
CLOSE EVERYTHING DOWN THE
BEGINNING- INCLUDING SCHOOLS-
BASED ON OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
AND FOR ONCE- YOU KNOW YOU
DON'T HAVE TO. GO VERY FAR TO
SEE CHILDREN SPREADING
INFLUENZA. BLAKELY HAD AND THEN
SOME DATASETS HALF OF. CASES OF
INFLUENCE ARE SPREAD BY YOUNG
CHILDREN. D. I DON'T NEED TO.
TELL A TEACHER OR PARENT THAT
HE WE ALL WE ALL- SEE THAT FIVE
YEAR OLD RUNNING AROUND WITH
THE RAIN KNOWS AND THEN. COMING
TO GIVE YOU A HUG AND COFFEE.
IN YOUR FACE. AND SO AS THE
DATA IS BUILT AS THE AS THE
DATE HAS COME OUT ON. OUTBREAKS
INFECTIONS- MAKES VARIANCES
WITH OTHER COUNTRIES RE OPENING
SCHOOLS BOUGHT. THE PANDEMIC.
IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT FOR
PEDIATRICIANS TO ACCEPT THAT
THE CHILDREN PARTICULARLY YOUNG
CHILDREN IN ELEMENTARY AID VERY
MUCH LESS LIKELY TO SPREAD THIS
INFECTION THERE'S EVEN CASE
REPORTS WHERE- A CHILD.
ELEMENTARY AGE CHILD COMES TO
SCHOOL EXPOSES HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE NOBODY WEARING MASKS.
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE IS
CHILD ALSO HAD INFLUENCES SIX
PEOPLE GOT INFLUENCE SIX.
ADULTS AND CHILDREN GOT
INFLUENZA NOBODY GOT COVERT WE-
HAVE SUBSEQUENTLY YOU KNOW
FOUND IT'S NOT THAT CHILDREN
DON'T GET CODE IS NOT THAT THEY
DON'T SPREAD CODED TO JUST NOT
VERY GOOD AT. AND MASKS WORK-
THE CALIFORNIA'S BEEN FANTASTIC
IN IN REALLY THE MALTA SAN
INTERVENTIONS THAT THAT HELP
PREVENT COVERED SPREAD IN
SCHOOLS IN OF MASKS SOCIAL
DISTANCING HAND HYGIENE AND
ALICIA MARKS AND SCHOOLS AND
WILL REOPEN SAFELY- WHERE. WELL
EITHER. PREVALENCE OR OR OR-
FUNDS OR NEGOTIATIONS- MAKE IT
DIFFICULT WE REALLY ENCOURAGE
THAT AT LEAST PRIORITIZE
YOUNGEST LEARNERS. DID FOR THE
KINDERGARTNERS. I SHOULD ALSO
SAY THE RIVAS HE MENTIONED- IN
IN THE PRIOR PANEL THERE IS AN
ARTICLE IN THE NEW ENGLAND
JOURNAL OF MEDICINE AND ON ON
OCTOBER TWENTY FIRST- CALL THE
MISSING PIECE I SHOULD NOTE
THAT THE AUTHOR TAKES. PERSONAL
INCOME FROM BARELY LIFE
SCIENCES WHICH IS A GOOGLE
SISTER COMPANY THAT SELLS
SURVEILLANCE TESTING TO
GOVERNMENTS. SO WITH A STRONG
RECOMMENDATION FROM. THAT
CONFLICT OF INTEREST I SHOULD
NOTE THAT BE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU OUR
FINAL SPEAKER. ED TRUST WEST.
RACHEL REPUBLICANS. OKAY. I
BELIEVE SHE'S TESTIFIED OKAY
HERE WE GO. HI GOOD AFTERNOON.
YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND BEGIN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY FOR
CALLING THIS HEARING MY NAME IS
RACHEL REFLOW AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATOR ENGAGEMENT
AT THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST AND
ALSO FORMER TEACHER SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR AND LIKE MANY OF
YOU I'M A PARENT OF. A CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THIS HAS BEEN A YEAR LIKE NO
OTHER AND IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT
SCHOOLS DISTRICTS TEACHERS AND
POLICYMAKERS ARE WORKING HARD
TO RESPONDTO THE NEEDS OF THE
MOMENT. WE AT ED TRUST WEST AND
THOSE OF US IN THE EDUCATION
EQUITY SPACE ALSO KNOW THAT
LONG BEFORE CORONAVIRUS SCHOOL
CLOSURES AND DISTANCE LEARNING
CALIFORNIA FACED AN EPIDEMIC OF
EDUCATION INEQUALITY. IT'S BEEN
A SAD REALITY THAT FOR DECADES
STUDENTS WHO NEED THE MOST
RESOURCES OFTEN GET THE LEAST.
WE GIVE STUDENTS OF COLOR AND
LOW INCOME STUDENTS THE LEAST
ACCESS TO CRITICAL COURSEWORK.
HIGHLY QUALIFIED TEACHERS
CRUCIAL TECHNOLOGY AND A HOST
OF OTHER RESOURCES. WHEN OUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DR ALCIA
SMITH ARIANNA FIRST TESTIFIED
ABOUT SCHOOL CLOSURES TO THIS
COMMITTEE IN APRIL. WE THOUGHT
SCHOOL CLOSURES WOULD BE
TEMPORARY AND FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME. AND NOW HERE WE
ARE HALFWAY THROUGH THE FALL
SEMESTER. AND BASED ON A RECENT
POLL OF K. TWELVE PARENTS BY
ADDRESS WEST WE KNOW THE
DISTANCE LEARNING IS NOT
WORKING FOR MOST FAMILIES. THE
DECISIONS THE CALIFORNIA MAKES
RIGHT NOW WILL DETERMINE HOW WE
TURN THIS CRISIS INTO AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER SERVE ALL
STUDENTS. WELL THIS HEARING IS
FOCUSED ON THE STATE'S ROLE IN
THE SAFE RE OPENING OF SCHOOLS
WE URGE THE COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALSO KEEP EQUITY
CONSIDERATIONS AT THE
FOREFRONT. AS WE PLAN FOR AND
IMPLEMENT IN PERSON AND HYBRID
INSTRUCTIONS. WE MUST REMEMBER
THAT THE BEST SOLUTIONS COME
FROM THE PEOPLE CLOSEST TO THE
PROBLEM. THAT'S WHY ADDRESS
WEST CONDUCTED A STATE WIDE
PULL ON FAMILY'S EXPERIENCES IN
APRIL AND IN OCTOBER. AND I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADD THE PERSPECTIVES OF
FAMILIES TO THIS CONVERSATION.
IN OUR OCTOBER POLL WE HEARD
THAT AT HALF WAY THROUGH THE
FALL SEMESTER PARENTS ARE NOT
FINDING DISTANCE LEARNING
SUCCESSFUL AND THERE ARE CLEAR
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AS THE SCHOOL YEAR
CONTINUOUS. ONLY 35% OF PARENTS
RATE DISTANCE LEARNING AS
SUCCESSFUL COMPARED 257% IN OUR
APRIL POLL. ADDITIONALLY LOW
INCOME PARENTS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO RATE DISTANCE LEARNING AS
UNSUCCESSFUL. STUDENTS FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE.
DISTANCE LEARNING FULL TIME
FURTHER LOW INCOME PARENTS AND
PARENTS OF COLOR ARE LESS
LIKELY TO EVEN HAVE THE OPTION
OF FULL TIME IN PERSON LEARNING
6% OF LOW INCOME PARENTS REPORT
THAT THEIR CHILD'S SCHOOL IS
OFFERING IN PERSON FULL TIME
CLASSES WHILE HIGHER INCOME
PARENTS REPORT TRIPLE THE
ACCESS AT 19% PARENTS AROUND
THE STATE ARE SAYING THAT THE
DID DIGITAL DIVIDE IS STILL A
TOP CONCERN. ALMOST HALF 44% OF
PARENTS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHETHER THEIR FAMILY WILL BE
ABLE TO AFFORD INTERNET ACCESS.
PARENTS ARE REPORTING THAT THE
PANDEMIC IN DISTANCE LEARNING
ARE CAUSING HIGHER LEVELS OF
STRESS FOR THEM AND THEIR
CHILDREN. SIX IN TEN PARENTS
SAY THEY ARE VERY CONCERNED.
ABOUT ENSURING THAT THEIR CHILD
FEEL SAFE EMOTIONALLY AT EASE
DURING THIS TIME. THIS HEARING
IS COMING AT AN OPPORTUNE TIME
THE STATE HAS A CRITICAL ROLE
TO PLAY AND HOW WE TURN THIS
CRISIS INTO AN OPPORTUNITY. WE
HAVE REACHED A POINT NEARLY
EIGHT MONTHS INTO THE PANDEMIC
WHERE WE MUST BE MORE PROACTIVE
AT MANAGING THIS EVER CHANGING
LANDSCAPE. BASED ON WHAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM FAMILIES ADDRESS
WEST HAS THREE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW THE
STATE CAN ADDRESS CHALLENGES
PRESENTED BY RE OPENING.
SCHOOLS AND HYBRID LEARNING.
NUMBER ONE. DIGITAL EQUITY
REMAINS A CRITICAL ISSUE. THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD DIRECT CD E.
TO COLLECT DATA TO DETERMINE
REMAINING DEVICE AND
CONNECTIVITY NEEDS. AND WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO MEET THIS NEED.
CITY SHOULD PROVIDE CLEAR AND
SPECIFIC GUIDANCE ON HOW
SCHOOLS AND ELEAZAR SHOULD
SUPPORT STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
IN MAKING TECHNOLOGY MORE
ACCESSIBLE. INCLUDING BY
PROVIDING TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT.
DISTANCE LEARNING AND HYBRID
LEARNING THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
SEPARATE APARTMENTS AROUND THE
AMOUNT OF ASYNCHRONOUS AND
SYNCHRONOUS INSTRUCTION FOR
DISTANCE AND HYBRID LEARNING.
AND DEFINED ATTENDANCE AND
PARTICIPATION FOR NON PUNITIVE
PURPOSES IN SETTING THESE
REQUIREMENTS THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CONSULT PARENTS STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS STAKEHOLDERS. AS
WELL AS THE MOST RELEVANT
RESEARCH ADDITIONALLY THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD DIRECT THE
FEEDING E. TO COLLECT DATA ON
INSTRUCTIONAL MODELS THAT
SCHOOLS ARE USING. INCLUDING
WHICH STUDENTS ARE BEING SERVED
BY WHICH MODELS ATTENDANCE AND
ENGAGEMENT RATES ALONG WITH
OTHER KEY DATA TO HELP GUIDE
DECISION MAKING DURING THIS
SCHOOL YEAR. THE STATE AND
LOCAL DISTRICTS NEED DATA TO
MAKE GOOD DECISIONS. FINALLY
STUDENT AND FAMILY ENGAGEMENT
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD DIRECT
CD E. AND C. C. E. TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TO EDUCATORS ON HOW
TO BEST ENGAGE FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS IN A HYBRID
ENVIRONMENT. AS WELL AS HOW TO
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT OF
HEALING AND WELLNESS TO SUPPORT
SIGNIFICANT STUDENT SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL NEEDS AT THIS TIME.
IN CLOSING WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO READ THE
FINE EDUCATION PRIORITIZE
EQUITY AND REBUILD SCHOOLS TO
BE PLACES OF HEALING THAT
NURTURE STUDENTS SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND ACADEMIC
DEVELOPMENT SO THAT ALL
STUDENTS CAN THRIVE. ACROSS ALL
EFFORTS ONE COMMONSENSE
PRINCIPLE MUST APPLY. DIRECT
THE MOST RESOURCES TO THE
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES HIT
HARDEST. ALL OF THIS WILL
REQUIRE FINANCIAL RESOURCES SO
WE WILL NEED TO LEVERAGE
FEDERAL DOLLARS AND PROTECT
STATE EDUCATION FUNDING.
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS ADDRESS
WEST IS HERE TO HELP. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. OKAY THANK YOU. I WILL
NOW GET TO QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THE NEXT
AYE PANEL AYE I DO HAVE SOME
BUT I'LL START OFF WITH OTHER
COMMITTEES MEMBERS FIRST THE
FIRST TO HEAR DR ARAMBULA NEXT
TO ME WAS TO BEGIN SHARKS
ARAMBULA MY FIRST QUESTION IS
FOR- BILL SIMMONS. YOU KNOW.
BILL UNDERSTAND YOU REPRESENT-
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND WANTED
TO SPEAK HYPOTHETICALLY ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT'S- ACTUALLY
OCCURRING IN MY BACKYARD YOU
MIGHT NOT BE AWARE ABOUT IT BUT
JUST HOPING YOU CAN SPEAK TO.
WHAT YOU WOULD RECOMMEND AS A
TEACHER OR SOMEONE WHO'S ON THE
FRONT LINES. I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF REPRESENTING
FOURTEEN CITIES WE HAVE THIRTY
PLUS DISTRICTS IN FRESNO
COUNTY. THE THREE LARGEST ONCE
DECIDED NOT TO OPEN BUT SANGER
UNIFIED AS OF LAST WEEK DID
DECIDE TO OPEN THEIR OWN
MENTERI SCHOOL. BUT THEY OPENED
WITHOUT CONSULTING THEIR
TEACHERS. AND IF YOU LOOK
TOWARDS SANGER UNIFIED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION THEY PULLED OVER
TWO HUNDRED OF THEIR MEMBERS.
OF THE TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
81% OF THEM DID NOT THINK THEY
WERE READY TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL. THEY ACTUALLY SAID THEY
FELT THAT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
WAS RUSHING. SO MY QUESTION FOR
YOU IS WHAT RECOURSE DO
TEACHERS HAVE. WHAT OPTIONS DO
THOSE WHO ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES. HAVE FOR ADVOCATING FOR
THEIR STUDENTS AND THEMSELVES
IN THE MIDST OF THIS CRISIS.
WELL AS YOU KNOW DISTRICTS CAN
HAVE THE CHOICE OF REOPENING
WE'VE BEEN FORTUNATE IN SAN
JUAN BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO- HAVE DISCUSSIONS- WITH THE
DISTRICT AND WORK TOGETHER- ON
RE OPENING SO THEY HAVE
CONSULTED US BUT IF OUR
DISTRICT WHERE TO- DECIDE TO RE
OPEN IT NEXT WEEK- OUR TEACHERS
DON'T HAVE- A LOT OF CHOICE-
THEY'RE REQUIRED IT'S PART OF
THEIR JOB TO- RETURNED TO WORK.
UNFORTUNATELY. THEY DON'T FEEL
SAFE- IF THEY DON'T THINK ALL
THE SAFETY MEASURES ARE IN
PLACE AND- AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER. THE NEED FOR TESTING
SO THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND- THAT
THEY THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY ARE FEET THAT THEY WOULD
FEEL SAFE- IS VERY IMPORTANT.
YOU KNOW I WILL JUST- SAY
EARLIER YOU HAD SAID THAT WE
NEED TO PROVIDE GUIDELINES
WITHOUT GETTING INTO THE
DETAILS AND- WHILE I AGREE WITH
THAT- IN PRINCIPLE AND IN THIS
CASE AS WELL. I WOULD BE
CONCERNED TOWARDS WHAT TO OUR
CHAIRWOMAN OF APPROPRIATIONS
DESCRIBED AS A POTENTIAL FOR
THE WILD WEST. I THINK YOU HAVE
TO LISTEN TO THOSE WHO ARE IN
THE CLASSROOMS I THINK YOU HAVE
TO LISTEN TO THE TEACHERS I
THINK WE MUST. LISTEN TO THEM
FOR US TO DELIVER A GOOD
PRODUCT AND SO WHILE I HEAR YOU
SAYING THAT TEACHERS DON'T HAVE
A DIRECT LINE OF INPUT I THINK
THEY SHOULD. AND I THINK WE
NEED TO BE INCLUSIVE OF THEIR
OPINION IN ALL DECISIONS THAT
WE'RE MAKING REGARDING STUDENTS
THEY ARE GREAT ADVOCATES FOR
CHILDREN AND I. STRONGLY
BELIEVE WE NEED TO DO MORE TO
ENCOURAGE THEIR PARTICIPATION
IN THESE DISCUSSIONS THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU. A DOLLAR
SCANDALOUS. SERVICE GONZALEZ M.
VETERANS I GUESS I ASK A NUMBER
OF YOU AS WORK WERE IT SEEMS AS
FAR LOWER INCOME STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR RETURNS IN
PERSON- WHAT IF ANYTHING CAN WE
DO ABOUT THAT I THINK. I COULD
ASK PAUL FROM. THAT COUNTY
BOARD I'M SORRY OF MY AS COUNTY
SUPER. YES OR AS MISS REPORT
FROM AND TRY WELL WHAT WHAT.
WHY IS THE REASONING IS THE
SCHOOL AREN'T RE OPENING WITH
HAVE ENOUGH TO RIO OR IS THERE
ARE. A NUMBER OF THESE
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE FEELING
MORE AND SAFE TO SEND CHILDREN
BACK. AND WHAT CAN WE DO TO
SUPPORT THEM MORE WE NEED TO.
SUPPORT THEM MORE. HELLO THIS
IS RACHEL REFLOW- THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION I THINK THIS IS
WHERE THE LACK OF DATA IS
REALLY CHALLENGING BECAUSE IT
IS DIFFICULT TO KNOW EXACTLY.
WHICH FAMILIES ARE- HAVING
WHICH OPTIONS AND MAKING WHICH
CHOICES ON A STATEWIDE BASIS
WHAT WE DO KNOW FROM OUR POLL
IS THAT LOW INCOME FAMILIES ARE
REPORTING THAT THEY ARE NOT
HAVING THE OPTION ON THERE. THE
REPORTING THAT THERE OPTION IS
AT A MUCH LOWER RATE THAN
HIGHER INCOME FAMILIES. AND SO
WE CAN PROBABLY DRIVE FROM THAT
THAT- COMMUNITIES THAT SERVE-
SCHOOLS THAT SERVE LOW INCOME
FAMILIES ARE PERHAPS NOT
OPENING UP AT THE SAME RATE AS
MORE A- MORE RESOURCE
COMMUNITIES I THINK IT WOULD
ALSO BE IMPORTANT TO COLLECT
DATA ON. WHEN SCHOOLS ARE
PROVIDING PARENTS WITH AN
OPTION TO RETURN TO A HYBRID OR
IN PERSON AND FAMILIES ARE
CHOOSING TO STAY IN EXTENDED
DISTANCE LEARNING WHAT THE
REASONS ARE FOR THAT DECISION.
IS IT AN ISSUE OF
TRANSPORTATION IS THAT AN ISSUE
OF CHILD CARE BASED ON THE
HYBRID SCHEDULE IS IT AN ISSUE
OF CONCERN- FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF EITHER THE CHILD OR
FAMILY MEMBERS- THE STATE WILL
BE REALLY IMPORTANT TO THEN BE
ABLE TO ANSWER. THE QUESTION
THAT YOU'RE ASKING IS WHAT TO
DO ABOUT IT- AND SO WITHOUT
THAT DATA IT'S CHALLENGING BUT
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT- DISTRICTS
COLLECT THIS DATA SO THAT THEY
CAN MAKE THE APPROPRIATE.
ACCOMMODATIONS TO SUPPORT ALL
FAMILIES TO HAVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO HYBRID OR IN PERSON
LEARNING- AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL RECOMMENDED THAT THERE BE
SPECIFIC GUIDANCE THAT IS
REQUIRING LOCALS A LOCAL
DISTRICTS TO COLLECT. THIS DATA.
THANK YOU. THANK I WANT TO GO
BACK TO THE TO OUR
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE SANTA
TEACHER ASSOC MISTER SIMMONS.
HI BILL YES SIR BILL SUFFERS
WAS TO NOTE THAT- UP MY COLOR
OVER HERE ASKED WHERE IS SAN
JUAN TO SAN JUAN IS ABOUT FIVE
MILES TO THE EAST OF HERE. IT
IS IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY IT'S
AND VERY YEAH I THINK NOT
STEINORTH. FIVE SEVENTY FIVE
SQUARE. OF THE EASTERN HALF OF-
SACRAMENTO COUNTY YES AND MY
QUESTION TO YOU FIRST OF ALL IS
WHAT SCHOOL DO YOU TEACH FOR
SIXTH GRADE. WELL CURRENTLY I'M
NOT IN THE CLASSROOM I THE
LAST- SCHOOL THAT I TAUGHT AT
WITH- WITH SIDE- WHICH IS THE
K. EIGHT IN CITRUS HEIGHTS OKAY
I MENTION THAT BECAUSE I AM A
PRODUCT OF THE- SAN JUAN SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I. I ATTENDED
CAMERON RANCH ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
ALONG TO A LONG TIME AGO.
TRAFFIC SCHOOL YES THANK YOU I
WANT TO TALK MOREABOUT WHAT
YOU WERE THAT BACK AND FORTH
WITH. DOCTOR RAMBLE UP ON AND
YOU KNOW THAT THEIR NEEDS AND
THE REQUESTED AND FRANKLY
REASONABLE REQUESTS AND
COMMONSENSE REQUEST FROM. OUR
TEACHERS AND FRANKLY OUR
COMMUNITY AS AS FAR AS THE RE
OPENING AND TESTING AND CONTACT
TRACING AND SO FORTH. SO AND I
AM A LITTLE BIT CONFUSED
BECAUSE A FEW WEEKS AGO I SAW
THERE THERE READ THE-
SUGGESTION BITER STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION AND I KNOW WE HAVE
MULTIPLE CHAPTERS AND- AS FAR
AS THE ASK THAT HAVING A
VACCINE IN PLACE BEFORE. RE
OPENING I DIDN'T HEAR YOU SAY
THAT TODAY AND SO I JUST WANT
YOU CAN CAN YOU CAN CLARIFY FOR
THE RECORD AS FAR AS- WHAT IS
FROM OUR CLASSROOM TEACHERS
AROUND THE STATE. WHAT WHAT
WHAT IS THE REQUEST FROM
CALIFORNIA AS FAR AS HAVING A
VACCINE IN PLACE AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR ITS
UTILIZATION FOR OUR SCHOOLS
BEFORE WE HAVE RE OPENING. WELL
I ONLY REPRESENT TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED TEACHERS AND I CAN'T
REPRESENT ALL TEACHERS BECAUSE-
THERE ARE TEACHERS THAT WOULD
COME BACK- TODAY IF PROPER
SAFETY MEASURES WERE IN PLACE-
BUT THERE ARE MANY TEACHERS
THAT ARE FEARFUL AND WOULD
WANT- HAVE A VACCINE IN PLACE-
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT COMING BACK IN A
HYBRID MODEL WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE FACT THAT STUDENTS- I'VE
GONE AND LOOKED AT OTHER HYBID
MODELS AND THOSE STUDENTS IN
OTHER DISTRICTS ARE ACTUALLY.
SEEING THEIR TEACHER LAST. HI
THEN ARE TEACHERS CURRENT. ARE
SOME IN THE DEATH ONE MODEL YOU
THOUGH IT'S OVER THERE. AT AND
IT'S A LITTLE I. FOR ME TO BE
SITTING HERE IN A ROOM- AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE STATE CAPITOL- BY
MYSELF. WITH WITH A SECURITY
GUARD HERE AND- EVERYONE ELSE-
DOING THIS VIRTUALLY WITH
MARATHON YET WE EXPECT OUR
SCHOOLS TO OPEN UP AND- HAVE
OUR STUDENTS IN PLACE. AND IT
IT JUST IS A LITTLE IRONIC THAT
THAT IS THE CASE I MEAN IF YOU
CAN'T HAVE ME IN THE SAME ROOM
WITH THIS WITH YOUR COMMITTEE I
N. OF FIVE PEOPLE. WHAT HOW WHY
WOULD IT WHY WOULD YOU THINK
THAT- YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
BRING STUDENTS BACK INTO A
CLASSROOM SO- HAVING THE
GUIDELINES- THAT ARE CLEAR AND
NOT CONSTANTLY CHANGING. WOULD
BE HELPFUL AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS PANDEMIC IS CHANGING
RAPIDLY BUT IT'S MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO MAKE PLANS UNDER
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES HAVING
TESTING AVAILABLE SO PEOPLE
FEEL CONFIDENT. THAT PEOPLE ARE
COMING INTO THE SCHOOLS AND
THEY'RE SAFE- WOULD BE HELPFUL.
ANDPROVIDING ALL OF THE-
FUNDING SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT THE SCHOOLS ARE ALL.
CLEAN AND WE HAVE ALL THE
PROPER PP THAT'S WHAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. OKAY THANK YOU SO YOU
ARE OF COURSE A DISTRICT OF
FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THERE
ARE SIX MILLION FORTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS THERE ARE SIX MILLION
KIDS IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND
SO THAT THE SNAPSHOT OF A
LARGER LARGER SNAPSHOT. SO YOUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT- RECENTLY VOTED
TO RE OPEN ON THE FIFTH OF JUNE
OF JANUARY AND THE I GUESS THE
BOARD VOTED ON AND I ASSUME
THAT THE TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WAS PART OF THAT EQUATION SO
WHAT ARE YOU DOING A YEAR
DISTRICT AS FAR AS A TESTING
AND IS THAT MEET. YOUR YOUR-
HAD A COMFORT LEVEL FOR YOUR
TEACHERS IN YOUR DISTRICT. WELL
ACTUALLY HAVE NOT- BEEN ABLE TO
UNDERGO. WITH THE DESK TESTING
PER. RIGHT NOW THE GUIDELINES
ARE THAT EVERY- EVERY STAFF
MEMBER BE TESTED EVERY WEEK.
WHICH WOULD MEAN ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PEOPLE A WEEK
WOULD BE TESTED. I DON'T
BELIEVE RIGHT NOW THE DISTRICT
HAS SIX HUNDRED FIFTY TESTS
AVAILABLE- AND THEY'RE TALKING
TO US ABOUT- HAVING. OUR
MEMBERS GO TO COUNTY TESTING
SITE THERE'S NOT ONE TESTING
SITE THAT'S WITHIN OUR DISTRICT
NEAR MANY OF OUR SCHOOLS RIGHT
NOW IN THE COUNTY. AND SO- THAT
PUTS THE BURDEN ON THE- STAFF
PERSON SO WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
NEGOTIATED THAT YET BECAUSE
TESTING STILL SEEMS TO BE THE%
BIGGEST CHALLENGE BECAUSE THE
AVAILABILITY OF TEST R. R. M.
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE. SELL IT
TO WRAP THAT UP FOR YOU
FIRSTHAND WHY AND YOU'RE STILL
WELL THERE HAVE A REOPEN DATE
YOU'RE STILL NEGOTIATING WITH
THE WITH YOUR DISTRICT ON
SATISFACTORY PROTOCOLS FOR
TESTING AND I WOULD ASSUME
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING FOR
TEACHERS ACROSS THE STATE. ALL
RIGHT I WOULD ASSUME THAT ALSO
AND- WE ARE. WEARE ON. RE
OPENING WE HAVE FACED THEN ARE
RE OPENING SO WE WELL- WE HAVE
ALREADY STARTED WITH- ONE ON
ONE ASSESSMENT AT SCHOOL SITE
AND AS I MENTIONED NEXT WEEK WE
ARE RE OPENING FOR SMALL
COHORTS OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS AND WE ARE WORKING-
TO- HOPEFULLY REOPEN SMALL
COHORTS OF YALE STUDENTS PRIOR
TO JANUARY- BUT- THE LOGISTICS
OF RE OPENING A SCHOOL DISTRICT
WITH SIXTY FOUR SITE. IN. FORTY
THOUSAND IS FAIRLY MONUMENTAL
YEAH AND WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
THAT YOU KNOW THE PARENTS IN
THE DISTRICT WHO SAY WE'RE
STILL WORKING ON IT BUT WE'VE
BEEN AT THIS FOR EIGHT MONTHS
AND YOU KNOW KIDS AS DR
ARAMBULA NOTED IN DISTANCE
LEARNING ARE HAVING A TOUGH
TIME I KNOW MY OWN KIDS IN A
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE AS
WELL AND SO YOU KNOW WE'RE
TRYING WE DON'T LET THE PERFECT
BE THE ENEMY IN THE GOOD. OF
THE ENEMY OF THE GOOD AND YOU
KNOW WE'RE STILL OF COURSE
MONITORING WHAT LEVEL WERE AT
AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN THE RED
WHICH ALLOWS IT I KNOW ONE
DISTRICT IS HOPING TO GET THE
ORANGE BEFORE THEY CAN BUT THE
RED THEY CAN OPEN OUR STANDING
AND SO WHAT DO WE SAY TO THE
FAMILIES WHO ARE LIKE HEY
PEOPLE ADULTS WE'VE HAD. SIX
SURPLUS MONTHS TO GET TO GET IT
RIGHT AND TO SAY WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT IS
UNACCEPTABLE I AYE AYE WHICH.
THE GUEST THAT YOU HAVE HEALTH
OFFICIALS THAT CAN ANSWER
QUESTION. AS AND YOU HAVE.
OFFICIALS STATE. THAT HAVE
CHANGED GUIDELINES ON US.
SOMETIMES THREE TIMES IN A WEEK
AND YOU'RE ASKING THE LOCAL
DISTRICT AND LOCAL TEACHERS
ABOUT WHY WE'RE NOT OPEN. THIS
IS A PANDEMIC. THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED A HUNDRED OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS. SO WE WANT TO BE
WITH OUR STUDENTS THAT'S OUR
PREFERENCE. OUR TEACHERS ARE
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
DISTANCE LEARNING TO INTERACT
WITH THE STUDENTS IN A POSITIVE
WAY. BUT THE CHALLENGES THAT
THIS IS A PANDEMIC AND PEOPLE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND. THAT
EVERYONE NEEDS TO BE SAFE. WE
HAVE SCHOOLS IN OTHER STATE OF
ARIZONA HAD A- MIDDLE SCHOOL
THAT THEY HAD TO CLOSE DOWN
JUST YESTERDAY OR THE DAY
BEFORE. BECAUSE THEY HAD
SEVERAL CASES THERE SO EVERY
TIME OUR TEACHERS. AND OUR
FAMILIES HERE ABOUT THIS THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE MORE STUDENTS
MOVING TO HOME SCHOOL. BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE STILL NOT FEELING SO.
IN THIS FANDOM. OKAY THANK YOU
FURTHER QUESTIONS YES MR DAHLE
I JUST A COMMENT I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR REPRESENTING THE
TEACHERS AS A TEACHER- I
APPRECIATE YOUR VOICE IN THIS
CONVERSATION AND YOU YOUR POINT
THAT SHE WERE EXPECTING
STUDENTS TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL
YET WE WON'T EVEN LET PEOPLE
WALK INTO THIS ROOM AND SPEAK
TO US FROM FIFTEEN FEET AWAY AS
A VERY VALID POINT IT IS A VERY
VERY VALID POINT SO THANK YOU
FOR DOING THAT. AND I JUST
SPEAK FROM MY OWN EXPERIENCE I
USUALLY STOP IN THE FALL OF ONE
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME I
CAN'T ACT I'M NOT DOING IT NOW
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO GET ON
THE SOON THING I DON'T KNOW
WELL ENOUGH. SO I'M NOT DOING
THAT NOW BUT I DID HAVE A
CHANCE TO THAT IT IS SPEAK MY
DAUGHTER'S GOVERNMENT CLASS-
HER HIGH SCHOOL GOVERNMENT
CLASS AND I TAKE A FROM A
TEACHER'S PERSPECTIVE IT WILL
FIVE TO NO I WAS LOOKING AT THE
KIDS THEY WERE TALKING TO ME
AND ASKING ME SOME QUESTIONS IT
IS INTERESTING WHEN YOU'RE
BEHIND THAT. SCREEN YOU'RE
LOOKING INTO STUDENTS HOMES.
WHICH YOU NEED TO REALIZE
THERE'S JUST. I GUESS BUT ALSO
THAT THEY ARE. AND THEY'RE HOME.
AND STUDENTS DIFFERING LIVING
SITUATIONS I SAW THAT. I
BLATANTLY THERE SENT AND
BACKGROUND ETCETERA TO MATCH
WHEN YOU. YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
OTHER OTHER BROTHERS AND
SISTERS AT HOME OR OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS ETCETERA. SO THIS IS
JUST A VERY VERY DIFFICULT
ENVIRONMENT. AND I HAVE A LOT
OF TEACHER FRIENDS WHO- THE
WORKING VERY HARD JUST TO LEARN
THE TECHNOLOGY. AND ONE THING%
WE HAVEN'T DONE ONE ON
CALIFORNIA'S PREPARING FOR
ONLINE LEARNING GOING FORWARD I
THINK IT'LL BE SOME COMPONENT
OF IT GOING FORWARD. BUT
MINUTES DURING THE SCHOOL DAY
COULD BE AFTER THE SCHOOL THEIR
CENTER. BUT WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT THE PLATFORM'S TEACHERS AGO
BEGAN TO REALIZE TEACHER OPEN
AN EMAIL. OKAY THEN OPEN HILL
FROM THE SA HIM HIT IT IN A
WORD DOC. AND THEN HAVE TO
GRADE IT GOING TO ANOTHER
DOCUMENT THEN PUT IT INTO
ANOTHER YOU KNOW PUT IT IN A
GREAT BOOK. AND MAYBE MAKE SOME
OTHER COMMENTS ON THIS THEY CAN
BE OPERATING WITHIN THREE FOUR
FIVE PLATFORMS. YOU KNOW OVER
ONE ESSAY I THINK OF THE TIME
ASSOCIATED. IF YOU'VE GOT
THIRTY FIVE STUDENTS YOU GOT
THIRTY FIVE EIGHTH GRADE ESSAYS
THAT HAVE TO BE GRADED. THINK
OF THE TIME ASSOCIATED. JUST
NOT EVEN IT NOT NOT EVEN YOU
KNOW. JUST GRADING THE S. BUT
JUST LOGISTICS. WITH GRAY IT.
GETTING THROUGH ALL PLOT SO IT
IS HURRICANE. SO I JUST WANT
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU. REALLY
TO THE TEACHERS A CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. I THINK THAT HE-
THANK YOU FOR THAT RE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF DONALD JUST BEFORE I
LEFT HERE I HEARD. MRS GROUP.
TEACHING OUR OUR KIDS IN THEIR
VERGE CLASS THERE IS A- CLASS
OF THEIR SIXTY KIDS. ON ON
ZERO. SHE WAS TALK TO THE TWO
COHORTS OF THE SAME TIME AND SO.
OUR TEACHERS ARE WORK OVER. AND
WE'RE YOU KNOW GRATEFUL FOR IT
FOR THE ALL ACROSS. THAT'S WITH
THAT THANK YOU FOR THE PARTY.
IS LAST X. HELP FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY. WE'RE
LAWMAKERS AND WE'RE GONNA GET
RIGHT BACK AT IT IN A NUMBER OF
WEEKS AND- POTENTIALLY WILL
HAVE A FUSION. OF FEDERAL
MONEY- WITH IT WITHIN A SECOND
ROUND OF A CLUB NINETEEN.
CONGRESSIONAL ACTION- WE'RE
WHAT MONITORING THESE ELECTIONS
OF COURSE WITHIN A WEEK AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW. DETERMINES
WHETHER OR NOT RATES GOING TO
HAPPEN OR NOT BUT- HOPEFULLY
WE'LL GET BACK AT IT AND
ADDRESSES ISSUES AS WE CAN FROM
THE STATE LEVEL AND THAT WAS.
THE PERSPECTIVE OF TODAY'S
HEARING- SO WITH THAT WE DO
HAVE THREE PEOPLE THAT WISH TO
PARTICIPATE DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD. WE HAVE ONE
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO A TWO.
WE HAVE ONE I BELIEVE IN THE
NORTH STEPS OUTSIDE THE CAPITAL
AND ONE REMOTELY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO SO- ACTUALLY WAS
WE'LL SEE WE'LL SEE RIGHT HERE
THE NORTH STEPS YOU READY TO
GO. SO WHAT LET'S START WITH
YOU PLACE. ALL RIGHT NOW. FIND
IN THANK MY NAME IS PATRICK
BANKER WHO LIVE IN SO. I SHOULD
SAY HOW. HOW PROUD I AM OF THE
WORK THEY ALL DO IN THE COURAGE
AND FAR ALL HAVING HEARTS. AND
I SAW APPRECIATE THE POLICE.
AND HELL COURAGEOUS THEY ARE.
AND I'M NOT AND I APPRECIATE
ALL THAT I REPRESENT IS THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR IN OUR TOWN AND- IN
A COUNTRY. HE EARNED. I KNOW
THERE'S DIFFICULT TIMES GOING
ON FOR ALL OF US IN OUR TOWN
IT'S- AND IT'S DIFFICULT FOR
ALL OF US. I WAS IN A- HOUSE IN
FAIR OAKS. MAIENSCHEIN AND I
HAD MY GUITAR WITH ME I WAS
WALKING DOWN THE STREET AND I
SAW FAMILY OUT IN THE FRONT
YARD A FATHER AND A MOTHER AND
HER THREE LITTLE GIRLS. AND ASK
ME IF I PLAY A SONG. AND I SANG
A SONG BY A- STAFF SERGEANT
MILLS. OF EIGHTY SECOND
AIRBORNE DIVISION. YEAH IT'S
CALLED BORN IN A SMALL TOWN
UNDERSTAND. AND GOT HIS BUT-
I'M ABOUT I LOVE HER FAMILY CAN
COUNTRY IT'S- AND A- IT HAS
MADE ME REALIZE THAT
EVERYBODY'S HAVING AHARD TIME
AND I TOLD THE FATHER NINE AND
I'M GONNA TELL YOU ALL THE SAME
THING AND I HOPE THAT ALL THE
POLICEMEN HERE AS WELL. YOU
KNOW THE FATHER'S IN TOWN THAT
YADIRA GOOD JOB. AND ON. HI
MARIA AND I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
DO. I WOULD LIKE TO GET BACK TO
SCHOOL MY BETTER BEEN DIFFICULT
BECAUSE BEEN A SOME KIND OF
REASON WHY HOW BEEN GETTING
HARD TIME FROM AND I THINK I
MIGHT HAVE TO DO WITH A-
SOMETHING. CALLED A
BIOTECHNOLOGY HANNAH AYE
CERTAINLY. I CERTAINLY SHOULD
SAY THAT A. I DON'T KNOW AS
MUCH AS THEY ALL DO AND- IT'S
DIFFICULT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I'M
TRYING TO HAVE COMPASSION AS
MUCH AS I CAN FOR EVERYBODY.
BUT I WAS GETTING A HARD TIME
EVEN ON THE WAY HERE. AND I AM
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO STAND UP
FOR WHAT'S RIGHT AND- TWO GUYS
CAME OUT OF A CAR YESTERDAY OR
DAY BEFORE THAT TRIED TO TASER
ME AND. THERE'S BEEN PEOPLE
HAVE BROKEN MY APARTMENTS YOU
KNOW. USE MY USE MY AN STAFF
AND TRY TO PUT CHEMICALS ON MY
VEHICLE AND- ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT I YOU KNOW I
HAVEN'T DESERVE HAVING DONE
ANYTHING ANYBODY I'M I'M- I'M
SERVICE CERTAIN OMINOUS ADVANCE
BUT ON. I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
WHOEVER HIS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THIS. I JUST WANNA SAY THAT
I'M- I'M NOT MAD AT YOU. I
THINK IT PROBABLY DECENT PERSON.
I JUST THINK THAT HOPEFULLY WE
CAN UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER YEAH
AND I JUST THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ALL THE SOMETIMES
TO ASK. EACH OTHER. AND I'D
LIKE TO ASK THEM AND EVERYONE
ELSE WHO MIGHT BE LISTENING.
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO ASK YOU WHAT IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS YOU HAVE
LEARNED SO FAR ABOUT HOW TO
LIVE LIFE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR- AND WHAT IS
SACRED TO YOU. AND WHAT THE FAA
IN. THE ONLY PARTY THAT GOD
MADE THANK YOU YOU FOR YOUR AT
NEXT WE HAVE. THE WOMAN IN THE
WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE YOU
CAN COME UP TO. MY GET READY
THE WIRE COMING UP WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE-
INDIVIDUAL IN SAN FRANCISCO
PLEASE PRESS. THREE HELLO. I'M
WILL PERISH FOUNDER OF TEN
STRANDS AN EDUCATIONAL
NONPROFIT THAT IS ADVANCING
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY. IN
CALIFORNIA'S K. TWELVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. I'M HERE TODAY TO
REQUEST THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT SCHOOLS AND UTILIZING
THE OUTDOORS SO MORE STUDENTS
CAN SAFELY RETURN TO SCHOOL. WE
KNOW THE PANDEMIC IS CAUSING
STRESS TRAUMA AND SOCIAL
ISOLATION. IT'S ALSO CREATING
DEVASTATING LEARNING LOSS THAT
EXPANDS THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS STILL DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED INTERNET.
SIX HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
STILL DON'T HAVE A COMPUTER OR
OTHER DEVICE. THE MAJORITY OUR
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND THOSE
FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
CLOSURES EXACERBATE
INEQUALITIES VULNERABLE
STUDENTS FACE EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THE USE OF OUTDOOR SPACES IS AN
EQUITABLE COST EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY TO MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS WHO CAN SAFELY
RETURN TO CAMPUS WHILE
FOLLOWING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
MEASURES. THAT'S WHY TEN
STRANDS AND OUR PARTNERS GREEN
SCHOOLYARDS AMERICA SAN MATTEO
COE AND UC BERKELEY'S LAWRENCE
HALL OF SCIENCE FOUNDED THE
NATIONAL COVE ED NINETEEN
OUTDOOR LEARNING INITIATIVE.
SINCE MAY MORE THAN A HUNDRED
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS AND
VOLUNTEERS HAVE JOINED AND ARE
HELPING SCHOOLS REOPEN SAFELY
AND EQUITABLY USING OUTDOOR
SPACES. AB THREE BENEFITS ABOUT
OUR LEARNING OUR WELL BEING
OUTDOORS GREATLY REDUCES THE
RISK OF VIRUS TRANSMISSION.
EXPOSURE TO NATURE IMPROVES
MENTAL HEALTH BY REDUCING
STRESS AND RESTORING THE
ABILITY TO PAY ATTENTION.
STUDENTS CONNECT WITH THEIR
ENVIRONMENT AND WANT TO BECOME
STEWARDS. OUTDOOR LEARNING
WORKS IN MANY SCHOOL PROGRAMS
CORE CURRICULUM LIKE SCIENCE
AND HISTORY LIBRARY ART MUSIC
GARDEN AND OF COURSE
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION. P. AND
RECESS LUNCH AND OTHER MEALS
BEFORE AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. OUTDOOR LEARNING IS A
SUCCESSFUL STRATEGY TO RE OPEN
SCHOOLS SAFELY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. OKAY OUR FINAL SPEAKER
FORTY TWO TO PLEASE BE IN. I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I CAN BE
HEARD AND I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU DON'T
PAY ATTENTION TO YOUR DEVICES
THE WAY YOU ARE PAYING
ATTENTION TO YOUR DEVICES WITH
THE LAST TWO SPEAKERS GOOD I
HAVE EYE CONTACT. MY NAME IS
SANDRA HAD STRUM. AND I'M
MARRIED TO A SAN JUAN PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER HE WAS IN THE
SENATE YESTERDAY WITH ME IN A
SIMILAR HEARING AND HE WASN'T
ABLE TO GIVE HIS PUBLIC
COMMENTS. BECAUSE HE HAD TO
LEAVE AFTER WAITING FOR THREE
HOURS I'M BACK TODAY WITH THE
SAME COMMENT THAT HE HAD
WRITTEN THAT I WASN'T ALLOWED
TO READ ON HIS BEHALF KEVIN
MCCARTY I'M GLAD THAT SCREEN IS
SO INTERESTING TO YOU FAR MORE
INTERESTING THAN THE PERSON
STANDING BEFORE YOU. AND THIS
PROVES MY POINT THE SCREENS
AREN'T WORKING. THEY'RE HURTING
THE CHILDREN. MY HUSBAND IS NOT
IN AGREEMENT WITH BILL SIMMONS
BILL SIMMONS MAY THINK HE
REPRESENTS ALL SAN JUAN
TEACHERS BUT HE DOES NOT. MY
HUSBAND TEACHES KINDERGARTEN IN
THE SAN JUAN SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND HE IS NOT IN SUPPORT OF
THESE LOCKDOWNS HE NEVER HAS
BEEN IN SUPPORT OF THESE
LOCKDOWNS HE IS NOT IN SUPPORT
OF MASKING CHILDREN. AND WE ARE
ALSO THE PARENTS OF FOUR
CHILDREN THREE OF WHOM ARE
BEING ZOOM SCHOOLED CURRENTLY
IN THE SAN JUAN SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND DESPITE WHAT YOUR EXPERTS
AS THEY WILL NOT BE RETURNING
TO A MASKED ENVIRONMENT NOT
BECAUSE WE'RE FEARFUL OF THE
COATED. THE COVE AND THAT HAS A
99% RECOVERY RATE THAT THE CDC
IS NO LONGER CALLING A PANDEMIC
BUT BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT YOU
LEGISLATORS ARE UP TO AND YOUR
LITTLE GAME. FROM SELLING OUR
CHILDREN TO PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES LOADING THEM UP WITH
VACCINES THAT PARENTS DON'T
WANT TO SELLING THEM TO TACK
MAKING MONEY AT THEIR EXPENSE
YEAH FIFTY YOU SHOULD ALL BE
ASHAMED OF YOURSELVES. YOUR
LITTLE GAME IS OVER THE PARENTS
ARE DONE AND YOUR GOING TO NEED
TO FIND OTHER WAYS TO FUND YOUR
CRIMES THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. OKAY WITH THAT
NO MORE PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND WE
WILL ADJOURN TODAY'S HEARING
THANK YOU.